ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible] FOR JUST.
BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
THE RUSSELL.
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG HILL.
HUESO -- TITLE.
JACKSON.
JONES LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
I'M BURKE Y. CASKEY WIENER WILK.
THANK YOU SIR.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS OF OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LED IMPAIR THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN.
ASSUME A CADA EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS SACRAMENTO VALLEY
OFFICE AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING A WE LED IN THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE BUT CENTER
ARCHULETA.
LET US PRAY.
THE NAME OF GOD.
THE COMPASSIONATE THE MERCIFUL.
ARE SUSTAINER OUR GUIDE EVER
PRESENT NEVER ON AWARE.
IN PHILLY ABLE.
YOUR SERVANTS IN YOUR LOVING
CARE.
GUIDE US TO PURE CONVICTIONS
THAT INSPIRE US IN THE COURAGE
TO MATCH THOSE CONVICTIONS.
WE PRAY FOR PEACE NOT WAR.
LOVE NOTHATE BENEVOLENCE NOT
AGREED.
UNITY NOT DIVISION WE COMMIT
OURSELVES TO NUMBER TRYING OUR
PRAYERS WITH ACTIONS THAT
CONTRADICT THEM.
LET US BE FOR TRUTH NO MATTER
WHO OR FOR ITS AGAINST AND
JUSTICE NO MATTER WHO WERE FOR
IT IS AGAINST AND HOPE NO MATTER
WHAT OFFICE WAS LIE AHEAD.
FILL OUR HEARTS MINDS AND SOULS
WITH TRUE LOVE AND COMPASSION
FOR THE PEOPLE WE SERVE.
WE HAVE TO PROTECT US AND GRANT
OUR FAMILIES LOVED ONES AND
THOSE WHO LOVE US AND THOSE WHO
DO NOT.
AND THOSE WHO DO NOT KNOW LOVE
LOVE.
GUIDE THE DELIBERATIONS OF THE
MEMBERS OF THIS CHAMBER TO JUST
DECISIONS AND GOT OUR STATE AND
NATION TO THE BOAT OF
RECONCILIATION.
MAYBE HONOR ONE ANOTHER.
GLORIFIED YOU TOGETHER AND
INSPIRE THE WORLD TO BE BETTER.
WITH THIS WE HAVE TO ACCEPT THIS
PRAYER FOR US FOR YOU ARE THE
MOST MERCIFUL WHO ACCEPTS
PRAYERS.
AMEN.
COLLEGE WOULD YOU PUT YOUR HAND
OVER YOUR HEART HAS WE
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR MEN AND WOMEN
WHO SERVE THIS GREAT COUNTRY.
AND ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO GAVE
THEIR LIVES FOR OUR COUNTRY THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED [inaudible]
IS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS I HOPE
EVERYONE HAD A PRODUCTIVE
WEEKEND.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS O COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE PROVISIONS
OF SENATE RULE FORTY FOUR WILL
BE AFFORDED TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE CONFEREES FOR THIS
WEEK.
MEMBERS WILL MOVE TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
STARTING WITH THE SECOND READING
FILE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL.
FIVE SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY TWO
SIX THIRTY EIGHT SIX FIFTY SIX
THREE TWENTY THREE SEVEN SEVENTY
TWO FIVE THIRTY FOUR SEVEN
FOURTEEN SENATE BILL.
SIX SIXTEEN THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY THE SCENE THE SECOND
READING FOR I WILL BE DEEMED
READ MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA START
WITH SENATE THIRD READING.
WE'RE STARTING WITH FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
FOURTEEN SENATOR ALLEN.
NOT AT HIS DESK.
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE SENATOR
JACKSON ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE
UP.
VERY GOOD MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOR SIXTY A SENATOR
JACKSON AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION.
SENATOR JACKSON'S GOOD -- GOOD.
AFTERNOON MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES.
THIS MEASURE SB FOUR SIXTY EIGHT
IS A GOOD GOVERNMENT MEASURE.
THAT WILL HELP US IMPROVE OUR
SYSTEM OF TAX EXPENDITURES. TO
ENSURE WE MAKE THE BEST USE OF
OUR LIMITED PUBLIC DOLLARS.
CALIFORNIA HAS CREATED.
AND PASSED NEARLY [inaudible]
EIGHTY TAX EXPENDITURES.
THESE ARE PROVISIONS IN THE TAX
CODE THEY INCLUDE TAX CREDITS
TAX DEDUCTIONS SALES TAX
EXEMPTIONS AND INCOME EXCLUSIONS
THAT REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TAX
COLLECTED.
FROM A PARTICULAR INDUSTRY OR
SECTOR IN EXCHANGE FOR AN
INTENDED PUBLIC POLICY
OBJECTIVES.
HOW MANY TAX EXPENDITURES WERE
CREATED DECADES AGO?
AS FAR BACK AS THE NINETEEN
FORTIES.
THEY WERE DESIGNED TO ACHIEVE
CERTAIN GOALS SUCH AS IMPROVING
INDUSTRY COMPETITIVENESS
INFLUENCING TAXPAYER BEHAVIOR.
OR SPURRING ECONOMIC GROWTH ALL
OF WHICH ARE VERY SHOWN THE
INAPPROPRIATE IN WORTHY GOALS.
BUT THEY HAVE SAT ON THE BOOKS
FOR DECADES WITHOUT ANY SCRUTINY
WITHOUT ANY OVERSIGHT AND
WITHOUT EVEN ANY DATA TO
DEMONSTRATE THE RESULTS THAT
THEIR CONTINUED EFFECTIVENESS OR
RELEVANCE.
EXISTS TODAY.
THESE TAX EXPENDITURES KERRY
SIGNIFICANT COSTS TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN THE SAME MANNER
AS OUR SPENDING PROGRAMS.
THIS YEAR TAX EXPENDITURES WILL
REDUCE REVENUES IN THIS TO US
STATE IN OUR GENERAL FUND BY
SOME SIXTY SIX BILLION DOLLARS.
EVERY DOLLAR OFA TAX
EXPENDITURE THAT DOES NOT
GENERATE ITS COST IN NEW REVENUE
TAKES APPROXIMATELY FORTY CENTS
OUT OF CALIFORNIA'S CLASSROOMS
VIA PROP.
NINETY EIGHT AND REDUCES THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR
CRITICAL PUBLIC SERVICES HEALTH
CARE.
INFRASTRUCTURE HIGHER EDUCATION
HOUSING MENTAL HEALTH THE COURTS
THAT SAID.
FOR SO THE QUESTION IS ARE THESE
TAX EXPENDITURES WORTH THEIR
COST.
IF I IF YOU PROMISE ME THAT IF I
GIVE YOU A DOLLAR IF YOU'LL GIVE
ME BACK.
TEN WELL OF COURSE I'M GOING TO
GIVE YOU THAT DOLLAR.
BUT IF YOU PROMISE ME THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO GIVE ME BACK TEN
AND YOU GIVE ME BACK TWENTY FIVE
CENTS.
MAYBE I NEED TO RE EVALUATE THAT.
DEAL.
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT
CONTINUING ITS BENEFIT.
AND A TWENTY FIFTEEN AUDIT BY
THE STATE AUDITOR IN CALIFORNIA
CONCLUDED THAT QUOTE ADOPTING
OVERSIGHT METHODS.
WOULD IMPROVE THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE STATE'S CURRENT AND
FUTURE TAX EXPENDITURES
PROVIDING THE LEGISLATURE WITH
MORE INFORMATION AND A BETTER
ACCOUNTING OF THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS.
AND IMPACT. EIGHT TWENTY
SEVENTEEN REPORT BY THE PEW
CHARITABLE TRUSTS SCORED
CALIFORNIA IS TRAILING.
WITH TWENTY EIGHT STATES AHEAD
OF US IN EVALUATING THEIR TAX
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS IN INFORMING
THEIR LEGISLATURE'S AS TO THE
VALUE OF THESE PROGRAMS.
SO SB FOUR SIXTY EIGHT BEGINS AN
OVERSIGHT PROCESS REGARDING TAX
EXPENDITURES THAT WE'VE ACTUALLY
BELIEVE IT OR NOT NEVER HAD
BEFORE IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY.
AND I HOPE THAT IT'S ONE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CAN BUILD UPON.
IT CREATES A BOARD CONSISTING OF
THE STATE COMPTROLLER.
THE LEAD CHANNEL LIST THE STATE
AUDITOR AND DESIGNATE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND A
DESIGNATED THE US SECRETARY.
OF GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY.
THIS BOARD WILL PRIORITIZE THE
EXAMINATION OF THESE TAX
EXPENDITURES.
AND WHICH OF THESE TAX BREAKS WE
SHOULD EVALUATE FIRST.
AND THEN IT DIRECTS THE LA -- TO
CARRY OUT THE RESEARCH NOW I'M
MINDFUL THAT IF THE LA --
DOESN'T HAVE THE BAND WITH TO DO
THIS THAT ANOTHER ENTITY MAY IN
FACT BE MORE APPROPRIATE BUT
THIS IS THE BASIC FRAMEWORK THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT AFTER THE LA --
OR WHOMEVER WE CHOOSE HAS
PERFORMED A THOROUGH EXAMINATION
OF THE VALUE TO THE STATE OF A
TAX EXPENDITURE.
THE BOARD WILL HOLD PUBLIC
HEARINGS INTENDED TO RECEIVE
INPUT FROM INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS OF ALL KINDS.
REGARDING THAT STUDY AND THE
BENEFITS OF THE TAX EXPENDITURE.
FOLLOWING THAT THE BOARD WILL
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
AS TO THE MAINTENANCE DELETION
AUGMENTATION OR REDUCTION IN THE
TAX EXPENDITURE IF WE AS A
LEGISLATURE DEEM IT APPROPRIATE.
THIS BILL BRINGS TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY TO OUR TAX
INCENTIVE PROCESS BY CREATING A
MECHANISM AND A PUBLIC PROCESS
FOR REVIEW.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE FURTHERMORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SITE
DONE OPENS BUYERS REMORSE SIR.
A WHITE -- BUT DIE I'M
[inaudible]
I IT'S JUST MAYBE THE
FRUSTRATION THAT MAYBE THIS BILL
SHOULD ST AERO.
THAT WILL NOT COME CLOSE TO
HITTING THE TARGET I WAS HOPING
THAT IT MIGHT -- I LIKE THE
INTENT OF SENATE BILL.
FOUR SIXTY EIGHT AS A FORMER TAX
PREPARER I WOULD RATHER SEE
INDIVIDUAL AND CORPORATE TAX
CREDITS.
EVALUATED WHICH ARE THE TRUE TAX
EXPENDITURES.
I BELIEVE LOOKING AT TEN THIRTY
ONE EXCHANGES ARE HE STOPS OR S.
CORPSE.
THAT THAT IS JUST -- GOING TO BE
DRIVING US INTO A CALL THE SACK --
IT'S A DEAD END DRIVE NOT
CONFORMING WITH FEDERAL TAX LAW
ON ME STRATEGIES AS TIME AND
ENERGY MISSPENT I BELIEVE.
THE CONSEQUENTLY I'M IN A LAYOFF
OF SB.
SIX FOUR SIX EIGHT WITH THE
HOPES THAT A MORE APPROPRIATELY
FOCUSED EFFORT COMES BACK TO US
FOR CONCERN CONCURRENCE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
CENTER MORE LIKE MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
JACKSON WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
IT'S THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
WE IS A STATE CREATE TAX
INCENTIVES FOR VARIOUS SECTORS.
FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE ONE NOW FOR
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
BECAUSE THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY PROMISED US THAT IF WE
GAVE THEM CERTAIN TAX CREDITS
AND INCENTIVES.
THAT WULD CREATE MORE BUSINESS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE THAT BILL WAS PASSED
AFTER TWENTY FOURTEEN AND WE
WOULD PUT TO CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS AND METRICS ON THEM
THEY ACTUALLY CAME BACK AND
DEMONSTRATED THAT THAT TAX
CREDIT WAS WORKING SO WELL.
THAT WE AUGMENTED IT.
BUT WE DO REQUIRE THEM TO COME
FORWARD AND TO EXPLAIN TO US WHY
THIS IS SERVING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT THIS MEASURE DOES IS IT
STARTS US MOVING FROM TWENTY
FOURTEEN BACK? TO WHERE WE HAVE.
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
TAX CREDITS FOR WHICH WE'VE
NEVER EVEN ASKED THAT QUESTION.
AND SO IT WAS IT IS BECAUSE OF
THAT THAT WE NEED TO GIVE
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT TO
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE ON HOW
WE'RE SPENDING THEIR MONEY.
AND IF WE ARE DOING IT IN THE
BEST MANNER POSSIBLE AND WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER JACKSON MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
BY ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL.
BY POOR JUST [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I CARRY IT ALL [inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL.
THAT'S WHERE I HILL [inaudible]
BY HUESO.
BY -- TITLE HI JACKSON BY JONES
[inaudible]
NO.
LEYVA.
HI BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LUCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
BY Y. CASSIE BY WINNER BY WILK
[inaudible]
NO.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO BE PLACING A BILL
OF BILLS ON CALL FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN SENATOR ALLEN ARE YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE THIS UP.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWO TWELVE BY
SENATOR ALAN ANAK REALLY INTO
ELECTIONS [inaudible]
SENATOR ALAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THIS BILL AUTHORIZES
GENERAL LOST CITIES GENERAL ARE
COUNTIES IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
TO DO WHAT CURRENT.
CHARTER LAW I CITIES HAVE THE
RIGHT TO DO.
WHICH WOULD BE -- TO ALLOW THEM
TO UTILIZE TWO DIFFERENT
MAJORITY WINNER VOTING METHODS
FOR LOCAL ELECTIONS IF THEY SO
DECIDE IT'S ENTIRELY PERMISSIVE
A TWO ROUND RUNOFF.
OR RATE CHOICE VOTING IF THE
ELECTORAL SYSTEM ALLOWS FOR IT --
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL.
UNDER CURRENT THE LOS VOTERS IN
GENERAL I CITIES HAVE TO ELECT
THEIR CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS USING
PLURALITY WINNER VOTING BUT
CHARTER CITIES HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO ADOPT MAJORITY WHEN
NOBODY METHODS LIKE TO RUN RUN
OFFER RENTER'S VOTING.
IF THEY WANT TO THIS EXTENDS THE
RIGHT -- TO TO GENERAL IF FOLKS --
AND IT DOES NOT IMPOSE ANY
CHANGE A LOCALITY TO JUST
PROVIDE THEM WITH MORE OPTIONS
SO THEY CAN BETTER SELECT IN
ELECTIONS METHOD THAT MATCHES
THEIR NEEDS.
AND THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES AND
WITHOUT ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL.
BY POOR JUST [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
HI GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
I HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI.
ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO NUMBER.
I LIKE OWSKI BY WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM TWENTY THREES
SENATOR ROTH MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY FIVE A
SENATOR ROBERTSON ACT REALLY IN
THE PHARMACY SAID RON.
WHEN PRESIDENT CALLING SAYS
SENATE BILL SIX FIVE FIVE MAKES
NUMEROUS TECHNICAL CHANGES AND
UPDATES TO PHARMACY LAW IN ORDER
TO BRING CONFORMITY ENSURE
MINIMUM COMPETENCY REMOVE
BARRIERS TO LICENSURE?
AND TO SEEK ALIGNMENT WITH SOME
STIPULATED REQUIREMENTS AMONG
OTHER THINGS THE BILL.
WILL REQUIRE GENERALLY A
CALIFORNIA APPLICANT TO HAVE
TAKEN THE NATIONAL PHARMACY
LICENSURE EXAMINATION HONOR
AFTER TWO THOUSAND FORDHAM
MEASURE KNOWLEDGE IN VARIOUS
OCCUPATIONAL SETTINGS.
ORDER OF TAKEN ANOTHER TEST THAT
DOES SO -- ALIGNS RENEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR ADVANCED
PRACTICE PHARMACISTS WITH THE
PHARMACIST RENEWAL REQUIREMENTS.
IN OTHER WORDS MUST GENERALLY
HOLDEN ACTIVE PHARMACY LICENSE
IN ORDER TO HOLD.
AN ACTIVE ADVANCED PRACTICE
LICENSE IT ALLOWS THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY BOARD TO ASSESS FEES
FROM GOVERNMENT OWNED PHARMACY
LICENSE FEES.
FROM GOVERNMENT OWNED FACILITIES
REMOVING THE CURRENT EXEMPTION
CURRENTLY PROVIDED TO SOME
GOVERNMENT PHARMACIES.
AND IT CLARIFIES IT REVERSED
DISTRIBUTOR.
CAN TAKE BACK DRUGS AND DEVICES
FROM AN UNLICENSED ENTITY FOR
DESTRUCTION PURPOSES AS OPPOSED
TO THE CURRENT REQUIREMENT AS I
UNDERSTAND IT WHICH REQUIRES.
DRUGS AND DEVICES TO BE REMOVED
ONLY FROM LICENSED ENTITIES THE
BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE BOARD
OF PHARMACY AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROBB MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THUNDERSTONE THANK YOU MEMBERS
ARE COMMON SENSE -- REVISIONS TO
CALIFORNIA STATE PHARMACY Là I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR BRING IN
FOR DINNER TONIGHT THOUGH.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE CENTER ROTH WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
HIS RESPECTFULLY AS FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SIR MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA.
I'M ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
HI ROTH.
BY RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
AYE AMBERG.
BOB AKOWSKI BY WINNER BY WILK.
BY.
SENATOR MOVES THE CALL MOVING TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR SENATOR
RUBIO.
PASS ON FILE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT
SENATOR RUBIO.
SHE'S READY MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR RUBIO ANAK WILLING TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
SENATOR RUBIO YOU KNOW WHAT I'M
SO SORRY MY HALF OF ALSO PASS ON
HOW TO PROPERLY TAKEN.
VERY GOOD NOT A PROBLEM ALL
RIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY SENATOR CHIANG.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
THAT ABOUT THIRTY FIVE A SENATOR
CHIANG AN ACT RELATING TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CENTER CHIANG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES.
DESPITE YEARS A COMMENDABLE
EFFORTS TO COMBAT SLAVERY AND
TRAFFICKING THIS IS STILL A
CRIME OUR STATE STRUGGLES WITH
TODAY.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING REMAINS
WIDESPREAD IN CALIFORNIA SB
THIRTY FIVE WILL RECONVENE THE
CALIFORNIA LINES TO COMBAT
TRAFFICKING AND SLAVERY.
TASK FORCE TO HELP WE CUT WE
CALIBRATE THE STATE'S HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SUPPRESSION STRATEGY.
IN PARTICULAR THE TASK FORCE
WILL LAY THE GROUNDWORK FOR A
PER PREVALENCE STUDY FOR
CALIFORNIA.
THERE SIMPLY ISN'T ENOUGH DATA
FOR US TO TRULY UNDERSTAND THE
SIZE AND SCOPE OF THIS ISSUE AND
I'VE HEARD FROM A A VARIETY OF
GROUPS ACROSS THE STATE.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THIS
CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE AT A MORE
DETAILED LEVEL IN ORDER TO MAKE
SOUND POLICY DECISIONS.
THE TIME IS RIGHT TO RECONVENE
OUR STATE LEADERS ON HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND REALIGN OUR
STATE Y. STRATEGY.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
SUPPORT ON SB.
THIRTY FIVE THE USER CHIANG
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
I BILL BY PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
COM HI CABALLERO.
BY CHIANG BY DAUGHTER.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO -- TITLE
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
HI JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING.
MORE LOCKED.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI.
PAN.
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
I AM BURKE.
CASSIE.
I WINNER BY WILK.
HI.
THEN REMOVE THE CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY FOUR SENATOR RUBIO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE A
SENATOR RUBIO AND ACCOLADES
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY AND INTO
RUBIO [inaudible]
ALONG [inaudible]
ONE I'M SORRY
.
MEMBERS I BEG YOUR INDULGENCE
WE'RE GOING TO DO FILE ITEM
TWENTY EIGHT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL TWO
SEVENTY THREE BY SENATOR RUBIO
AND EXPLAIN TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I'M PRESENTING SB TWO
SEVENTY THREE ALSO KNOWN AS THE
PHOENIX ACT.
SB TWO SEVENTY THREE WOULD
EXTEND THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR FELONY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
OFFENSES FROM THREE YEARS TO TEN
YEARS FOR SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. TO REPORT THEIR ABUSE
THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES CRITICAL
TRAINING FOR PEACE OFFICERS TO
BE ABLE TO HELP SURVIVORS.
ASK THE RIGHT QUESTIONS AT AND
AND HELP THEM COME FORWARD.
MEMBERS IT IS TIME TO EMPOWER
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
DATA SHOWS MULTIPLE REASONS WHY
SURVIVORS MAY NOT COME FORWARD
WITHIN THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS INCLUDING H..
THE TIME OF THE ABUSE ONGOING
TRAUMA THREATS BY THEIR
PERPETRATORS OR LACK OF EVIDENCE
IN AMERICA AN AVERAGE OF FIFTY
WOMEN ARE SHOT TO DEATH BY THEIR
INTIMATE PARTNERS EVERY MONTH.
AND MANY MORE ARE INJURED.
WHEN MY STORY WAS PUBLICIZED AS
I TOO AM A VICTIM OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HUNDREDS THE WOMEN CAME
FORWARD TO TELL THEIR STORIES?
ONE WOMAN IN PARTICULAR STANDS
OUT TO ME.
SHE SPENT EIGHTEEN YEARS IN AN
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP.
EVEN AFTER IT ENDED SHE WASN'T
ABLE TO COME FORWARD.
IT WAS TOO EMBARRASSING TO
TRAUMATIZING [inaudible] ONE
OTHER WOMAN STATED.
THAT SHE GOT AWAY FROM HER
ABUSER.
AND HE WAS STALKING HER.
SO MUCH SO THAT HE FOUND HER.
SHOT INTO HER HOME AND SHOT HER
FATHER.
LET'S NOT MAKE THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATION. ONE MORE HURDLE.
THEN AN ALREADY BROKEN
TRAUMATIZED VICTIM HOUSE TO JUMP.
I URGE YOU TO JOIN ME.
AND PROTECTIONS FOR WOMEN
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
IT'S NOT ONLY WOMEN IT'S ALSO
MEN AND THE NUMBERS ARE GROWING
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR A RIVAL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER RUBIO DEBATER
DISCUSSION DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR NIELSEN FOLLOWED BY
CENTER BORCHERS.
BETTER PRESIDENT LAYS DOWN THE
SENATE I DO INDEED URGE AN AYE
VOTE.
AND THIS IS ANOTHER STEP IN A
LONG CONTINUUM OF ELEVATING.
THE KNOWLEDGE OF AND THE
CONSEQUENCES OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE INCIDENTS.
I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
MENTIONING THAT SOMETIMES.
MAYBE RARELY BUT THAT DOES
HAPPEN TO ME IN.
TWO WAY BACK IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES.
AT THE PLEASURE WORKING WITH
THEN MEMBERS JACKIE SPEAR AT AND
SHE LOOKED COOL.
WHO WERE PIONEERS IN THIS AREA
OF LAW?
I WAS NOT HERE BUT I WAS TERM
THE BOARD PRISON TERMS.
AND ADMINISTRATIVELY WE WERE
ABLE TO DO SOME THINGS THAT ALSO
ELEVATED THE CONSEQUENCES FOR
PERPETRATORS WHO HAD SUCH
INSTANCES IN THEIR HISTORY.
EDIT ELP PAINT A PICTURE OF
THEIR FUTURE DANGEROUS THIS.
THIS IS ALL.
TOO COMMON.
IN SOCIETY THEN THE AUTHOR MAKES
A GOOD POINT.
THE INTIMIDATION.
AND THE FEAR.
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS BEEN SO --
PRESTON [inaudible]
AND HEART.
THEN IT'S PHYSICAL.
BUT IT'S ALSO PSYCHOLOGICAL.
I DON'T HAVE [inaudible]
GOVERNOR FUTURE.
AND FUTURE RELATIONSHIPS.
CAN I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DEAL
WITH MANY OF THESE INSTANCES AND
STUDY THEM AND THAT.
THE PRECURSOR EVENTS THAT LED UP.
THE CRITICAL MOMENT OF THAT
ACTUAL.
WOMAN FINALLY COMING FORWARD.
FOR THE INFORMATION GETTING OUT
IN SOME MANNER.
SO THAT THE PERPETRATOR.
ADD TO PAY SOME PRICE.
THIS IS ANOTHER AGAIN STEP.
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
TOWARDS MINIMISING SUCH
INCIDENCES.
BUT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
[inaudible]
DOMESTIC ABUSE.
AND IN SOME CASES I WOULD EVEN
ARGUE TORTURE [inaudible]
I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN.
OF THIS LOOK LIKE CENTER BOARD
JUST WANTS TO SPEAK AT THIS
POINT SO WILL CALL ON SENATOR
SKINNER.
THANK YOU ARE.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I STAND
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I
KNOW THAT SOME PEOPLE MIGHT BE
CONCERNED THAT STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS THERE THERE'S A
REASON WE HAVE THAT ON CRIMES.
AND CERTAINLY IN THE ISSUE OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IT IS MOST
COMMON THAT NOT MOST COMMON
WOULD BE OBVIOUS THAT YOU YOU
THE VICTIM WOULD KNOW YOUR
PERPETRATOR.
AND SO THERE'S SOME ARGUMENT
THAT.
IF YOU KNOW THE PERPETRATOR WHY
WOULD YOU NEED A LONGER STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS.
BUT I THINK WHAT WE KNOW.
IS THAT VERY OFTEN.
THE PERSON WHO IS THE VICTIM OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE [inaudible]
THEY ARE.
SUSCEPTIBLE TO IT BECAUSE THEY
ARE DEPENDENT.
ON THE PERSON.
AND WHEN YOU ARE DEPENDENT ON
THE PERSON IT IS MUCH HARDER.
FOR YOU TO BE ABLE TO SEE.
THAT YOUR AN INNOCENT VICTIM IN
THAT CIRCUMSTANCE.
THERE'S ALSO A GREAT DEAL OF
SHAME.
SO IT IS MUCH HARDER THAN TO
REPORT.
ADDITIONALLY.
MANY PEOPLE ARE DEPENDENT ON THE
PERSON FINANCIALLY.
AND SO THEY COULD JEOPARDIZE
THEY OR THEIR CHILDREN'S
LIVELIHOOD.
WITH REPORTING.
SO THEY MAY BE ABLE TO EXTRACT
THEMSELVES FROM THE DOMESTIC
ABUSE BUT STILL NOT BE WILLING
FOR ANY NUMBER OF REASONS TO
REPORT.
AND WHEN THEY FINALLY GET TO THE
POINT IN THEIR LIVES WHETHER
IT'S THROUGH.
COUNSELING OR WHETHER THROUGH
NOT BEING FINANCIALLY OR
OTHERWISE DEPEND ON THE PERSON
ANY LONGER.
THEY SHOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO
REPORT AND IF THEY HAVE THE
EVIDENCE THEN THE PERSON WHO WAS
THE PERPETRATOR OF THAT TO
MYSTIC VIOLENCE SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
AND SO WITH THAT I ASKED ZERO
VOTE.
THANK YOU SKINNER CENTERS
SKINNER ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
RUBIO YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I DO WANT TO THANK
BOTH OF MY COLLEAGUES THAT.
THE JUST SHARED SUPPORT FOR THE
FOR FOR THIS BILL IT IS A REALLY
CRITICAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD HELP.
EMPOWER WOMEN TO COME FORWARD I
AM INCLINED TO SHARE ONE OF THE
WITNESSES THAT TESTIFIED IN MY
AND MY A HEARING.
THIS VICTIM.
WAS TIED UP [inaudible]
TORTURED STARVED SHE WAS SLEEP
DEPRIVED.
SHE HAD TO GO TO COUNTY FOR SO
MANY YEARS.
THEN SHE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS.
BY THE TIME SHE DECIDED TO COME
FORWARD SHE HAD AUDIO.
VIDEO.
THREATENING LETTERS.
AND SHE WAS TOLD HER TIME WAS UP.
SHE COULDN'T BRING HER
PERPETRATOR TO JUSTICE BECAUSE
IT WAS TOO LATE.
EVEN WITH THE EVIDENCE SHE HAD.
AND SO THIS IS SO IMPORTANT IT
IS PERSONAL AS YOU ALL KNOW.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE AND I
VOTE THANK YOU.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
HI BILL.
BY PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
AYE DODD.
I THE RAZA.
AYE GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER.
BY GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
BY HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TOTAL.
HI JACKSON HI HI JONES
[inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY.
MOORLACH.
I'M REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
BY NUMBER.
OUR CASKEY.
I WINNER BY WILK.
HI.
SENATE RUBIO MOVES A CALL.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO GO --
TO FILE ITEM [inaudible]
TWENTY NINE SENATOR SKINNER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE THREE
FOUR SENATE BILL THREE TEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND ACT RELATED
TO JURIES.
SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU AYE MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
I'M COLLEAGUES.
I ASK YOU WHAT TO MARTHA STEWART.
LARRY KING AND TIM ALLEN.
ALL HAVE IN COMMON.
IF THEY LIVED IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY REGISTERED TO VOTE THEY
WOULD BE LEGALLY ABLE TO
REGISTER VOTE AND LEGALLY ABLE
TO VOTE.
BUT WHAT THEY COULD NEVER DO IN
CALIFORNIA IS SERVE ON A JURY
[inaudible]
WHY?
BECAUSE ALL OF THEM.
WERE PASSED.
CONVICTED OF A FELONY.
NOW ALL OF THEM AS WE KNOW SERVE
THEIR TIME.
HAVE.
BEEN LAW ABIDING AND GOODS
CONTRIBUTORS TO OUR SOCIETY.
AND YET IN CALIFORNIA THEY WOULD
BE FOR EVER BEYOND FROM SERVING
ON A JURY.
THE BASIC FUNDAMENTAL.
NOTION OF JURIES IN OF OUR
CONSTITUTION IS THAT.
WE WOULD BE [inaudible]
WE WOULD.
THE ABILITY TO GO BEFORE OUR
PEERS.
THAT IS A JURY OF OUR PEERS THAT
WOULD DETERMINE.
AFTER THE EVIDENCE WHETHER WE
WERE.
GUILTY OR NOT.
BUT NOW DUE TO THAT FACT.
IN CALIFORNIA IT IS HARD FOR
MANY PEOPLE TO HAVE A JURY OF
THEIR PEERS AND IN FACT.
RIGHT TODAY IN CALIFORNIA 30% OF
OUR AFRICAN AMERICAN MEN THAT
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA WOULD BE
FOREVER BARRED FROM SERVING ON A
JURY WHEREAS HOWEVER.
THEY HAVE THEIR VOTING RIGHTS
RESTORED AND MANY MANY OTHER
RIGHTS RESTORED INCLUDING THEIR
ABILITY TO GET PROFESSIONAL
LICENSES.
AND MANY OTHER THINGS.
SO WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO.
IS.
PROVIDE.
LIFT THAT BAN THAT WE NOW HAVE
IN STATUTE -- THERE WAS LATE
OPPOSITION FROM THE DA'S THEY
DID NOT EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION
WHEN IT WAS BEFORE COMMITTEE IN
PUBLIC SAFETY.
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT I'VE SAT DOWN
WITH THE DA ASSOCIATION AND
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT WHAT THEIR
CONCERN IS IN THE EVER CONCERNED
THAT EVEN IF YOU ARE UNDER --
PAROLE THAT YOU WOULD UNDER THIS
BILL BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT RIGHT
TO VOTE SO I WILL WE HAVE
DISCUSSED AMENDMENTS.
AND I WILL BE TAKING AN
AMENDMENT IN THE ASSEMBLY.
SO THAT HOPEFULLY THE DA'S WE'LL
GET TO NEUTRAL THEY HAVE
DISTRIBUTED A LETTER CONFIRMING
THAT WE'VE HAD THIS CONVERSATION --
AND THE BILL ALSO STILL RETAINS
THE ABILITY FOR THE PROSECUTOR
OR THE PUBLIC DEFENDER. TO
BASICALLY STRIKE A JUROR SO TO
NOT CONSIDER THEM.
AND IT STILL RETAINS THE
QUESTIONNAIRE PROCESS WHICH CAN
ASK PEOPLE EVERYTHING.
THINGS LIKE HAVE THEY EVER BEEN
CONVICTED OF A CRIME SO IF THE
PROSECUTOR DOES NOT WANT TO HAVE.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN PASSED
CONVICTED OF A CRIME THEY CAN
USE THEIR ABILITY TO STRIKE A
JUROR [inaudible]
SO ESSENTIALLY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS JUST RESTORE THE RIGHTS
IN THE SAME WAY THAT WE RESTORE
PEOPLE'S VOTING RIGHTS AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR HERTZBERG.
OUR SYSTEM OF LAWS.
IN THIS COUNTRY AND IN THIS
STATE.
ARE BASED UPON.
DEEP.
ETHICAL CONSIDERATIONS.
AND THOSE ARE THAT WHEN YOU HAVE
A DATE YOU PAY IT.
WHEN YOU HAVE A DEBT TO SOCIETY
YOU PAY IT?
SERVING PRISON TARMA JAIL TIME
IF YOU'RE A IN JAIL BECAUSE OF A
FELONY WE NOW HAVE CHALLENGES
FOLKS WHO ARE FELONS WHO IN JAIL.
YOU PAID YOUR DEBT.
DOES THAT MEAN THAT YOU SHOULD
NOT ALSO HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
THERE'S THOSE WHO DON'T LIKE TO
SERVE ON JURIES ARE THOSE THAT
THINK IT'S A PROBLEM.
BUT THERE'S A DIGNITY IN
PARTICIPATING IN SOCIETY THERE'S
A DIGNITY WHEN YOU HAVE PAID
YOUR DEBT TO SOCIETY THIS BILL
RESTORES THAT.
NOT ONLY DOES IT HAVE IS THE
AUTHOR SUGGESTED THE IDEA THAT
YOU GET SUBJECT TO A JURY OF
YOUR PEERS UP THE IT CAME OUT OF
THE ORIGINAL JURY SYSTEM FROM
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS AGO.
BUT IT'S A MUCH DEEPER DYNAMIC
IN MY JUDGMENT.
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE COMMITTED A
WRONG PAY THEIR DEBT.
BUT THAT THEY ALSO BE COMMON
EVERY POSSIBLE REASONABLE WAY
FULL MEMBERS OF A PARTICIPATING
SOCIETY AND THAT INCLUDES
PARTICIPATING IN JURY SERVICE I
ASK YOUR AYE BOAT.
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING ON SENATOR
SKINNER YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU I THINK WE ARE
PRESENTED THE BILL WELL AND I
HOPE THAT -- PEOPLE AGREE THAT
THIS IS A LEGITIMATE RIGHT TO BE
RESTORED AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
NO BELL.
I FORGES.
NO BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD.
I THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GROVE NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TOTAL.
I JACKSON BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
BY KELSEY.
BY WIENER.
BY WILK [inaudible]
NOPE.
SENATOR SKINNER MOVES A CALL.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM. THIRTY
ONE BY SENATOR LEYVA.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR LEYVA AN ACT RELATING TO
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
SENATOR LEYVA THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I RISE TO
RESENT SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY
FOR THE CHILD CARE STABILIZATION
FORMULA.
AS A LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PARTY BILL SB ONE SEVENTY FOUR
WOULD ESTABLISH A SINGLE
REGIONALI STATE REIMBURSEMENT
RATE SYSTEM FOR CHILDCARE
PRESCHOOL AND EARLY LEARNING
SERVICES.
CURRENTLY TWO SEPARATE UNALIGNED
SYSTEMS FOR REIMBURSING CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS LIMIT ACCESS
FAILED TO MAXIMIZE PROGRAM
QUALITY AND FORCE MANY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS OUT OF BUSINESS.
WELL SOME PROVIDERS RECEIVE A
RATE BASED ON FACTORS SUCH AS
GEOGRAPHICAL LOCATION AND
REGIONAL CHILD COST OF CHILDCARE.
OTHERS PROVIDE PROVIDERS THAT
MEET HIGHER STANDARDS RECEIVE A
FLAT RATE REGARDLESS OF LOCATION
AND THE COST OF DOING BUSINESS.
TO DESK DRESS THE PROBLEMS
CREATED BY THE CURRENT RATE
SYSTEM RESOURCES MANAGER SHOULD
BE STREAMLINED AND SPENT IN A
WAY THAT.
CAN YOU GUYS GO OVER THERE.
SORRY IT'S JUST DISTRACTING
THANK YOU.
COMPENSATES TEACHERS AND
PROGRAMS FOR THE COST OF
PROVIDING CARE ARE RESPONSIVE TO
THE ECONOMIC DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZE THE COSTS
OF MEETING VARYING QUALITY
STANDARDS.
AND INCENTIVIZE HIGH STANDARDS
AND PARTICIPATION IN RESEARCH
BASED QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
EFFORTS.
BY EQUALIZING THE RATES
CALIFORNIA CAN ACHIEVE A MORE
EQUITABLE SYSTEM TO SUPPORT
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WHAT THE
SAME TIME KEEPING MORE PROVIDER
DOORS OPEN.
AND IMPROVING ACCESS TO
CHILDCARE MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IS
THERE ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON FILE ITEM.
THIRTY ONE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MR SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
BY ATKINS.
BATES.
HI BILL.
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
HI CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
AYE -- TADO.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES.
HI LEYVA HI I AM A CHOIR I
MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LUCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
HI NUMBER.
VIA CASKEY BY WINNER
[inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY TWO SENATOR JACKSON
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOR NINETY THREE BY
SENATOR JACKSON ANAK RELATE TO
EDUCATION.
SENATE JACKSON THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES -- MANY
RUSSIAN JORI THE BENEFITS WHEN
WE ARE ABLE TO WELCOME TO OUR
HELLO FLOOR.
WOMEN AND YOUNG GIRLS WHO HAVE
COMPETED IN ATHLETICS OR IN
SCIENCE.
AND THIS IS DUE IN GREAT MEASURE
NOT CHOSE TO THE EXTRAORDINARY
TALENT OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE BUT
ALSO AS A RESULT OF SOMETHING
REFERRED TO HIS TITLE.
NINE AND ANYONE WHO HAS BEEN
HERE FOR A FEW YEARS KNOWS THAT.
I FREQUENTLY SPEAK ON ON THIS
SUBJECT BECAUSE I THINK TITLE
NINE HAS BEEN ONE OF THE MOST
CRITICAL.
PIECES OF LEGISLATION TO ENSURE
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY FOR GIRLS AND
WOMEN IN THIS NATION.
SO THIS IS THOUGH A MEASURE THAT
ALSO EXTENDS TO SEX EQUITY IN
ALL EDUCATION LAW ALONG WITH
CORRESPONDING STATE LAW.
IT'S BEEN VITAL TO ENSURE THAT
ALL STUDENTS WOMEN AND MEN.
AS WELL AS GIRLS AND BOYS AT
EVERY GRADE LEVEL.
IT ENSURES THAT THEY HAVE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUCCESS IN
ACADEMICS AS WELL AS ATHLETICS
AND CAN SPURS SEWER IN EDUCATION
IN AN ENVIRONMENT SAFE FROM
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AND VIOLENCE.
THIS IS AN ITEM TITLE NINE IS
THERE TO PROTECT IN THE AREA OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT BUT SADLY AND SOMEWHAT
SHOCKINGLY.
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND VIOLENCE IN
IN HIGHER EDUCATION IS PERVASIVE.
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
CAMPUS CLIMATE SURVEY VALIDATION
STUDY OF TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITY STUDENTS.
AN ESTIMATED 62% OF WOMEN.
AND 61% OF MEN EXPERIENCE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ONE IN FIVE WOMEN.
AND ONE IN FOURTEEN MEN
EXPERIENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT.
IN COLLEGE HOWEVER DUE TO THE
UNDER REPORTING THAT WE KNOW
EXISTS AND WAS DISCUSSED
PREVIOUSLY ON THE ISSUE OF
DOMESTIC ABUSE AND CRIMES
RELATING TO GENDER DISPARITIES
AT CENTRAL.
THESE ARE YOU KNOW FORMALLY
UNDER REPORTED SO THE NUMBERS
ARE MOST LIKELY EVEN HIGHER BUT
YET ONE IN FIVE AND ONE IN
FOURTEEN IS TOO MANY.
THE EFFECTS OF THIS ARE OFTEN
DIRE.
STUDENTS TO EXPERIENCE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT NOT ONLY
SUFFER PHYSICALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY BUT ARE ALSO DENIED
AN EQUITABLE ACCESS TO EDUCATION
WHEN SCHOOLS DO NOT
APPROPRIATELY RESPOND.
TO AND OR INVESTIGATE THESE
INCIDENTS ONE OF THE MANY
HARMFUL RESULTS OF CAMPUS
SURROUNDS MEANT AND THE SALT IS
THE PUSH OUT.
THAT OFTEN OCCURS WHEN SCHOOLS
DO NOT TAKE APPROPRIATE STEPS TO
RESPOND TO THESE INCIDENTS.
AND AN ESTIMATED 34%.
THAT'S WHY ONE IN THREE OF
STUDENT SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT ON CAMPUS WILL DROP OUT
OF SCHOOL. ONE IN.
THREE CALIFORNIA HAS LOOKED TO
AND RELIED UPON TITLE NINE FOR
DECADES ALONG WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS I STATE LAW BUT WE
ARE INCREASINGLY CONCERNED.
AND BY THE STATEMENTS THAT ARE
BEING MADE ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL
BY THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND MISS BETSY DEVICE
TO CHEERS.
THE CONCERN THAT THERE IS
DISMANTLING OF TITLE NINE
PROTECTIONS BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT HAS EXPRESSED OPEN
HOSTILITY BOTH OF THE SAFEGUARDS
THE TITLE NINE PRESENTS AND TO
ADDRESSING GENDER BASED VIOLENCE
IN GENERAL.
IT HAS IN FACT ALREADY PROPOSED
FEDERAL REGULATIONS THAT GOT
TITLE NINE'S CRITICAL
PROTECTIONS SO WHAT DO WE DO
WHEN THAT HAPPENS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE MOVED. TO CODIFY
THOSE IMPORTANT PROCEDURES TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN PROTECT AGAINST
THAT KIND OF DE CONSTRUCTION
GOING ON THAT WE NEED TO DO MORE
TO PROTECT THE STUDENTS BOTH
MALES AND FEMALES.
IN THE COLLEGE SETTING SO THIS
MEASURE DOES THE FOLLOWING IT
ADDS SEXUAL VIOLENCE TO THE
DEFINITION OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
IN THE EDUCATION CODE.
IT DIRECTS ALL POST SECONDARY
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
IMPLEMENT FUNDAMENTAL PROCESSES
AND REQUIREMENTS REGARDING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE PREVENTION BECAUSE WE
KNOW PREVENTION IS ALWAYS THE
BEST WAY TO DEAL WITH THESE
PROBLEMS IF AT ALL POSSIBLE.
IT ALSO INCLUDES ADOPTING AND
PUBLISHING GRIEVANCE PROCEDURES
AND PROVIDING FOR PROMPT AND
EQUITABLE RESOLUTION OF
COMPLAINTS.
IT ALSO REQUIRES AN EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION WHEN IT FINDS AND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT HAS CREATED A HOSTILE
ENVIRONMENT. TO ELIMINATE THAT
HOSTILE ENVIRONMENT PREVENT ITS
REOCCURRENCE AND ADDRESS IT'S
AFFECTS.
COLLEAGUES WE HAVE HAD ON THE
FLOOR WOMEN JIM THIS.
THE NATIONAL CHAMPIONS OLYMPIC
GOLD MEDALISTS WHO TALK ABOUT
THEIR EXPERIENCES IN THE COLLEGE
SETTING.
BEING VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND HARASSMENT WE NEED TO DO
BETTER AND THIS IS A MEASURE
THAT WILL.
DO THE BEST THAT IS POSSIBLE
BOTH TO PREVENT AND THEN WHEN IT
OCCURS TO PROVIDE A SYSTEM OF
DUE PROCESS FOR ALL PARTIES
CONCERNED. TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
REDUCE AND HOPEFULLY AT SOME
POINT EXTINGUISH THIS EPIDEMIC
THAT IS GOING ON AMONG OUR STATE
AND OUR NATION'S COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITY WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE CENTER
BORDERS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT WASN'T
PLNNING ON SPEAKING OF THIS --
BUT I WANT TO COMMEND.
THE SENATOR FROM SANTA BARBARA I
THINK HER MOTIVATIONS -- ARE
MERITORIOUS ON ON THIS PROPOSED
PIECE OF LEGISLATION -- I'M
AFRAID HOWEVER THAT WE MIGHT BE
BRINGING A PISTOL -- TO A VERBAL
JOUST WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS.
ONE OF THE PROVISIONS IN HERE I
THINK IS.
CAN BE DANGEROUS AND THAT IS THE
RIGHT. TO CONFRONT YOUR ACCUSERS
[inaudible]
AND THIS.
IN THIS PROPOSED LEGISLATION --
SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGES WHAT WE
HAVE PROPERLY UNDERSTOOD AS THE
RIGHT TO CONFRONT YOUR ACCUSERS.
THIS IS A BEDROCK.
COMPONENT OF OUR LEGAL SYSTEM.
BUT HERE I THINK WITH THIS
PROPOSED LEGISLATION THAT THAT
IS NO LONGER THE CASE THAT
INDIVIDUAL ACCUSED WILL HAVE TO
RELY UPON INTERMEDIARIES IN
OTHER FORMS OF COMMUNICATION. TO
COMMUNICATE AND DEFEND HIM OR
HERSELF.
I AGREE WITH THIS WITH CENTER
FROM SANTA BARBARA THERE IS AN
INTOLERABLE UNACCEPTABLE LEVEL.
OF A SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN OTHER
MISCONDUCT IN OUR UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS SHE IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
SO MUCH MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE
ABOUT IT.
BUT I'M NOT ABOUT. TO CARVE OUT
AN EXCEPTION OF WHAT WE BELIEVE
IS A CONSTITUTIONAL.
PROVISION THAT WE ALL ABIDE BY.
THE INDIVIDUAL ACCUSE SHOULD
HAVE THE ABILITY TO FREELY
CONFRONT.
HIS OR HER ACCUSERS THE CHANGE
THAT WOULD BE TO CHANGE THE WAY
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL IN JUDICIAL
IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WORK
AND THAT IS THE PRICE I'M NOT
WILLING TO PAY.
I RESPECTFULLY -- WILL BE VOTING
AGAINST THIS ENCOURAGE THOSE --
THAT ARE CONCERNED ABOUT CIVIL
LIBERTIES TO DO SO AS WELL.
THANK YOU CENTER BORDERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THE ANSWER
JACKSON PLEASE CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A MATTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES AND I APPRECIATE THE
OF I GUESS THE SEMI.
RECOGNITION OF THIS BILL -- I
WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND SIMPLY BY
SAYING THAT WE ARE FOLLOWING
CORD DIRECTIVE ON THIS THE
COURTS HAVE SAID.
THAT THERE IS A RIGHT TO
CONFRONT OR AND TO CONSULT AND
TO CROSS EXAMINE THE ACCUSED.
AND THE ACCUSER TO THE AND VICE
VERSA.
THERE IS THAT RIGHT BUT THE
COURT SAID IT CAN BE DIRECT OR
INDIRECT.
AND WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS WE HAVE
CHOSEN THE INDIRECT ROUTE
BECAUSE WE KNOW IN CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE YOU HAVE UNEQUAL
BARGAINING POWER.
THAT A VICTIM WHO IS THERE IN A
PROCESS STILL PROBABLY SUFFERING --
THE EMBARRASSMENT THE
HUMILIATION -- THE THE EMOTIONAL
TRAUMA OF HAVING BEEN ASSAULTED
BY THE INDIVIDUAL THAT SHE IS
HAVING TO CONFRONT IN THIS
PROCEEDING.
THAT THERE SHOULD BE AN
INTERVENOR AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL CALLS FOR AN INDIRECT
ABILITY SO THAT THE VICTIM IS
NOT SUBJECT TO THE KIND OF
ABUSES OR HARASSMENT THAT WE
KNOW CAN TAKE PLACE AND DOES
TAKE PLACE -- THE COURTS HAVE
GIVEN US THIS GUIDANCE WE ARE
TAKING THEIR GUIDANCE.
IN USING THAT INDIRECT APPROACH
AS DIRECTED BY THE COURT AND
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
BY ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL.
BY POOR JUST [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
DODD.
THERE ARE SO.
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
[inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON BY JONES.
NO.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
NOVEMBER OUR CASKEY BY WIENER BY
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
CENTER MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
THREE SENATOR TO RUSSELL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY NUMBER
SENATOR ALSO AN ACT RELATING TO
TENDENCY.
SENATOR ALSO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
SB.
TWENTY NINE FIVE TWENTY NINE
WILL REQUIRE LANDLORD EVICTING A
TENANT. TO HAVE AND STATE THEIR
REASON FOR THE VACATION
[inaudible]
IF.
THE TENANT IS IN A TENANT
ASSOCIATION CONSISTING OF THREE
OR MORE UNITS.
OWNED BY THAT LANDLORD.
AND THE ASSOCIATION HAS ADOPTED
BY LAWS OR AN OPERATING
AGREEMENT.
BECAUSE MUST BE STATED IN
WRITING.
AND BE THE DOMINANT MOTIVE FOR
THE TERMINATION OR THE FICTION.
THIS BILL HAS BEEN NARROWED AND
NO LONGER INCLUDES A RENT STRIKE.
RENTERS FACE AN INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT REALITY IN CALIFORNIA.
NEARLY HALF CALIFORNIANS ARE
RENTERS. 44% ARE TRYING TO RAISE
THEIR FAMILIES.
THE LA TIMES RECENTLY OBSERVED
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO FALL INTO
HOMELESSNESS OFTEN FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
BECAUSE OF A RENT STRIKE OR A
NEW VISION.
SB FIVE TWENTY NINE SEEKS TO
EQUALIZE ATTENDANCE VOICE.
OUR RENTER'S NEED PROTECTIONS.
IN CALIFORNIA HOUSING SHORTAGES
HAVE REACHED CRISIS LEVEL.
PHIL ALLOWING A VOICE FOR
RENTERS IS CRITICAL.
SB FIVE TWENTY NINE ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS TO ACT WITHOUT FEAR
OF RETALIATION. TO ASK FOR
EQUITABLE LIVING STANDARDS TO
PROTECT THE SAFETY AND STABILITY
OF THEIR FAMILIES.
INSEPARABLE FROM OUR VISION OF
PRODUCTION PRESERVATION AND
PROTECTION.
IS A TENANTS ABILITY. TO STAY IN
THEIR HOMES.
CENTRAL TO THE ABILITY OF
INDIVIDUALS TO JOIN TOGETHER IS
A SYSTEM.
THAT MITIGATES THE RISK OF HARM
AND RETALIATION COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER DORADO MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RESPECTFULLY RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL -- SOME RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS HAVE SUCH A HARD
TIME EVICTING BAD TENANTS THEY
HAVE TO GO THROUGH MONTHS
WITHOUT GETTING RENT PAYMENTS
THEN THERE'S DAMAGE TO THE
PROPERTY.
THEY HAVE TO GO TO COURT TO GET
INTO A JUDGE TO VICTIMS IN THIS
YEAR OF HAS TO SHOW UP AND BY
THE TIME ALL THIS HAPPENS.
MONTHS AND POSSIBLY SOMETIMES
YEARS HAVE GONE THROUGH THE
PROCESS BEFORE TENANTS CAN
ACTUALLY EVEN VICTOR.
OURS HE'S ME LANDLORDS CAN
ACTUALLY EVICT BAD TENANTS.
SO THIS BILL JUST ADDS TO THAT
SITUATION I KNOW THERE ARE SOME --
TENANT ORLANDO LANDLORDS IN MY
DISTRICT THAT HAVE HAD SEVERE
PROBLEMS EVICTING BAD TENETS
THAT OTHER TENANTS COMPLAIN
ABOUT.
ILLEGAL YOU DRUG USE AND THINGS
THAT ARE GOING ON THAT SHOULDN'T
BE GOING ON VIOLATION THE
PARKING PUTTING FIVE OR SIX CARS
AND YOU KNOW A SMALL PARKING
AREA BLOCKING OTHER TENANTS FROM
PARKING.
AND THEY VIOLATE THE RULES INTO
AND LANDLORDS ALREADY HAVE A
HARD TIME EVEN GETTING TENANTS.
AND THAT'S PER CALIFORNIA LAW
AND BY THE TIME I SAID YOU GO
THROUGH THE COURT PROCESS AT
LAST A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
AND IT BECAUSE COSTS A LOT OF
MONEY AND IT ALSO HURTS THE
TENANTS THAT ARE THEY'RE PAYING
THEIR BILLS DOING WHAT'S RIGHT
AND FOLLOWING THE RULES SO I
WOULD ASK RESPECTFULLY TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROW FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
MINING.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS SOMEONE I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
AS I READ THE BILL.
IT SEEKS TO CODIFY ASSOCIATIONAL
RIGHTS THAT ARE ALREADY
PROTECTED UNDER THE U. S. IN THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTIONS.
IT'S MORE SPECIFIC TO RATE THAT
WOULD BE AFFORDED TO A GROUP OF
TENANTS WHO CONSCIOUSLY FORM AN
ASSOCIATION.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT ALSO
RECOGNIZE IT DOES NOT REMOVED
FROM A LANDLORD THE ABILITY TO
PURSUE IT JUST BECAUSE OF THE
ACTION. FOR FAILURE TO PAY RENT
TO OR NOT MAINTAINING THE
PROPERTY WHATEVER.
IT JUSTIN STILLS AS OUR US
CONSTITUTION DOES.
THE RIGHT TO ASSOCIATE TO
PROTECTION IN COLLECTIVE
INTERESTS I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE CENTER
STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
IT'S INTERESTING THAT I'M I'M
CHATTING WITH ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS IT OWNS A LARGE --
APARTMENT COMPLEX AND TO MAKE A
LAW THAT IS -- LOOKING TO INVEST
FROM CALIFORNIA LOOKING IN
TENNESSEE LOOKING AND IN TEXAS.
OF YOU KNOW SOME OF THESE
APARTMENT -- ORDERS INVEST --
TENS OF THOUSANDS MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND AND COMPLEXES
[inaudible]
AND SOMETIMES YOU YOU GET GREAT
TENANTS AND SOMETIMES YOU GET.
NOT SO GREAT TENANTS SICK DO A
LOT OF DAMAGE TO YOUR YOUR
PROPERTIES AND THE ELECTION
PROCESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS ONEROUS.
EXPENSIVE -- COMES AT A HIGH TAG --
FOR LEGAL FEES -- IN COMPARISON
TO JUST HAVE A STATES THAT.
IF YOU HAVE A VALID CLAIM SOME
DOESN'T PAY THE RENT --
SOMEBODY'S DOING SOMETHING
ILLEGAL AND THERE AND THEIR UNIT
THAT.
INSTEAD OF MONTHS -- IT COULD
TAKE A FEW WEEKS.
AND YOU CAN CLEAR THAT UNIT UP
ALLOWING TENANTS TO ORGANIZE.
AND TO I GUESS IN SOME WAYS AND
MY BEGIN TURNING TO FORM A KIND
OF A CLAUSE LIKE CLASS ACTION
SUIT AGAINST THE A LANDLORD THAT --
SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO TO
MANAGE AND GOVERNOR PROPERTIES
OF THE WAY THEY SEE FIT.
CERTAINLY IF A TENANT.
DOESN'T LIKE.
A RENT DECREASE SERVER DOESN'T
LIKE THE THE RULES PUT DOWN BY --
A LANDLORD THAT HE MAY HAVE
SIMPLY PUT IN THE AND THE LEAST
THAT YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW THE CC
AND OURS OF THE EXISTING
DEVELOPMENT -- WITH REGARD TO
SAY CANNABIS OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT -- THERE CAN BE SOME MAJOR
DISAGREEMENTS AND AND AND THE
LEGAL FEES TO TURN TO MITIGATE
THE CIRCUMSTANCES CAN BE
[inaudible]
OUTRAGEOUS.
AND SO YOU KNOW IF YOU ARE
UNHAPPY TENANTS -- YOU CAN
CERTAINLY FIND OUT OF THE
BUILDING.
THE FINAL OF THE LANDLORD THAT
MIGHT BE MORE ALIGNED TO THE
KIND OF LIFE THAT YOU WANT TO
LIVE IN A PARTICULAR UNIT.
BUT THIS AGAIN IS WHAT I WOULD
CALL DEATH BY A THOUSAND SLICES
FOR INVESTORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE GOT THIS BLACK
CLOUD.
OVER CALIFORNIA WE SEEN IT WAS
SICK WELL WE SEE IT WITH
PROPERTY RIGHTS -- WE SEE WITH
OTHER CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS THAT.
PEOPLE ARE JUST GETTING FED UP.
AND THEY'RE DIVESTING.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY
FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES THAT I'VE
KNOWN -- INCLUDING FAMILY THAT
HAVE.
COMPLETELY DIVESTED OF THEIR
INTEREST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND MOVE THOSE AS
VESTMENTS.
VIA.
METHODS LIKE TEN THIRTY ONE
EXCHANGES AND TAX DEFERRED --
MECHANISMS -- TO GO TO A PLACE
WHERE.
THE BUSINESS CLIMATE THE IS
BETTER SO.
YOU KNOW WE CAN CONTINUE DOWN
THIS PATH -- BUT MY FRIENDS I'M
GONNA.
PREDICT THAT.
WITHIN A FEW YEARS WE ARE NOT
GOING TO SEE THE ROBUST REVENUE
STREAMS THAT WE SEE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE FRANKLY
THE PEOPLE THAT.
WANTED TO BE ENTREPRENEURS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WERE
STIFLED FROM DOING SO AND
THERE'S SO MUCH COMPETITION NOW --
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES.
THERE ARE SO MANY BENEFICIARIES
OF OF ENTREPRENEURS THAT WERE
FORMALLY FROM CALIFORNIA THAT
HAVE MOVED OUT OF THE OUT OF THE
STATE.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER REASON NOW.
FOR LANDLORDS BIG SMALL. TO SAY
ENOUGH.
IS ENOUGH.
LET US MANAGE OUR PROPERTIES WE
WORK OUR HEARTS AND SOULS LIKE
SOME OF MY FRIENDS DID AND
BUYING ONE PROPERTY AND THEN
BUYING TO AND THEN BUYING.
THREE AND THEY TRY TO HIM THESE
PROPERTIES.
THROUGH THEIR GENERATIONS TO
THEIR TO THEIR KIDS TO MANAGE TO
INVEST IN THEIR PROPERTIES BUT
WHEN YOU START TALKING ABOUT
RENT CONTROLS AND TENET WRITES
THAT -- COULD USE THE LEGAL
SYSTEM TO THEIR ADVANTAGE --
WE'RE GOING DOWN A SLIPPERY
SLOPE.
AND FRANKLY -- ENTREPRENEURS ARE
GONNA GO WHERE THERE -- ABLE TO
DO BUSINESS AND MAKE A PROFIT I
KNOW THAT'S A DIRTY WORD FOR
MANY VIEW ON THE FLOOR THE
SENATE BUT ACTUALLY MAKE A
PROFIT -- THEY'RE GONNA GO WHERE
THE PATH OF LEAST RESISTANCE
WILL TAKE THEM THIS IS ANOTHER
BILL.
THE FORCE LANDLORDS THAT HAVE
BEEN IN THE STATE FOR MANY MANY
YEARS OF PROVIDED QUALITY
HOUSING FOR SO MANY.
IF YOU START PUTTING THESE C<c.cyan></c>
AS A RENT CONTROLS ON THESE
LANDLORDS IF THEY DO KEEP THOSE
PROPERTIES ARE NOT CAN INVEST IN
THOSE PROPERTIES.
IF THEY COULD ONLY GET A LIMITED
RATE OF RETURN.
AND WE'LL HAVE SUBSTANDARD
HOUSING FOR MANY PEOPLE MUCH
THOSE REASONS ARE TO KNOW THAT
SB FIVE OR NINE THANK YOU
STUDENTS SENATOR STONE FOR THE
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
JACKSON.
IS THANK YOU AS SOMEONE WHO WAS
AT ONE POINT A RELUCTANT
LANDLORD I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
I AM FRANKLY TIRED OF HEARING
HOW PEOPLE ARE GOING TO LEAVE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
POINTED OUT.
THAT THE EXPLAIN WHY THE FOUR OH
FIVE FREEWAY IS ALWAYS CONGESTED
IF PEOPLE AREN'T LEAVING THEY'RE
GOING FROM PLACE TO PLACE I CAN.
VOUCH FOR THE ONE A ONE IS BEING
IN SIMILAR CIRCUMSTANCES WITH
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD IF YOU OWN PROPERTY YOU
NEED TO BE RESPONSIBLE.
FOR PROFITS A GOOD THING AND
SEWER PEOPLE AND THIS IS A BILL
THAT YOU'RE SIMPLY REINFORCES
WHAT IS EXISTING LAW.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE BAD
TENANT WHO'S DESTROYING THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OR SHOOTING OFF
FIREARMS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
LEGALLY ALREADY LEGALLY
AUTHORIZED RIGHTS. TO ENSURE
THAT LANDLORDS ALSO ABIDE BY
THEM.
THAT'S ALL THIS BILL DOES.
IT ALSO ALLOWS TENANTS TO BE
ABLE TO COME TOGETHER AND HAVE A
VOICE.
AND NOT BE A PUNISH FORD WITH A
FICTION.
THAT'S ONLY FAIR AND REASONABLE
I THINK IN TODAY'S WORLD WHERE
THERE ARE FAR TOO FEW UNITS.
OF FOR PEOPLE THAN THERE ARE
PEOPLE THEMSELVES SO -- AGAIN.
IT'S A FICTION WHEN WE KEEP
HEARING ABOUT ALL THOSE PEOPLE
LEAVING CALIFORNIA WE STILL GOT
MORE THAN ENOUGH TO TAKE CARE OF
OUR ECONOMY KEEP IT GOING IN A
ROBUST FASHION.
THIS IS A BILL ABOUT FAIRNESS
FAIRNESS DOES NOT MEAN WE CAN'T
HAVE PROFIT IT JUST MEANS THERE
HAS TO BE PROFIT WITH FAIRNESS
AND WITH THAT I ASKED FOR MY
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON CENTER
BORDERS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THE CALIFORNIA VOTERS IN THIS
LAST -- ARE IN THIS LAST CYCLE.
VOTED DOWN RENT CONTROL.
IN MY OPINION.
AND I THINK THE MOTIVATIONS OF A
THE AUTHOR -- AND I THINK I
THINK THE THEY ARE [inaudible]
BASED.
WITH IN GOOD INTENTIONS.
BUT BECAUSE CALIFORNIA VOTERS
VOTED AGAINST RENT CONTROL.
THIS IS A BACK DOOR TOWARD RENT
CONTROL.
WHEN YOU CREATE A? FIVE FIVE
TENANTS [inaudible]
BEGINNING UNITS.
IT IS ONLY A MOMENT OR TWO
BEFORE YOU'LL START GETTING INTO
NEGOTIATING -- ON THE COST OF
RENT ITSELF.
AND AS A COLLECTIVE MEASURE
THAT'S EXACTLY WHERE THIS IS
GOING TO GO THIS IS A BACK DOOR
TOWARD RENT CONTROL IN.
I THINK IN CONTESTS TO WHAT --
THE WILL OF THE CALIFORNIA
VOTERS EXPRESS IN THIS LAST
CYCLE I WOULD STRONGLY URGE A NO
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BORDERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
CABALLERO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT -- I WAY I DIDN'T
PREPARE TO RISE AND SPEAK ON
THIS TODAY BUT BUT I FEEL
COMPELLED TO DO SO BECAUSE I
WANT TO I WANT TO JUST SAY FOR
THE RECORD THAT THERE'S NO WAY
THAT THIS IS A BACK DOOR TO RENT
CONTROL THAT IS NOT.
THE INTENT OF OF THE BILL AS I
UNDERSTOOD IT -- AND AND QUITE
FRANKLY THIS IS REALLY JUST A
RESTATEMENT OF WHAT.
CURRENT CASE LAW SAYS ABOUT THE
RIGHTS OF TENANTS ON THEY ARE IN
A VERY DIFFICULT POSITION MANY
TIMES WHEN IT COMES TO
NEGOTIATING WITH THEIR LANDLORDS
OVER -- WHAT WHAT THE CONDITIONS
OF THE RENTAL AGREEMENT ARE MANY
TIMES IT'S TAKE IT OR LEAVE IT
IN IN IN MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES
WHERE WE HAVE A VERY VERY LOW
VACANCY RATE -- IT'S TAKE IT OR
LEAVE IT AND IT'S REALLY VERY
EXPENSIVE -- AND AND YOU HAVE NO
RIGHT SO -- I I JUST WANT TO
COMMEND MY COLLEAGUE FOR FOR
THIS BILL I I THINK -- IT IT
REALLY IS JUST A A STATEMENT OF
WHAT STATE LAW ALREADY ALREADY --
EXPECTS.
THANK YOU CENTER CABALLERO
SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
REAL ESTATE IS A WEALTH BUILDING
OPPORTUNITY -- BUT IT'S ALSO A
LOT OF WORK.
LAST YEAR WE HAD PROP TEN ON THE
BALLOT WE HAD A HEARING IT WAS
INTERESTING TO SEE HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS CAME UP AND SPOKE IN.
THAT THEY HAD PURCHASED.
A PROPERTY AND THEY'RE READY TO
GET OUT -- SO MAYBE WERE
ENCOURAGING.
PEOPLE.
TO JUST BY.
INDIVIDUAL HOMES AND AND NOT.
CONSOLIDATED BY LARGER.
UNITS WITH MORE THAN ONE OR TWO
YOU KNOW MAYBE FOR PLEXUS A
PLEXUS BE WERE GOING TO
DISCOURAGE.
THAT A LITTLE BIT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR HOUSING.
BUT IT RENTAL PROPERTY IS HARD
WORK.
I'VE BEEN THERE IT'S A IT'S A
DIFFICULT TASK IN IN AND IF WE
KEEP ADDING MORE -- TO TO THAT.
DIFFICULTY THAT DOES NOT BODE
WELL FOR CALIFORNIA -- BUT ARE
YOU JUST LOOK AT THE LIST OF
THOSE THAT ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL -- THE WHOLE INDUSTRY IS
TELLING YOU THAT THIS IS TOO
ONEROUS.
AND JUST MAYBE TO ROUTE TO
RESPOND TO ONE COMMENT THAT THE
NET MIGRATION OUT OF CALIFORNIA.
HAS BEEN.
DOCUMENTED IN AND WE'RE SEEING
MORE PEOPLE MOVE OUT THEN MOVE
IN. TWO OTHER STATES FROM OTHER
STATES SO SB FIVE TWENTY NINE I
I URGE A NO VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU CENTER MORLOCK SEVERAL
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IN
MEMBERS BOB.
I TO AM CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
BILL -- SOME WAS RECENTLY SAID
HERE ON THE FLOOR THAT IT'S SORT
OF A FALLACY THAT YOU KNOW.
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING AND THAT KIND
OF THING BUT THE HOOVER
INSTITUTE THERE ARE -- ECONOMIC
THINK TANK OFF THE CAMPUS OF
STANFORD -- RECOMMENDED A BOOK
TO ME A FEW YEARS BACK IN THE
TITLE OF IT WAS HOW MONEY WALKS.
THE TALK ABOUT CORPORATIONS
LEAVING AS WELL AS INDIVIDUALS
AND WHAT'S INTERESTING THE TWO
MAIN DEMOGRAPHICS THAT ARE
LEAVING ARE HIGHLY EDUCATED
YOUNG PROFESSIONALS BETWEEN THE
AGES OF TWENTY FIVE AND THIRTY
NINE YEARS OLD THE OTHER.
ONE IS UPPER MIDDLE CLASS PEOPLE
THERE ARE ABLE -- AFFORD TO BE A
BELIEVE THE STATE OF COURSE THE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES.
AND SO -- I DO THINK WE HAVE
SOME CONCERNS IT OR SOME THINGS
THAT SHOULD CONCERN US HERE IN
THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
AS MONEY WALKS -- BUT ALSO ON
THIS PROPERTY -- THE BILL RIGHT
NOW I I USED TO OWN AND I STILL
DO I SHOULD SAY MY WIFE RUNS IT
NOW BUT A PROPERTY MANAGEMENT
COMPANY.
AND SO WE DO KNOW PEOPLE THAT
THEIR OWN RENTALS AND AND THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS AND AND THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
WE'VE MET THAT ARE FULLY IN THE
STATE -- PROPERTY OWNERS WITH A
GOOD NUMBER RENTALS AND THEY'RE
GOING -- FOR STATES THAT -- HAVE
MORE A LITTLE BIT MORE A LOT
MORE ECONOMIC FREEDOM AND AND
NOT THE CONSTRAINTS WHICH MAKES
IT DIFFICULT -- TO BE ABLE TO
COMPETE AND SO ANYWAY FOR THOSE
REASONS -- I AM OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL -- BECAUSE I JUST AM A
BELIEVER IN PROPERTY RIGHTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORALE SENATOR
GALGIANI.
I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
ON BEHALF OF SOME OF THE MOM AND
POPS IN THE STATE WHO HAVE JUST
A FEW PROPERTIES AND DON'T HAVE
THE FINANCIAL WHEREWITHAL. TO
HIRE AN ATTORNEY AND GO TO COURT
AND GO THROUGH ALL THAT AND I
ALSO RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY MEMBER OF MINE.
WHO HAS A RENTAL PROPERTY IT'S
AN OLD VICTORIAN THAT WAS
CONVERTED INTO APARTMENTS AFTER
WORLD WAR -- TWO RANTS TO THOSE
WITH LOW INCOME WHO'S HAD A
DEATH THREAT AGAINST HIM AND LET
ME TELL YOU MEMBERS THAT WHEN
SOMETHING LIKE THAT HAPPENS
OTHER TENANTS.
IN THE BUILDING ARE FEARFUL TO
COME FORWARD AND THEY ARE NOT
WILLING. TO TO BE A WITNESS OR
TO TESTIFIED TO THE FACT THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT HAS HAPPENED --
SO I REGRETTABLY RISE TO OPPOSE
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU CENTER
GALGIANI CENTER BRADFORD.
MADAM PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AND I
WASN'T GOING TO SPEAK.
AS WELL BUT I'M LED TO LEND MY
VOICE TO THIS ISSUE BASED ON
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
IN LOS ANGELES RIGHT NOW.
LAST WEEK THEY STARTED AN
INVENTION OF A HUNDRED AND TWO
YEAR OLD WOMAN WHO HAS LIVED IN
A BUILDING FOR THIRTY YEARS. FOR
THIRTY YEARS A MOVE THAT WAS SO
EGREGIOUS SAID EVEN ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER STEPPED IN TO
OFFER THAT LAND SOME TYPE OF
SUPPORT. TO THIS WOMAN AND TRUE
THE PROPERTY OWNER HAS EVERY
RIGHT TO READ HIS PROPERTY TO
WHOEVER YOU WANT TO STATE.
HE NEEDS TO UNIT BAKARE IT SO
HIS DARKER MOVE AND AND I
UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE B.
MULTI UNIT -- BUILDING SO THEY
CAN POSSIBLY RETIRE IN THAT AND
THEIR OLD AGE -- LET FAMILY AND
FRIENDS MOVE THERE SO IT MAKES
SENSE BUT IN A MANNER WHICH THIS
WOMAN IS BEING AFFECTED WHERE
SHE HAS PAID AROUND ON TIME SHE
IS A GREAT TENNIS AGAIN.
THE BEEN THERE FOR THIRTY YEARS
AND THE REASON HE SAYS IS
BECAUSE SHE'S THE ONLY TENANT IN
MY BUILDING A HOUSE A MONTH THE
MONTH -- AGREEMENT AND HE HE
NEEDS FOLKS HAVE LONG TERM
RESEARCH LEASE AGREEMENT SO THIS
IS COMMON SENSE MEASURE AND AND
I STRONGLY US FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
SENATOR ALSO YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU TO ALL
MY COLLEAGUES TO OF VOICE
SUPPORT -- I FIND IT REALLY HARD
TO UNDERSTAND.
WHY WE WOULD?
DEFEND ONLY ONE SIDE WHICH IS
THE LANDLORDS.
AND NOT CONSIDER.
THE MEN AND WOMEN AND THE
FAMILIES WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO
PAY THEIR RENT.
PAID ON TIME MANY TIMES WITH TWO
OR THREE JOBS EVEN OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING TO DO THAT.
BUT WHAT THIS IS REALLY ALL
ABOUT IS SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
AMERICAN.
AND THAT IS THE RIGHT TO
ASSOCIATE WITH OTHERS FOR A
COMMON INTEREST.
THE DOCTORS HAVE AN ASSOCIATION
THE PILOTS HAVE AN ASSOCIATION
OUR CAUCUSES HAVE AN ASSOCIATION.
WE DO THAT SO THAT IN A
REASONABLE BALANCED WAY WE CAN
RAISE OUR ISSUES.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT.
IT'S IT'S IT'S DISTURBING TO
HEAR.
FOLKS DESCRIBE RENTERS AND
DEMONIZED.
DEMONIZED RENTERS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING EVERY DAY -- INSTEAD
OF APPRECIATING THAT PART OF
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE RENTERS WHICH IS MORE THAN
HALF OF THE PEOPLE IN THE STATE.
TO ASK YOU. TO CONSIDER THAT IN
MAKING YOUR DECISION.
AND AGAIN.
WE'RE SPENDING ENORMOUS AMOUNTS
OF MONEY IN.
PRODUCTION WE KNOW THAT'S
IMPORTANT WE HAVE TO PRODUCE
MORE HOUSING.
WE HAVE TO PRESERVE WHAT WE HAVE.
THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT PART
OF THE EQUATION.
BUT THAT'S GONNA TAKE SEVERAL
YEARS TO PRODUCE THE AMOUNT OF
HOUSING THAT WE NEED IN THE
MEANWHILE RENTERS CALIFORNIANS.
CALIFORNIANS ARE ASKING FOR SOME
RELIEF ALLOW THEM TO BE ABLE TO
JOIN TOGETHER.
AND BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT
PRESENCE IN THEIR APARTMENT
BUILDINGS WITH THEIR LANDLORD
AND THAT THE LANDLORD LISTEN TO
THEM IN A REASONABLE WAY.
SO COLLEAGUES THIS IS NOT ABOUT
RENT CONTROL I DON'T CARE WHAT
ANYBODY SAYS THIS IS ABOUT
WORKING FAMILIES.
TRYING TO STAY IN THEIR HOMES
AND THERE THEY ARE PART MEN'S.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ON AYE
VOTE.
THE CENTER ALSO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
BY ARCHULETA [inaudible]
NO ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL. FIVE FOR JUST
[inaudible]
NO BRADFORD.
BY CAL YET ALL [inaudible]
HI CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD.
NO THEY'RE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
NO GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI HILL [inaudible]
NO HUESO -- TITLE [inaudible]
NO JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LABOR [inaudible]
HI MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCKED.
NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER [inaudible]
BY KELSEY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
NOPE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
NUMBER.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THE CALL --
BILLS THAT WERE ON CALL
PREVIOUSLY UP RIGHT NOW WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE SENATOR JACKSON'S.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORE LUCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO.
I TWENTY SIX KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN SENATOR ALAN
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
BOOKS YOU MAY CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO -- TITLE [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO HAN. FIVE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS
EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE SENATOR ROTH MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MERRELL [inaudible]
HI.
EYES THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM THIRTY SENATOR CHIANG
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
I HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONNING [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
HI.
BY THIRTY SIX IN NEW ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT SENATOR RUBIO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONNING [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
HI.
I THIRTY FIVE NEW ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE SENATOR SKINNER
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
ICE TWENTY SIX KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY ONE SENATOR LEYVA
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MORRELL.
BY WIENER.
HI. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES -- TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY TWO SENATOR JACKSON
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
HI DODD [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO.
I SUI NINE KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU MEMBERS
WERE NOW MOVING BACK TO OUR
THIRD READING FILE ITEM THIRTY
FOUR SENATOR ALLEN ARE YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE THAT UP.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX EIGHTY SIX BY
SENATOR ALLEN AN ACT RELATING TO
PEOPLE SUPPORT SERVICES SENATOR
ALAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THIS
BILL SB SIX EIGHTY SIX
ESTABLISHES A GRANT PROGRAM TO
FIND. TWENTY PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO AID IMPLEMENTATION
OF COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTIONS THAT
IMPROVE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CHILDREN.
AND FAMILIES LIVING IN SOME OF
OUR MOST DISTRESSED
NEIGHBORHOODS.
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD PROGRAMS
PROVIDE ROBUST SYSTEMS OF
SUPPORT TO ALL CHILDREN IN THE
PARTICIPATING COMMUNITIES TO
GROW UP WITH ACCESS. TO HIGH
QUALITY EARLY CHILDHOOD PROGRAMS
SCHOOLS HEALTH SERVICES AND
RELIABLE SYSTEMS OF FAMILY.
AND COMMUNITY SUPPORT.
WITH 70% CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
LIVING COMMUNITIES OF CONSTRUED
POVERTY.
NO OVER A NEARLY TWO MILLION
CHILDREN LIVING IN POVERTY
OVERALL.
INNOVATIVE PRACTICAL APPROACHES
ARE NEEDED TO ADDRESS.
THE CHALLENGES THAT THEY FACE
THIS IS A PRIORITY OF THE END
CHILDHOOD POVERTY CAMPAIGN THE
BILL IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
MASS FOR AND I'VE OF THANK YOU
CENTER OUR MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
BY ARCHULETA I ATKINS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
BY CHAIN I DODD.
I THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I'M ACQUIRE BY.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH.
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER BY [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
OUR CASKEY BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
BY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
GROWTH -- TITLE HI.
I IS THIRTY KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES -- TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY FIVE CENTER STONE STERN
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN THIRTY BY
SENATOR STERN AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT.
THUNDERSTORMS.
THANK YOU VERY PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A
COMMISSION ON THE FUTURE OF WORK
AND WE'RE CALLING TECH EQUITY.
WE FEEL THAT.
THE PACE OF GOVERNMENT IS
ACTUALLY NOT CATCHING UP TO THE
PACE OF INNOVATION.
WHETHER IT'S ISSUES LIKE
AUTOMATION AND THE RISKS OR
OPPORTUNITIES THEY PRESENT TO
THE WORKFORCE BUT ALSO.
THE VALUE OF OUR DATA AND HOW
THAT DATA IS BEING USED -- BY
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES RIGHT NOW --
WHETHER IT'S ABOUT PRIVACY
CONCERNS IT'S SOME MAY HAVE AND
I DO APPRECIATE THE CENTER FOR
SANTA BARBARA'S INPUT.
ON THIS PROCESS IS MOVE THROUGH
COMMITTEE -- BUT ALSO ON THE
OVERALL VALUE PROPOSITIONS THAT
WE'RE ENGAGING WHEN WE'RE USING
FREE PRODUCTS. FOR WHICH WE WE
IN TURN.
GIVE OVER OUR DATA -- WHAT VALUE
ARE WE GETTING IN RETURN FOR
THAT EXCHANGE THIS BILL WOULDN'T
PRE DECIDE ANY OUTCOMES BUT
WOULD MERELY SET UP AS A PROCESS
OF EXPERTS?
AFTER THE STATE TO AUGMENT WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S ALREADY PUT IN
PLACE WITH HIS COMMISSION ON THE
FUTURE WORK. TO ADD THIS TECH
EQUITY COMPONENT -- AND ALSO
INCLUDES IN THE PRIVACY ISSUES
BROUGHT UP IN COMMITTEE.
I THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
CENTER HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SADDAM
I RISE TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
JUST WANT TO SHARE A COUPLE OF
THOUGHTS BECAUSE YOU KNOW OFTEN
WHEN WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF
CHANGE IT'S HARD FOR US.
TO DETERMINE WE'RE SEEING BITS
AND PIECES OF IT IN OUR
RESPECTIVE LIVES.
BUT YOU KNOW WE HAVE SEEN THIS
THIS SHIFT IN HISTORY BEFORE BUT
I DON'T THINK ONE THIS BIG.
IN TERMS OF WHAT WORK IS GONNA
LOOK LIKE IN THE FUTURE HOW DO
WE PAY FOLKS WHAT IS THE GROWTH
RATE BETWEEN THE BOTH OF CAPITOL
AGAINST THE GROWTH OF WORK AND
HOW DO WE CREATE A SOCIETY THIS
BOTH EQUITABLE AND JUST ON HE
ONE HAND.
STILL INVOLVES PEOPLE WITH THE
DIGNITY OF WORK AND YET TAKES
ADVANTAGE OF THIS TECHNOLOGY
REVOLUTION THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
EXTRAORDINARY.
WHEN I STARTED SERVING IN
GOVERNMENT SOME YEARS AGO WE HAD
THESE LITTLE PAGERS OUR PHONES
LOOK LIKE BRICKS AND WE DIDN'T
HAVE GOOGLE OR ANY OF THIS OTHER
FANCY SEMANSKY STUFF AND NOW
IT'S OVER TAKE IN OUR LIVES?
AND THE RATE OF CHANGE IS SO
EXTRAORDINARY I WANT TO JUST
ECHO THE AUTHOR'S COMMENTS HERE
BECAUSE IT REALLY IS.
NOT JUST THE NATURE OF THE
CHANGE BUT THE RATE OF CHANGE WE
IN GOVERNMENT OFTEN ARE SLOWLY
DELIVERED IF AND WE WANT TO BE
DELIVERED AND WE WANT TO BE
INCLUSIVE WE WANT TO ADD OTHER
FOLKS INTO THE PROCESS.
AND YET THE RATE OF THIS
DISRUPTION IS NOTHING LESS THAN
EXTRAORDINARY SO ALL I CAN SAY
IS THAT I SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
AND HOPE THAT THE COMMISSION ON
THE FUTURE OF WORKS.
WELL -- WORK WORKS WITH THE
DILIGENCE AND DISPATCH NECESSARY
TO HAVE A MEANINGFUL INPUT
OTHERWISE THERE WILL QUIRK WILL
BE YESTERDAY'S NEWS AS WELL AS
FOR AN ALBUM.
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG
THUNDERSTORM WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU I HEARTILY
CONCUR WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AND
APPRECIATE HIS WORK.
TO THINKING THROUGH -- NOT JUST
THE FUTURE OF WORK BUT IN THE
ACHE IN THE CONTEXT OF TAX
REFORM IN THE BROADER CHALLENGES
WERE FACING IS A STATE TO
UNDERSTAND.
A STATE THAT'S NOT JUST BASED ON
A GOODS ECONOMY AND ON
MANUFACTURING BUT ON A SERVICE
SECTOR AND INCREASINGLY ON A
DIGITAL ECONOMY THEY REALLY
BELIES THIS SORT OF REGIONAL
NATURE OF OF OUR ENTIRE
GOVERNMENT REGULATORY STRUCTURE
SO.
IT'S TIME TO CATCH UP I THINK
THIS BILL MAKES AN EFFORT
TOWARDS DOING THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE EYES
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY SEVEN SENATOR SKINNER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR
SKINNER AND ACTUALLY IN HOUSING.
SENATOR SKINNER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS BILL IS --
QUITE DIFFERENT -- THEN THE ONE
I STARTED WITH -- THERE WERE
SOME THINGS IN THE ORIGINAL BILL
THAT HAVE NOW BEEN INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SO
INAPPROPRIATE.
THE BILL WAS REDUCED TO CHEST
LIFTING THE SUNSET ON A LAW THAT
WAS PASSED DURING THE MORTGAGE
CRISIS.
AND THAT LAW.
REQUIRES A NINETY DAY WRITTEN
NOTICE TO RENTERS IN CASE THERE
IS A FOR CLOSURE.
SO WITH THAT SAID THE SIMPLY SB
EIGHTEEN CHEST LIFTS THE SUNSET
ON THAT REQUIREMENT UNDER
FORECLOSURES AND WITH THAT I
ASKED FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL.
I PORGES BY BRADFORD.
BY CAMBIADO.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
BY GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
[inaudible]
I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
I WAS SO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONNING.
BY MORE LUCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
BY AMBERG [inaudible]
BARBARA COUNTY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARCHULETA [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
I JONES.
BY MORE LOCK.
HI NIELSEN.
HI.
I THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE
SENATOR ALAN.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FORTY THREE BY SENATOR
ALLEN AQUILINE GREENHOUSE GASES
SENATOR ALAN.
THE PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS THIS
BILL DIRECTS THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD TO CONDUCT THE STUDY --
DETERMINING THE FEASIBILITY OF
ASSESSING THE CARBON INTENSITY
OF ALL THE RETAIL PRODUCTS
SUBJECT TO THE SALES AND USE TAX
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND TO GIVE US INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT IT WOULD LOOK LIKE IF WE
WERE.
TO CREATE A AND REVENUE --
CARBON BASED -- SYSTEM WITH
REGARDS TO OUR SALES TAX SO
BASED ON THEIR BOARDS
TERMINATION WE CAN THEN CONSIDER
WHETHER NOT REPLACING -- THE
SALES TAX IS WORTH PURSUING I
LET ME JUST REITERATE THIS ONLY
CALLS FOR STUDY -- IT IS VERY
POSSIBLE IF NOT PROBABLE THAT
THE AIR BOARD WOULD COME BACK TO
US AND SAY HEY -- LOVE THE IDEA
CONCEPTUALLY BUT TOO DIFFICULT
TO IMPLEMENT -- IN PRACTICE --
BUT WE THINK WE OUGHT TO GIVE IT
A SHOT BECAUSE WERE FACING SOME
ENORMOUS CHALLENGES AND WE'RE
TRYING TO CREATE A SYSTEM THAT
DOES A BETTER JOB.
OF INCENTIVIZING DISINCENTIVE
RISING BEHAVIOR THAT WILL HELP
US MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS IN
THIS OUGHT TO BE PART OF THE THE
MIX OF THINGS THAT WE CONSIDER.
MY WORK WHEN WE THINK ABOUT HOW
WE MOVE FORWARD BUT IT IS IT IS.
JUST A STUDY IT'S REVENUE
NEUTRAL THE IDEA IS IT IS IT
WOULD BE ABSOLUTE REVENUE
NEUTRAL SO THERE WOULDN'T BE.
ANY -- AGGREGATE INCREASE IN
TAXES I THINK IT'S A STUDY THE
DESERVES SOME EXAMINATION AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER ELLEN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BATES.
NOBEL.
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD.
HI THERE ARE SO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO HI -- TITLE
[inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible] FIVE JONES
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
BYPORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
BY STONE.
NO NUMBER.
IOWA CASKEY.
AYE WIENER [inaudible]
HI WILK [inaudible]
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
GALGIANI.
I TWENTY FIVE KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS REMAIN BACK TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR DORADO.
PASS TEMPORARILY VERY GOOD OF
FILE ITEM FORTY SENATOR WIENER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SAID ABOUT ONE FORTY FIVE A
SENATOR WINNER ENACT WILLING TO
SEX OFFENDERS CENTER WIENER.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH BY THE
PRESIDENT OUR COLLEAGUE SENATE
BILL -- ONE FORTY FIVE WILL FOR
ONCE AND FOR ALL AND
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHLY
DISCRIMINATORY TREATMENT OF
SPECIFIC SOCKS SOCKS BUYERS
STATE SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY LAW --
BY GIVING COURT'S DISCRETION
OVER ALL OF THESE CASES TO
DETERMINE WHETHER SOMEONE SHOULD
OR SHOULDN'T GO ON THE SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY --
SPECIFICALLY SENATE BILL FORTY
ONE FORTY FIVE AND
DISCRIMINATION.
AGAINST LGBT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM FORCES WELL
TO BE TWO YOUNG PEOPLE ON THE
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY.
I WENT OPPOSITE SEX COUPLES --
WOULD NOT BE FORCED ONTO THE
REGISTRY WE NEED TO AND THIS
DISCRIMINATION.
UNDER CURRENT LAW IF A YOUNG
PERSON HAS VOLUNTARY SEXUAL
INTERCOURSE WITH A MINOR EACH.
FOURTEEN TO SEVENTEEN AND IS NO
MORE THAN TEN YEARS OLDER THAN
THE MINOR.
THEN THE MAN THEN THE OFFENSE IS
NOT MANDATORY I AND REGISTRATION
IN OTHER WORDS IF THERE'S
VAGINAL INTERCOURSE -- IN THAT
AGE RANGE THE CORE IS NOT
REQUIRED. TO ORDER THE PERSON TO
BECOME A REGISTERED ON THE SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY.
ON THE OTHER HAND.
IF ANY OTHER FORM OF INTERCOURSE.
OCCURS SPECIFICALLY ANAL SEX OR
ORAL SEX.
THEN THE COURT MUST PUT THE
PERSON.
ON THE SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY.
THE REASON FOR THIS DISTINCTION
IS THAT IN THE NINETEEN FORTIES
WHEN THE SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY
WAS CREATED IN CALIFORNIA.
A SAME SEX SEXUAL CONDUCT NON
VAGINAL INTERCOURSE WAS ILLEGAL
IN OUR STATE.
DIE PROHIBITION WAS REPEALED IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES BUT THE
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY.
WAS NEVER UPDATED.
AS A RESULT -- LGBT YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVE TO BE PUT ON THE SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY IN SITUATIONS
WHEN OPPOSITE SEX COUPLES.
DON'T WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
TREATS ALL FORM OF INTERCOURSE.
IN EXACTLY THE SAME WAY.
THE VAGINAL INTERCOURSE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN TREATED ON OUR SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY WE ARE NOT
CREATING A NEW SYSTEM.
OR A NEW STRUCTURE WE ARE JUST
ASKING THAT ALL FORMS OF
INTERCOURSE.
BE TREATED THE SAME WAY -- UNDER
THE LAW.
HI THIS BILL.
THE SCREEN OR EXCUSE ME VOTE LAW
CURRENTLY DISCRIMINATES AGAINST
ALL TO BE TO YOUNG PEOPLE -- BUT
IT ALSO LEADS TO BIZARRE AND
IRRATIONAL RESULTS. FOR ALL
YOUNG PEOPLE GAY AND STRAIGHT.
WE HAVE STRONG SUPPORT FROM THIS
BILL -- FROM THE LGBT COMMUNITY
BUT ALSO FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT AT
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ASSOCIATION.
AND THE POLICE CHIEF SUPPORT
THIS BILL -- BECAUSE THE SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY THAT IS
PUTTING PEOPLE ON TO THE
REGISTER YOU DO NOT.
OPPOSE HARM OR RISK TO ANYONE.
UNDERMINES EFFECTIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
IT'S TIME TO END THE
DISCRIMINATION ON OUR SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY COLLEAGUES
IT'S TIME TO STOP CRIMINALIZING --
LGBT YOUNG PEOPLE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU CENTER
WINNER MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
BURGESS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
BY HILL.
I WHISTLE.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
BY WORK OWSKI BY WINNER
[inaudible]
BY WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GROWTH -- TITLE [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
RUBIO STONE [inaudible]
WILK.
I TWENTY FOUR KNOWS TO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON THE
FILE ITEM FORTY TWO SENATOR
BRADFORD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY NUMBERCENTER BRADFORD AN ACT RELATING
TO CRIMINAL PROCEDURE.
CENTER BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PESIDENT
PRESIDENT SB TWO SIXTY NINE
WOULD PROVIDE JUST AUTOMATIC
COMPENSATION TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE WRONGLY CONVICTED AND HAVE
PROVEN THEIR INNOCENCE THROUGH A
COURT OF LAW.
UNDER CURRENT LAW INDIVIDUAL
MUST PETITION THE CALIFORNIA
VICTIMS COMP THE COMPENSATION
BOARD WITHIN TWO YEARS OF THE
RELEASE IN ORDER TO RECEIVE
COMPENSATION.
THIS CLAIM PROCESS TAKES YEARS
TO COMPLETE IT'S EXPENSIVE
INVOLVES LENT THE LITIGATION
AFTER THEY HAVE ALREADY BEEN
FOUND INNOCENT BY THE COURTS.
THE BILL REMOVES A TEAR TO YOUR
DEADLINE.
I INDIVIDUAL ASKED -- WAIT THE
FILE FOR COMPENSATION OUR OR
SHARE WITHIN THAT TWO YEARS AND
IT PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL
SEVENTY DOLLARS PER DAY.
SPENT ON PAROLE UNDER STATE
SUPERVISION OR ON THE SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY.
WE CANNOT GET PEOPLE'S LIVES
BACK BUT WE CAN TRY TO MAKE HIM
HOLD JUST.
LAST WEEK WE CELEBRATE OUR
RECOGNIZE THE THIRTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE CENTRAL PARK
JOGGER WHO WAS BRUTALLY ATTACKED.
AND WE SAW WERE FIVE INNOCENT.
AFRICAN AMERICAN MEN SPENT
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS IN PRISON
FOR SOMETHING THEY DIDN'T DO.
AND THEY WERE JUST COMPENSATED.
AS A A GROUP OF FORTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS THIS IS FAIR AND
JUST COMPENSATION IT WILL AVOID
THOSE COSTLY SETTLEMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY
FOUR SENATOR ARCHULETA.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR OH FIVE
PASSENGER ARCHULETA AN ACT
RELATING TO SOLID WASTE
[inaudible]
SENATE ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
TODAY I'M A REP -- PRESENTING SB.
FOUR OH FIVE WHICH WILL CREATE A
PILOT PROJECT FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY TO DEMONSTRATE THE
VIABILITY OF USING RECYCLED
GRINDING. TO REPAIR A ROADS AND
MAINTAIN OUR ROADS.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE PASSED.
SB ONE WHICH ALLOCATES
APPROXIMATELY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY OVER THE NEXT
TEN YEARS. FOR REPAIRING
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE ROACH.
IF THE STATE DOES.
IF THE STATE DOES NOTHING TO
ADDRESS THE CURRENT REPAVING
PROCESS MILLIONS OF TONS.
OF ASPHALT PAVING WILL BE
STOCKPILED THROUGHOUT OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THERE IS NO SECONDARY MARK FOR
THE STOCK.
THIS MATERIAL.
CALTRANS CURRENTLY ALLOWS FOR UP
240% OF THESE RECYCLED BY NEEDS
TO BE ADDED TO NEW ASPHALT IN
STREET.
IN REHABILITATION PROJECTS.
HOWEVER THIS BILL INTENDS TO SET
UP A PILOT PROJECT.
THAT WILL DEMONSTRATE A NEW RE
PAVING PROCESS THAT REUSES
8521100% OF THESE GRANDAGE.
SIMILAR WORK HAS BEEN CURRENTLY
UNDER WAY IN COMPANIES IN
INDIANA NEW YORK.
NOT ONLY WILL THIS BILL -- AND
THE PROCESS THAT IT WILL PRODUCE
WHAT REDUCE THE LOOMING
ENVIRONMENTAL PROBLEMS THAT COME
FROM HAVING THESE HUGE ASPHALT
PILES.
IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES NEAR OUR SCHOOLS.
THERE'S ALSO THE ADDED BENEFIT
OF REDUCING GREENHOUSE EMISSIONS
EMISSIONS.
THAT THERE WILL BE NO NEED TO
DIG UP AND MIND FOR ADDITIONAL
ASPHALT AND TRANSPORTED.
FROM WORK AREA TO WORK AREA THAT
OFTEN ARE SO FAR AWAY THAT THE
ORIGINAL MONIES SITE.
TURNS OUT TO BE A DETRIMENTAL
PROCESS IN ITSELF.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES I WILL RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
CENTER HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
BRIEFLY THIS IS A REALLY GOOD
IDEA.
GOOD IDEA BECAUSE AGAIN IT DEALS
WITH RECYCLING I HAVE -- ASPHALT
PILES AND COMMITTEES I REPRESENT
THE STUFF BLOWS ALL OVER THE
PLACE AND IMPACTS PEOPLE'S HOMES
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO BE MORE
RESPONSIBLE AND THOUGHTFUL WITH
RESPECT.
TO A PROJECT LIKE THIS IS A GOOD
THING ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG FOR
THE DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SAN ARCHULETA
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU.
ONCE AGAIN MY COLLEAGUES RIGHT
NOW CURRENTLY ELEVEN SENATE
DISTRICT FOURTEEN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT ARE FACING THE SAME
PROBLEM IT'S GOING TO GET WORSE.
I RESPECTED FOR ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
MEMBERS THIS IS A CANNED IT FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE EYES
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE
SENATOR HILL MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOR TWENTY FIVE A
SENATOR HILL AND ACT RULING
HEALING ARTS CENTER HILL THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SB FOUR
TWENTY FIVE REQUIRES HOSPITALS
CLINICS AND OTHER HEALTH HEALTH
FACILITIES. TO REPORT
ALLEGATIONS OF PATIENTS SEXUAL
ABUSE ANOTHER SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
BY MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS TO THE
APPROPRIATE STATE LICENSING
AUTHORITY WITHIN FIFTEEN DAYS SB
FOUR TWENTY FIVE CLOSES LEGAL
LOOPHOLES THAT CAN ALLOW A
SUBJECT OF REPEATED.
SEXUAL ABUSE AND MISCONDUCT
COMPLAINTS TO WORK AT A HEALTH
FACILITY FOR YEARS BECAUSE THE
RELEVANT REGULATORY BOARD IS NOT
NOTIFIED BY THE FACILITY.
OF THE ALLEGATIONS AGAINST A
LICENSEE ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL
ABUSE FOR MISCONDUCT BY DOCTORS
AND OTHER MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
MUST BE REPORTED SWIFTLY TO THE
APPROPRIATE LICENSING BOARD FOR
REVIEW.
SO THAT REGULATORS CAN DETERMINE
WHETHER TO CONDUCT AN
INDEPENDENT CONFIDENTIAL
INVESTIGATION.
JUST BECAUSE AN ALLEGATION IS
REPORTED IN NO WAY MEANS THE
MEDICAL BOARD WILL AUTOMATICALLY
BEGIN AN INVESTIGATION ALL
COMPLAINTS SENT TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD.
ARE COULD CONFIDENTIAL AND FIRST
REVIEWED BY A DOCTOR ON STAFF.
TO DETERMINE IF FURTHER ACTION
IS EVEN WARRANTED.
STATE REGULATORY BOARDS CANNOT
FULFILL THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES
TO PROTECT PATIENTS IN OTHER
CONSUMERS IF THEY ARE NOT
NOTIFIED OF THESE ALLEGATIONS
INVOLVING THEIR LICENSEES.
THE FAILURE TO DO SO SHIELDS BAD
ACTORS WILL EXPOSING PATIENTS TO
GREATER RISKS.
AS YOU ARE ALL FAMILIAR WITH THE
U. S. C. AND DOCTOR TYNDALL
SCANDAL WHERE THERE WERE
MULTIPLE COMPLAINTS OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT FOR DECADES.
NONE OF THE PRIOR COMPLAINTS
WERE REPORTED TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD.
THIS IS WHY THE MANDATORY
REPORTING WITHIN FIFTEEN DAYS TO
THE MEDICAL BOARD IS ESSENTIAL
WE KNOW THAT HOSPITAL'S TAKING
CARE OF THESE ISSUES THEMSELVES
DOES NOT WORK.
JUST LIKE IT DIDN'T WORK FOR THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH IS WHY WE
FINALLY CHANGE THAT.
I'VE BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND I'M
CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO SATISFY THE REMAINDER OF
THEIR CUT MINOR COMPLAINTS AND
CONCERNS.
MEMBERS THIS IS A BIPARTISAN
MEASURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER HILL MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BATES.
NOBEL HI PORCHES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER BY GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
HI.
MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
BY THE MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
HI.
NUMBER.
BY WHAT CASSIE I WINNER
[inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS BURGESS [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORE LUCK [inaudible]
HI. FIVE THIRTY TWO KNOWS FIVE
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO A FILE ITEM FORTY
SEVEN SENATOR STERN.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
THAT ABOUT FOUR SEVENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR STERN AND ACT RELATED
WILDLIFE CENTER CERTAIN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. THIRTY YEARS AGO THE
LEGISLATURE'S AND THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
PROTECT RAPIDLY DISAPPEARING
WILDLIFE HABITAT BY CREATING THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND. FOR
DECADES THIS PHONE IS PROTECTED
MORE THAN A MILLION ACRES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING HABITAT FOR DEAR.
OUR MOUNTAIN LIONS OTHER
THREATENED SPECIES AS WELL AS
WETLANDS AND WILDLIFE CORRIDORS.
THIS IS NOT JUST A COASTAL ISSUE
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT'S HELPFUL.
FOR FARMERS FOR HUNTERS AND
RANCHERS -- FROM THE FURTHEST
NORTHERN ENDS OF THIS STATE.
OUT TO THE DESERT PLAINS IN DOWN
TO THE SOUTHERN COAST.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS MEASURE HAS
YIELDED BENEFITS STATEWIDE AND
THAT IT OUGHT TO CONTINUE SO SP
FOUR SEVENTY FOUR WOULD EXTEND
THIS FUN TO TWENTY FIFTY ONE
INSURING THAT.
CALIFORNIA CAN KEEP THIS
CRITICAL PROGRAM UP AND RUNNING.
THERE IS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION AND I KNOW THERE WERE --CONCERNS AT LEAST REYES BY THE
FARM URINE COMMITTEE AND I DID
COMMIT DURING THE COMMITTEE
PROCESS TO ENGAGE WITH THEM AND
I HOPE THAT IS BEEN RELATED BACK
TO YOU THAT.
THOSE MEETINGS HAVE OCCURRED --
THOSE CONVERSATIONS WILL
CONTINUE AND ANY AMENDMENTS
NEGOTIATED WITH THE FARM BUREAU
WILL BE ADOPTED IN THE ASSEMBLY.
BUT IT PRESENTLY FEEL LIKE THIS
BILL STANDS ON ITS OWN TWO FEET.
AS GOOD MEASURE FOR THE GOOD AS
STATED STATE CALIFORNIA WITHOUT
A RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN MEMBERS
CITY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
WE'RE JUST [inaudible]
HI BRADFORD.
I CAN BE AT ALL.
I CHIANG BY DODD.
BY THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
BY HILL.
I HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES.
HI LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN AYE STONE [inaudible]
HI NUMBER.
BY Y. CASKEY.
I WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
MORE LUCK.
BY THIRTY THREE KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT
SENATOR HER TADO.
YES MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FOR NINETY EIGHT BY
SENATOR TACO AN ACT RELATING TO
TRANSPORTATION CENTER TADO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS SB FOUR
NINE EIGHT IS A SHORTLINE
RAILROAD IMPROVEMENT ACT A BILL
TO IMPROVE RAIL ROAD
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN OUR
STATE BY CREATING A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAM FOR SHORTLINE RAIL
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENT
PROJECTS.
CALIFORNIA'S SHORT LINES HANDLE
APPROXIMATELY ONE TENTH OF THE
STATE'S CARLOAD FREIGHT.
AND ARE A CRITICAL LINK BETWEEN
MANY OF THE STATE'S FREE
INTENSIVE INDUSTRIES PORTS AND
PRINCIPAL TRADE CORRIDORS.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE GIVEN
THE INBOUND AND OUTBOUND FREIGHT
RAIL TRAFFIC IN CALIFORNIA IS
EXPECTED TO INCREASE.
BY APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY MILLION
TONS BY.
TWENTY FORTY WITH THAT PROJECTED
GROWTH COMES INCREASES IN TRUCK
TRAFFIC AND FREE BOTTLE NECKS
WHICH WILL RESULT IN AN INCREASE
IN EMISSIONS UNLESS MORE IS DONE
TO REHABILITATE THE SHORTLINE
RAIL SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BILL FOLLOWS THROUGH ON THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA STATE
RAIL PLAN RECOMMENDATION.
OF STATE INVESTMENT IN PROGRAMS
TO SUPPORT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS TO UPGRADE
THE STATE WIDE SHORTLINE
RAILROAD RAILROAD NETWORK.
IMPROVING SHORTLINE RAILROAD
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE TRACK RAIL
AND SPURS.
AFFORDS LOCALIZE AND STATE WIDE
ECONOMIC BENEFITS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COMMUNITIES
THAT SURE ANYONE OF THE TWENTY
SHORTLINE RAILROAD RAILROADS
LOCATED IN THE STATE.
LASTLY I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE LATE OPPOSITION HAS
A RISE IN BY SEVERAL SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES I
BELIEVE THAT THERE MAY TWENTIETH
LETTER DOESN'T HAVE THE BENEFIT
OF UNDERSTANDING AMENDMENTS I
TOOK AN APPROPRIATIONS. FOR THE
BILL THAT IS BEFORE YOU NOW AS
AMENDED ON MAY TWENTY FIRST.
FIRST THIS GRANT PROGRAM IS
CAPTAIN EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
AND WOULD NOT USE UP ALL THE
REMAINING PROP ONE BE FUNDING.
SECOND THIS GRANT PROGRAM WILL
BE FUNDED FROM THE ON A ON
ALLOCATED PROJECTS SAVINGS FROM
THE TREE QUARTERS IMPROVEMENT
FUND PROGRAM.
OF WHICH THERE ARE THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
MY BILL WOULDN'T TOUCH THE
THIRTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY PROGRAMMED BUT
REMAINED ON ALLOCATED.
THIS GRANT PROGRAM WOULD BE
DESIGNED WITH GUIDELINES SET BY
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AND EXPECT THAT THEY
WILL MAKE SURE THE FRAMEWORK
HONORS A WRECK.
THE PRESIDENT PREVIOUS ADOPTED
IN THE T. C. I. F. PROGRAM.
LASTLY I WOULD AGREE THAT THE T.
C. I. F.PROGRAM HAS BEEN.
A GREAT SUCCESS LEVERAGING OVER
TWO BILLION DOLLARS FOR
CALIFORNIA STREET CORRIDORS.
IN FACT THE CTC ADOPTED THE
CLOTHES OUT OF THE PROGRAM AT
THEIR AT THEIR MEETING LAST WEEK
IN SAN DIEGO AND ADOPTED PLANS
FOR SWEEPING ALL REMAINING
SAVINGS IDENTIFIED AFTER JUNE.
TWENTY TWENTY INTO THE NEWLY
CREATED TRADE CORRIDOR
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM.
SB FOUR NINE EIGHT WILL KEEP
CALIFORNIA COMPETITIVE BY
INCENTIVIZING SHORT LINE
RAILROADS TO INVEST IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ABOVE.
AND BEYOND THEIR CURRENT
CAPACITY WILL HELP US KEEP
CALIFORNIA'S FREE FUTURE RIGHT
ON TRACK.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN A VOTE.
BUT YOU CENTER HER TADO MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR.
I DO HER DAUGHTER WE TAKE A
QUESTION.
PLEASE PROCEED I DID SUPPORT THE
BILL GOING FORWARD TO QUESTION
IS HAVE WITH THE AMENDMENTS HAVE
IT REMOVED THE OPPOSITION.
ORIGINALLY THERE WERE ELEVEN
CEOS OF THAT TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES IN OUR STATE OPPOSED TO
THIS I HAVE YOU REMOVE THE
OPPOSITION WITH YOUR AMENDMENTS
AND CLARIFICATION.
OF THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S TO
BE REDIRECTED.
SO IN REGARDS.
TO THE OPPOSITION I DON'T KNOW.
WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT AGENCIES HAVE
REMOVED THEMSELVES FROM
OPPOSITION BUT I KNOW THAT
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN LAST MINUTE --
WITH THE OPPOSITION COMING IN
AND THE INFORMATION THAT.
HAS BEEN -- PROVIDED AND
RECEIVED AND SO WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN ON OUR
END TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
ALL THE MOST UP TO DATE
INFORMATION AND THAT ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY HAVE IS
ACCURATE -- AND SO WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT ON OUR END
AND SO WE ARE HOPING THAT WITH
ALL THE INFORMATION AT UP TO
DATE THAT THEY RECEIVED THAT
BILL REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION
FOR ANY OF THOSE THAT ARE
REMAINING.
BY MY OWN TIME MEMBER HAS AN
IDEA OF SUPPORTED I THINK I WILL
REMAIN OFF TODAY -- THE QUESTION
IS WHETHER ARE PROJECTS THAT
THIS MONEY COULD USE ARE
ACTUALLY KNEW OR THEY WERE
ALREADY IN THE PIPELINE AND I
THINK THAT'S WHERE OF SOME OF
THE DIFFERENCE.
OCCURS AND I THINK IT WOULD BE
VERY IMPORTANT GOING FORWARD.
THAT SHOULD THE OPPOSITION KNOB.
CONSULTED AND CERTAINLY --
HOPEFULLY NEUTRALIZE BECAUSE
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT.
ISSUE IN TERMS OF FUNDING
THROUGH THE TCI OFF AND I KNOW
THAT THE TERMINATES IN.
TWENTY TWENTY IS CERTAINLY GOING
FORWARD THE TREATY IMPROVEMENT
CORD OR ISSUES ARE SIGNIFICANT
THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND CERTAINLY THAT'S WHERE WE
HOLD ADDITIONAL PROJECTS CAN BE
THE MANY CAN BE DIRECTED.
TO SO THANK YOU AND I WILL --
PLAYOFF TODAY THANK YOU THE USER
BATES MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE CENTERVILLE.
YES ISN'T CONTEXT SO THE TWO
THOUSAND SIX BALLOT MEASURE WAS
A BOND THAT IT HAD TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THIS PROGRAM AND
THAT MONEY IS BEING SPENT DOWN
THE AUTHOR IS SUGGESTING.
THAT OF THAT REMAINING MONEY
EIGHT MILLION.
BE USED.
JUST SO YOU GET THE CONTACTS THE
OTHER CONTEXTS IS -- WITH SP.
ONE WE ADDED THREE BILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
SO THIS FUN WILL BE REPLENISHED
IN EFFECT -- BY SB ONE IT WILL
ADD THREE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
TRADE GOOD MOVING PROGRAM.
AND SO THAT WOULD BE A TOTAL
INVESTMENT OF FIVE BILLION THE
AUTHORS ASKING -- FOR THE EIGHT
MILLION I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING
TO CAUSE TROUBLE IN TRANSIT
AGENCIES.
OR ANY OTHER ORGANIZATION IF WE
APPROVE THIS IRISH AND I VOTE ON
THIS.
THANK YOU SENATOR BILL FOR THE
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I ORIGINALLY WAS GOING TO OPPOSE
MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRAZIER ON
THIS BUT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
MAINTENANCE.
BECAUSE I RECEIVED THEM AND I
REALIZE NOW THAT IT IS NOT GOING
TO AFFECT MY DISTRICT OF THE
OTHER DISTRICTS INVOLVED.
IN THE FACT IS THAT THE EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS -- RECOMMENDED
THE THE FACT IS THAT THE STAGE --
TWENTY SHORT TERM A RAIL LINE
WILL BE AFFECTED AND OBVIOUSLY
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WILL BE
BENEFITTED IT WILL NOT AFFECT MY
DISTRICT AND SOME OF THE OTHERS.
THAT I APPRECIATE THE MEMBERS
THAT YOU PUT FORTH AND I URGE AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ARTS LISTENER
DRAWS SO YES THANK YOU I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS PUT INTO THIS -- I'M
STILL HIGHLY CONCERNED BECAUSE I
HAVEN'T GOTTEN A RESPONSE BACK
FROM YOUR CLARIFICATION FROM ALL
OF THE OF THE TRANSIT AGENCIES
SO.
I AM HOPING I'M TRUSTING THAT%
THIS WILL -- BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD SO I GUESS IS KIND OF ON
THE CONDITION I'M GOING TO GET
THAT BUT TODAY I WILL SUPPORT
YOU -- BUT AGAIN I'M I'M STILL
CONCERNED AND I'M HOPING THAT
EVERYTHING TURNS OUT THE WAY.
THE WAY THAT SOME OF THE
EXPLANATION WAS GIVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR DRAWS --
MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING ANSWER HER
TITLE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
AT THANK YOU AND I ASKED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER HER THOMAS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
HI BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HI HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
JONES ACT [inaudible]
LABOR [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONNING.
I'M MORE LUCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
TYLER CASKEY.
I WINNER BY WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
MORE LUCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
WILK.
EYES THIRTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON A FILE ITEM
FORTY NINE CENTER PORTANTINO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY ONE BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT
RELATING TO TAXATION TO TAKE
BACK TO MERELY TAX LEVY.
CENTER PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU -- MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SOME PRESENTING SB
FIVE TWENTY ONE WHICH WOULD
ALLOW A TAX CREDIT TO A TAXPAYER
THAT OWNS A PROPERTY RENTED TO
RELEASED BY.
PERSON RECEIVING ASSISTANCE
UNDER SECTION -- EIGHT IN THE
AMOUNT EQUAL 23% OF THE AMOUNT
OF RENT OR LEASE PAYMENTS AND
LIMITED TO FIVE QUALIFIED
PROPERTIES PER TAXPAYER PER YEAR --
FOR EXAMPLE A PASADENA HAS BEEN
LOSING -- SECTION EIGHT WILLING
TENANTS -- AND THIS WOULD CREATE
AN INCENTIVE FOR AKTION THE
LANDLORDS -- TO TAKE IN SECTION
EIGHT TENANT SO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO
MEMBERS IN DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USE THEIR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
THERE IS MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
BY ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL.
I PORGES.
BY BRADFORD I CAN BE AT ALL.
I CHIANG BY DODD.
I THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
BY HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON BY JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
BY PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE.
AYE AMBERG.
OUR CASKEY BY WINNER.
BY [inaudible]
WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS -- TITLE HI
[inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
HI.
EYES THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM FIFTY SENATOR PAN
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE FIFTY SIX BY
SENATOR PAN AND THAT GOING TO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE.
SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- THIS BILL --
ESTABLISHES A CERTAIN SB FIVE
FIFTY SIX ESTABLISH A
CERTIFICATION PROCESS FOR
BUSINESSES THAT PART.
PRACTICE LAND SURVEYING LAND
SURVEYING IS A HIGHLY TECHNICAL
TRADE IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY INVOLVES A PERFORMANCE
OF COMPLEX SURVEYS TO ESTABLISH
PROPERTY LINES ARE BOUNDARIES OF
ANY PARTS OF LAND.
RIGHT OF WAYS AND EASEMENTS
THESE BOUNDARIES ARE USED
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE PROJECT TO
ENSURE CONSTRUCTION PLANS ARE
BEING FOLLOWED CORRECTLY AND
SAFELY.
CURRENTLY THE BOARD FOR
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS LAN
SURVEYS IN GEOLOGISTS HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER INDIVIDUAL
LICENSEES.
SB FIVE FIFTY SIX WOULD MERELY.
ENSURE GREATER EMPLOYER
ACCOUNTABILITY BY ESTABLISHING A
CERTIFICATE OF AUTHORITY THAT A
LAND SURVEYING COMPANY MUST
OBTAIN PRIOR TO DEPLOYING ITS
LICENSE STAFF TO CARRY OUT THE
SERVICES.
THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
BOARD TO ADOPT RULES AND
REGULATIONS COVERING CONDITIONS
WHERE A CERTIFICATE IS GRANTED
OR REVOKED.
THIS BILL NO WAY CONSTRAINTS ARE
LIMITS THE PRACTICES OF OTHER
CRAFTS ARE TRAITS IN THE FIELD
EXPECT WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I CAL YELLOW I CHIANG
[inaudible]
HI DODD.
HI THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI.
I GLAZER AYE GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
BY HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LUCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
BY PAN.
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
BY STERN.
BY STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
IOWA CASKEY [inaudible]
I WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
HIGH MORALE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
BATES I I THIRTY FOUR KNOWS ONE
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE SENATOR
CHIANG.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SAID ABOUT FIVE SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR CHIANG AN ACCOLADE
HOMELESSNESS CENTER CHIANG.
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SB FIVE SEVENTY THREE
WILL PROVIDE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION TO THE HOMELESS
EMERGENCY A PROGRAM ANNUALLY
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS HE SB FIVE
FIVE SEVEN THREE HAS BEEN
RECENTLY AMENDED TO STATE THAT
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
YEARLY ALLOCATION WILL BE UPON.
APPROPRIATION OF THE LEGISLATURE
THIS YEARLY ALLOCATION OYSTER
THAT THE PROGRAM WILL CONTINUE
TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESSNESS THESE.
AS A LAST FOR ABOUT A HUNDRED
THIRTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ARE
HOMELESS NEARLY A QUARTER OF THE
NATION'S TOTAL HOMELESS
POPULATION.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN GOVERNOR
BROWN LEGISLATURE AGREE TO FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND TO CREATE THE
HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID.
PROGRAM BLOCK GRANT.
HE PASSED PROVIDE DIRECT
ASSISTANCE TO CITIES COUNTIES
AND CONTINUE TO ANYONE TO CARE
TO BEGIN TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
THE HEAT GRANT PROGRAM HAS
ALREADY ASSISTED COMMUNITIES AND
BETTER SERVING THE HOMELESS.
POPULATION TO SERVICES SUCH AS
STREET OUT WHICH IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE DIVERSION PROGRAMS
HOUSING VOUCHERS RAPID WE
HOUSING PROGRAMS.
THE ONLY NAME A FEW ELIGIBLE
VOTER PROGRAMS COST STATE.
AS AN EXAMPLE THE CITY OF
ANAHEIM WAS ABLE TO OPEN THREE
NEW HOMELESS SHELTERS AND THREE
MONTHS TO THE ASSISTANT OF FUNDS.
HOMELESSNESS ISN'T GOING WHEN
ONE OR TWO YEARS WE SPENT
SEVERAL IGNORING THE ISSUE NOW
IT'S CRISIS THAT OUR LOCAL
CITIES AND COUNTIES HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT.
LASTLY ACCOUNTABILITY IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT REGARDING
THESE FUNDS THERE IS INITIAL
REPORT DUE ON JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY AND THAT WILL
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED INFORMATION
ON HOW EFFECTIVE HE FUNDS HAVE
BEEN USED.
SB FIVE SEVENTY THREE REQUIRES A
YEARLY REPORTING AS WELL.
AND LIKE THE ORIGINAL HE PROGRAM
ALLOWS THE HOMELESS COORDINATING
FINANCING COUNCIL TO MONITOR
EXPENDITURES AND ACTIVITIES OF
OUR LOCAL CITIES AND COUNTIES
RELATED TO KEEP.
THEM WITHIN COUNTY INFORMED ME
THAT THERE IS ALREADY A WEEKLY
CALL WITH THE OMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL SET FOR REPORTING
PURPOSES.
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO FUND
THE KEEP BLOCK GRANT ANNUALLY IN
ORDER TO DIRECTLY ASSIST CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO ADDRESS THE
PERVASIVE HOMELESS THIS CRISIS
IN CALIFORNIA IN WITH THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE KHI BàN PERSON I
WAS A NO VOTE IN THIS ON THIS
BILL WHEN IT WAS BEFORE THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE BECAUSE OF THE
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION -- FOR
THE OUT HOMELESS SIMMERED IN CA
PROGRAM NOT THAT I'M AGAINST IT
ALMOST EMERGENCY AID PROGRAM BUT
I'LL BE REMOVING MY OPPOSITION
IN VOTING IN SUPPORT GIVEN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE AUTHORS
TAKEN.
AND ORIGINAL VOTE THANK YOU
CENTERRIGHT KELSEY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
THE MENTOR CHEN WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE.
OF HOMELESSNESS IS AN EMERGENCY
IT'S AN EMERGENCY ISSUE AND WE
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
SOLVE THIS CRISIS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK MY MY
COLLEAGUE FOR MOVING HIS
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS BATES.
HI BILL.
BY BURGESS BY BRADFORD.
I KELLY AT ALL.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I TERRAZZO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROVE.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE BY JACKSON
[inaudible]
BY JONES.
BY LEYVA HI I'M ACQUIRE BY
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
HIGH MORALE [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
BY AMBERG OUR CASKEY BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
ROOMY TO FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO
SENATOR UMBERG MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE SEVENTY SIX BY
SENATOR UMBERG ACT REALLY INTO
COASTAL RESOURCES CENTER AMBER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES -- CLIMATE CHANGES NO
LONGER THEORY CLIMATE CHANGE IS
IN ACTUALITY.
SB. FIVE SEVENTY SIX SIMPLY
ADDRESSES THAT REALITY BY
REQUIRING THE STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A COASTAL CLIMATE
CHANGE ADAPTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
AND READY THIS PROGRAM.
RECOMMEND BEST PRACTICES AND
STRATEGIES TO IMPROVE THE
CLIMATE CHANGE RESILIENCY OF
CALIFORNIA'S COASTAL COMMUNITIES --
CLIMATE CHANGE WILL PROBABLY
HAVE A MORE DRAMATIC EFFECT ON
COASTAL COMMUNITIES AND
THEREFORE WE NEED DEVELOP A PLAN
ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
HEARING AND SEEING THEM MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS BATES.
BY BILL AYE PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BY KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
BY GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER BY GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO HI -- TITLE
[inaudible]
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR [inaudible]
MCGUIRE HI [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING.
HI MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN.
BY STONE.
NOVEMBER.
OUR CASKEY BY WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI.
THEN REMOVE THE CALL MEMBERS
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE
SENATOR GROWTH.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX EIGHTY THREE BY
SENATOR GROVE AN ACT RELATING TO
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES CENTER
GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS SB SIX
EIGHTY THREE IS A MODEST MEASURE
THAT WILL HELP ENSURE THAT THERE
IS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY. FOR REGIONAL
CENTERS TECHNICAL OCCUR FIND
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKING AND
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
AND THERE HAS BEEN A LONG
STANDING CONCERN THAT CONSUMERS
AND FAMILY MEMBERS REGARDING
REGIONAL CENTER ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY.
AND HOW IT CAN BE A PER IT WOULD
YOU KNOW IMPROVED THERE WAS A
STUDY DONE WITH TWENTY ONE
REGIONAL CENTERS ACROSS THE
STATE AND THEY WERE NOT
CONSISTENT WITH INFORMATION
BEING PROVIDED TO THE CONSUMER
OR THE PARENT AND THE CONSUMER.
AND THIS WILL JUST HELP
STREAMLINE THAT PROCESS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE I IS
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX
SENATOR GLAZER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR GLAZER AND ACTUALLY TO
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY
[inaudible]
CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
SB TWO FORTY EIGHT WOULD PROVIDE.
LONG OVERDUE CHANGES TO THE
RENTERS TAX CREDIT.
AND PROVIDE FINANCIAL RELIEF O
TWO POINT FOUR MILLION LOW AND
MIDDLE INCOME RENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE WRITERS TAX CREDIT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO BUT HAS
ONLY BEEN INCREASED ONCE IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE SINCE THEN
RENTS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE TRIPLED.
ALL THE LEGISLATURE HAS MADE
STRIDES IN EXPANDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
LITTLE HAS BEEN DONE TO PROVIDE
DIRECT FINANCIAL RELIEF TO THOSE
WHO NEED IT THE MOST.
LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
WITH SKYROCKETING COSTS OF RENT.
THIS MEASURE INSTEAD OF JUST
DIFFERENTIATING BETWEEN SINGLE
AND JOINT FILERS THIS BILL
INCREASES THE CREDIT FOR THOSE
WITH DEPENDENCE.
MAKING THE CREDIT MORE USEFUL
AND FAIR.
THE SINGLE MOMS AND DADS AND
FAMILIES. FOR THIS BILL MAKES
THE RENTERS TAX CREDIT
REFUNDABLE.
SO THAT EVEN THOSE WITHOUT A TAX
OBLIGATION CAN RECEIVE THE
BENEFITS OF THE TAX CREDIT.
ALL TOGETHER OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND RANCHERS.
WHO NOW RECEIVE LITTLE OR NO
CREDIT WOULD BECOME NEWLY
ELIGIBLE?
UNDER THE NEW STRUCTURE OF THIS
BILL SINGLE OR JOINT FILERS
WITHOUT DEPENDENCE Và RECEIVED
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY DOLLARS.
AND THOSE WITH DEPENDENTS WOULD
RECEIVE FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
DOLLARS.
A SIGNIFICANT AND MUCH NEEDED
INCREASED FROM THE SIXTY DOLLARS
AND A HUNDRED TWENTY DOLLARS
RENTERS ARE NOW ELIGIBLE.
FOR THE SMART PROGRESSIVE BILL
COMPLIMENTS CALIFORNIA'S LONG
TERM GOALS TO INCREASE AND
EXPAND ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
WHILE WILL TAKE YEARS TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HOMES THIS
BILL WILL HELP MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS -- RIGHT NOW. TWO
FINAL POINTS.
THE CREDIT PROVIDED IN THIS BILL
WILL BE SUBJECT TO A BUDGET
APPROPRIATION.
AND FINALLY I WANT TO THANK THE
MANY CO AUTHORS ON THIS FLOOR
BIPARTISAN.
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE FOR
COMING TOGETHER AND SUPPORTING
THIS IMPORTANT RELIEF TO RENTERS
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER.
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
STANDING RISE AND RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO FORTY EIGHT
THANK MY COLLEAGUE. FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE -- THE FACT
THE MATTER IS WE DO HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS IN THIS STATE.
AND WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH PRODUCT
IN SHAME ON US FOR NOT DOING OUR
JOB OVER THESE LAST FEW YEARS.
AND SUPPOSE THEY WORRY BE
STEPPING UP AND AND ADDRESSING
THAT BUT WE NEED TO KNOW THAT WE
NEED A A SHORT TERM BOOST IN THE
ARM.
AND AS MENTIONED.
BY MY FRIEND -- WE'VE NOT RACES
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE THIS
IS ALL PRODUCT OF SUPPLY AND
DEMAND AND THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
SUPPLY.
I AM BLESSED BOTH MY CHILDREN
THAT LIVE IN MY HOMETOWN -- THEY
BOTH LIVE IN MARGINAL PART OF
TOWN IN A MAR IN IN MARSHALL
APARTMENT BUILDINGS AND THEY PAY
MORE FOR RENT THEN I PAY FOR MY
HOME.
AND YOU KNOW MY SONS ON THE
PATHWAY TO HOMEOWNERSHIP.
BUT MY DAUGHTER WITH HER HUSBAND
AND MY ONLY GRAND SON ARE NOT.
SO ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO BOTH
SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM TO LIFT
UP ALL PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA IS A
GOOD THING AGAIN THIS IS NOT
BEEN RACES -- NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE WE NEED TO DO IT THIS YEAR
AND WE NEED TO TAKE ON THE WHOLE
HOUSING.
SITUATION SO EVERY CALIFORNIA
HAS A SHOT AT THE END AT THAT
THE AMERICAN DREAM SO THANK YOU
AND AGAIN I SUPPORT SB.
TWO FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU
SENATOR WILK CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I URGE
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS BE TWO FORTY
EIGHT THE RATE LIMITING STEP FOR
SOMEBODY TO BUY A HOME IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OFTEN AS A
DOWN PAYMENT.
BY INCREASING THIS TAX CREDIT
PUTTING MORE MONEY INTO THE
HOMES OF THOSE AT ONE EIGHT SHE
THE AMERICAN DREAM.
MORE HOMES ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO SELL AND AND GET THESE QUé
THESE YOUNG ADULTS -- BEING
RENTERS ARE BEING HOMEOWNERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
THOSE REASONS ARE DIVERT SB.
TWO FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU CENTER
STONE SENATOR GROVE.
NICE I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRING IT FORWARD THIS IS A
SECOND REALLY GOOD BILL THAT
WE'VE HAD FOR RENTERS IN THE
PAST TWO WEEKS THE FIRST TIME
WAS ALLOWING RENTERS TO CLAIM
THE PAYMENTS TOWARDS THEIR
CREDIT SO THEY CAN ESTABLISH.
CREDIT I THOUGHT THAT WAS
OUTSTANDING BILL AND I'M GLAD TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU CENTER GROVE CENTER
GLAZER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I CERTAINLY WANT.
TO THANK THE SENATORS FROM SANTA
CLARITA TO MACULA BAKERSFIELD
AND THE MANY CO AUTHORS IN THE
FOR FOR RECOGNIZING THAT.
WE'RE WORKING ON THIS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ISSUE.
NOW IT'S GOING TO TAKE AWHILE
FOR IT -- TO REALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE BUT THE RENTER'S
CREDIT COULD HELP OUR POOR AND
MIDDLE INCOME RENTERS
IMMEDIATELY WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DIVER.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ALLEN I ARTS THAT I ATKINS
[inaudible]
I BATES.
HI BILL BY BURGESS I BRADFORD.
BY COMING AT ALL.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DODD.
HI THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI.
I GLAZER BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
BY JACKSON.
BY JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
HI MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
BY AMBERG.
I LIKE CASSIE BY WINNER BY WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MORLOCK [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
BY.
I THREE SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS BEFORE WE MOVE TO OUR
NEXT FILE ITEM I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE
MISTER BILL YOUNG WHO'S IN THE
GALLERY HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
ALRIGHT MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY SEVEN SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
YOU MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN OH SEVEN BY
SENATOR AKOWSKI AN ACT RELATING
TO ARBITRATION.
THERE WERE CAL SKI MAN PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SENATE BILL -- SEVEN
OH SEVEN PROVIDES A PROCESS
THAT'S IT JUST A PROCESS FOR
CONSUMERS AND WORKERS WHO GET
STUCK WITH AN ARBITRATION CLAUSE
AND THEN GET THE NIGHT THE
ABILITY TO ARBITRATE.
THEIR CLAIMS BECAUSE THE
BUSINESS STRATEGICALLY WITH
HOLDS PAYMENT THEY DON'T PAY THE
FEE FOR THE ARBITRATOR TO HEAR
THE CASE SO FLOOR MEMONS RESOLVE
A HANDFUL OF THE CONCERNS FROM
THE OPPOSITION AND I WILL
CONTINUE.
AS I NORMALLY DO TO TIGHTEN UP
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL GETS
OVER TO THE S.
ASSEMBLY SENATE BILL SEVEN OH
SEVEN ENSURES THAT BUSINESSES
AND EMPLOYERS CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH
WAYS THEY CANNOT USE ARBITRATION
CLAUSES THE FORCE CALIFORNIA'S
INTO ARBITRATION AND THEN.
IN CONSEQUENTIALLY FILL OUT
THEIR OWN ARBITRATION CLAUSES
WHEN THEY DON'T PAY THEIR FEE SO
I WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER WHITE HOUSE KEY
MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING THAT
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS HI [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL [inaudible]
HI PORGES.
BRADFORD I CARRIER ALL
[inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DOT.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI.
I GLAZER I GROW [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL BY WITH SO.
BY -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
NO LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY BY MORE LUCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO NUMBER I WILL COUNTY.
I WINNER.
HI WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
WILK AYE.
ICE THIRTY KNOW SOMEONE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
FIFTY NINE SENATOR ROTH. THIRTY
WILK WAS AT THE APPROPRIATE VOTE
YOU WISH TO CAST.
ALL RIGHT I THINK WE ARE THAN.
JUST GIVE ME ONE MOMENT.
EYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM FIFTY
NINE SENATOR ROTH MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY TWO BY
SENATOR ROBB THE NECRO INTO
EMPLOYMENT.
SENATE ROTH THING ABOUT A
PRESENT COLLEAGUES -- THE
CURRENT LAW SURPRISINGLY DOES
NOT REQUIRE THE DIVISION OF
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT. TO
POST UNPAID WAGES DUE TO
EMPLOYEES FROM EMPLOYERS.
FOLLOWING SOME ADMINISTRATIVE OR
LITIGATION MATTER.
ON THE D. I. R. AS BERMAN
INVESTOR RELATIONS WEBSITE.
IN SOME CASES ALTHOUGH IT HAS
BEEN DETERMINED THAT A FORMER
EMPLOYEES DO MONEY FROM THE
EMPLOYER.
THE EMPLOYEE NEVER LEARNS OF IT
AND NEVER CLAIMS THE MONEY.
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY TWO WILL
REQUIRE THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
TO LIST ALL SUCH FUNDS ON A
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE WEBSITE.
THE WEBSITE WILL BE INDEXED BY
THE NAME OF THE EMPLOYEE THE
AMOUNT OF WAGES AND BENEFITS.
AND THE DATE DEPOSITED NOT THE
NAME OF THE EMPLOYER.
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY TWO IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT EMPLOYEES
WHO ARE OWED WAGES ARE INDEED
ABLE TO LOCATE.
THE UNPAID WAGES AND COLLECT
THEM RESPECTFULLY AS FOR LIVE --
THANK YOU SENATOR ROBB MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES AYE BELL.
AYE BURGESS [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT.
I THE RUSSELL.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
HI HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
I AM.
VIA CASKEY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
BY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
HI. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE
ARE NOW MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM
SIXTIES SENATOR RUSSELL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY EIGHT
BY SENATOR ALSO AN ECHOING TO
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES CENTER
TORONTO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES THE
GOVERNOR OF EACH STATE TO
DESIGNATE A PROFIT PRIVATE
NONPROFIT CORPORATION. FOR THE
PROTECTION AND ADVOCACY OF THE
RIGHTS OF PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES.
SB THREE NINETY EIGHT UPDATES
STATE LAW REGARDING CALIFORNIA'S
PROTECTION AND ADVOCACY AGENCY.
TO REFLECT THE RECENT UPDATES TO
FEDERAL REGULATIONS REGARDING
PROTECTION AND ADVOCACY AGENCIES.
THIS BILL ALSO SPECIFICALLY
CLARIFIES THAT THE MEETING OF
FACILITY OR PROGRAM INCLUDES A
FACILITY USED TO HOUSE OR DETAIN.
NON CITIZENS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CIVIL IMMIGRATION CUSTODY.
THE STATE IN THIS ACCESS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IN LIGHT
EVERYWHERE OVER REPORT FROM
EARLIER THIS YEAR.
BY DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
REGARDING THE TREATMENT OF
PERSONS WITH MENTAL ILLNESS AND
OTHER DISABILITIES IN
IMMIGRATION DETENTION.
AMONG OTHER FINDINGS THAT REPORT
FOUND INADEQUATE MENTAL HEALTH
CARE AND MEDICAL CARE. FOR
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES MADE
ALL THE WORSE BY THE FACILITIES
COUNTER THERAPEUTIC CONDITINS
AND PRACTICES.
IT ALSO FOUND SIGNIFICANT UNDER
REPORTING OF THE NUMBER OF
ATTEMPTS OF SUICIDE ATTEMPTS
THAT OCCUR AT ADELANTO.
THIS MEASURE IS UNOPPOSED AND
HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
THROUGH THE SENATE I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DRAWS --
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE EYES
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVIE ON THE FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE
SENATOR DODD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
RESOLUTION FORTY NUMBER SENATOR
DODD RELATIVE TO OTHER
INDEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE
AWARENESS MONTH.
SENATOR DODD BETTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS S. C. R. FORTY NINE
SEEKS TO RECOGNIZE THE MONTH OF
JUNE AS ELDER VULNERABLE ADULT
ABUSE AWARENESS MONTH.
THIS IN RECOGNITION ALLIANCE
WITH THE NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL RECOGNITION DURING
THE MONTH OF JUNE.
SADLY ONE IN TEN AMERICANS SIXTY
YEARS OF AGE AND OLDER
EXPERIENCE ABUSE EACH YEAR.
THE ELDERLY AND ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES MAY BE IMPACTED BY
A CONSTELLATION OF PHYSICAL
MENTAL PHARMACEUTICAL OR MEDICAL
INFLUENCES.
INDIA ONE OF WHICH COULD
RESTRICT THEIR ABILITY TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES OR TO SELF
ADVOCATE TO REPORT TO
AUTHORITIES WHAT A BIãU
STICKERS OR TESTIFY AGAINST
PERPETRATORS.
RECOGNIZING THESE IS A FIRST
STEP TOWARDS PREVENTION OF ELDER
INDEPENDENT ADULT USE ABUSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE EYES
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO MEASURE PASS
EXCUSE ME THE RESOLUTIONS ARE
ADOPTED.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO
SENATOR MORALE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY ONE BY SENATOR MORALE
RELATIVE TO MUSIC CHANGING LIVES
MONTH.
CENTER MORALE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT.
AND MEMBERS OF I RISE TODAY. TO
PRESENT OUR S. C. R. FIFTY ONE
WHICH DESIGNATES MAY -- TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN IS MUSIC
CHANGING LIVES MONTH.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
ALMOST EVERYONE WE KNOW ENJOYS
MUSIC WHETHER PLAN AN INSTRUMENT
SINGER SINGING OR SIMPLY
LISTENING -- ALL AGES BENEFIT
FOR MUSIC AND HAS A UNIQUE
IMPACT ON KIDS TEENS AND ADULTS.
ADDITIONALLY STUDENTS LEARN
VALUABLE LESSONS AS WELL AS
DISCIPLINE HAVING A SET ASIDE
TIME TO MASTER PLAN.
THEIR INSTRUMENTS THE IDEA OF
THIS.
C. S. C. R. FIFTY ONE CAME MY
OFFICE FROM JOSIAH BRUNI WHO
ALSO AFTER WORKING IN THE MUSIC
INDUSTRY STARTED MUSIC CHANGING
LIVES. FOR M. C. L. THIS IS A
LOCAL NON NON PROFIT -- WHICH
SERVES THE COUNTIES A SALMON
DINO AS WELL AS RIVERSIDE AND IS
DEDICATED TO PROVIDING -- MUSIC
ART AND TUTORING PROGRAMS IN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
CENTERS -- THIS IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF MANY PROGRAMS ACROSS
STATE DEDICATED AND SEE YOUNG
PEOPLE -- ENRICH THEIR LIVES S.
C. R. FIFTY ONE RECOGNIZES
EFFORTS LIKE THIS AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF PER PRESERVING
ACCESS TO ART -- MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN DECLARING MAY TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN IS MUSIC
CHANGING LIVES MONTH.
I WOULD BE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORALE MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
[inaudible]
HUESO.
MATT MADAM CHAIR I JUST WANTED A
HER MENTOR PRESENT I WANNA STAND
UP JUST TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
I DON'T THINK -- WE DO ENOUGH IN
OUR STATE TO SUPPORT.
THE ARTS IN GENERAL -- BUT THIS
IS A WONDERFUL RESOLUTION THAT
JUST.
SIMPLY CALLS ATTENTION TO THE
IMPORTANCE.
OF OF MUSIC THE MUSIC ARTS AND
IT'S IT'S SO IMPORTANT HELPING
YOUNG PEOPLE.
DEVELOP THE DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE BRAIN ESPECIALLY.
OTHER CREATIVE -- SIDE AND WE
ALL KNOW THAT -- WE WILL -- AT
LEAST WE'VE ALL HEARD IT SAY
THAT -- OFTENTIMES MUSIC IS VERY
CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH OUR ABILITY
TO UNDERSTAND IMPORTANT SUBJECT
AREA SUCH AS MATHEMATICS.
AND HELPING OF PEOPLE TO BECOME
PROBLEM SOLVERS AS WELL.
BUT ONE THING I ALWAYS TELL
PEOPLE ABOUT MUSIC I I HAVE
NEVER MET A PERSON ON EARTH.
THAT DOESN'T LIKE MUSIC.
WE ALL MY LIKE BE DIFFERENT
MUSICAL STYLES AND GENRES BUT
EVERY PERSON ON EARTH
APPRECIATES MUSIC.
THAT HAS HEALING POWERS AND HAS
A POWER TO BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER.
ON IMPORTANT ISSUES AND IT'S
SUCH AN IMPORTANT.
ELEMENT TO OUR LIVES WE NEED TO
DO MORE IN OUR STATE TO SUPPORT
THE ARTS TO SUPPORT MUSIC.
AND TO SUPPORT MUSIC INSTRUCTION
IN OUR SCHOOLS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
CENTER HUESO CENTER NIELSEN.
NOT A PRESENT LADIES GEMS OF THE
SENATE THERE IS SOME HOPE ON THE
HORIZON HERE OR ACTUALLY.
HAS OF HAVING RISEN ALREADY.
AFTER MANY MANY.
YEARS OF MINIMAL ABSOLUTE
MINIMAL SUPPORT FOR THE ARTS THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR'S HAVE
INCREASED THE SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL.
THAT'S GOOD NEWS AND I WILL
CERTAINLY ATTEST. TO THE
THERAPEUTIC VALUE [inaudible]
OF MUSIC [inaudible]
INCLUDING.
THE CATTLE AND HORSES YOU CAN'T
GO TO VERY MANY DAIRIES.
OR HORSE BARNS THAT DO NOT HAVE
MUSIC PLAYING.
IT BRING SERENITY EVEN TO OUR
ANIMALS.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN MEMBERS
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING THEM FEDERAL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU AND MEMBERS I I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SENATOR MORALE MEMBERS.
THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE EYES
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTIONS ARE ADOPTED MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR
CENTER JACKSON MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY SIX BY
SENATOR JACKSON AND THAT GOING
TO ATTORNEYS.
CENTER JACKSON THANK YOU ARE.
I WANTED TO RICHARD TENSION TO
THE FASCINATING SUBJECT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BAR.
THIS IS THE ANNUAL FEE BILL.
THAT -- HAS BEEN THE SOURCE OF
SOME INTEREST OVER THE COURSE OF
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
BUT THE NUTS AND BOLTS OF IT IS
THAT WE HAVEN'T HAD AN INCREASE
IN THE STATE BAR FEES FOR TWENTY
YEARS.
WE HAVEN'T HAD AN INCREASE IN
TWENTY YEARS.
WE HAVE REQUIRED THAT THE STATE
BAR RE DEFINE ITSELF REORGANIZE
IT IS BEING IN THE PROCESS OF
DOING THAT AND AS PART OF THAT.
WE HAVE ASKED THE STATE AUDITOR
TO HELP US DETERMINE WHAT THE
FEES SHOULD BE GOING FORWARD.
THE STATE BAR ASKED FOR AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY MORE
THAN WHAT THE STATE AUDITOR AND
MANY OF US FELT WAS APPROPRIATE.
SO THIS BILL TAKES THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED BY THE
STATE AUDITOR.
BY AND WE'LL AMEND THE FEES. TO
REFLECT THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT OVER TWENTY YEARS
ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT EVEN THAT
LEVEL.
THE AMOUNT WILL BE FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY DOLLARS PLUS.
ADDITIONAL OF FEES ASSOCIATED
WITH MAINTAINING A TRUST ACCOUNT
WHEN A LAWYER COMMITS A
MALPRACTICE OR TAKES A CLIENT'S
FEES.
WE ARE TRYING TO COMPENSATE
THOSE PEOPLE THE FUND IS
INADEQUATE THIS IS ADDITIONAL
MONEY TO ASSIST WITH THAT.
IT WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN DO
BETTER DISCIPLINE OF ATTORNEYS
WHO ARE -- DESERVING OF THAT
DISCIPLINE PART OF THE PRIMARY
FUNCTION OF THE STATE BAR IS TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC ALSO TO GIVE
ACCESS.
THIS IS A MEASURE THAT WILL THUS
INCREASE THE FEES BASED UPON THE
STATE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATION
AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
THE BILL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
HI BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT.
BY THE RISE OF I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROWTH. FIVE
HUNDRED AYE HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
JACKSON HI I JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
I'M ACQUIRE.
I MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH BY.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
NOVEMBER.
OUR CASKEY.
I WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALAN [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
CHIANG -- TITLE.
I JONES [inaudible]
WARLOCK [inaudible]
I MORRELL [inaudible]
NO. FIVE THREE TWO KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON A FILE
ITEM SIXTY FIVE SENATOR ALLEN.
SIXTY FIVE HAVE SOME FILE MOVING
TO FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX SENATOR
WELL MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SAID ABOUT FIVE EIGHTY BY
SENATOR WILL CONNECT RELATING TO
ANIMAL ABUSE CENTER WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS ARE RISE 2% SB FIVE
EIGHTY THE ANIMAL CRUELTY AND
VIOLENCE INNOVATIVE INTERVENTION
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
THIS BILL SIXTY CURBING FOR AND
PREVENT SOME OF THE MOST SERIOUS
ACTS OF ABUSE AND VIOLENCE
COMMITTED AGAINST ANIMALS AND
PEOPLE.
THERE'S A PROVEN LINK BETWEEN
ANIMAL ABUSE AND VIOLENCE
TOWARDS PEOPLE. 71% OF THOSE
CONVICTED OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
50% OF THOSE CONVICTED OF RAPE.
BEGAN WITH ANIMAL ABUSE KNOWING
THIS WE NEED TO STEP IN AS EARLY
AS POSSIBLE.
IN THESE INDIVIDUALS LIVES TO
KEEP THEIR ACTIONS FROM
ESCALATING.
SB FIVE EIGHTY WILL ALLOW THESE
INDIVIDUALS GET THE PROFESSIONAL
HELP THEY NEED BEFORE IT'S TOO
LATE FOR THE MOST SERIOUS ANIMAL
CRUELTY CONVENTION --
CONVICTIONS.
OFFENDERS WILL UNDERGO A
PROFESSIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
EVALUATION AND RECEIVE
COUNSELING AND TREATMENT AT THE
COURT'S DISCRETION. FOR MINOR
CONVICTIONS DEFENDANTS WILL BE
ASSIGNED A STATE APPROVED ANIMAL
OWNERSHIP COURSE BY THE COURT.
THIS MEASURE WILL GIVE TROUBLED
INDIVIDUALS ACCESS TO THE
PROFESSION PROFESSIONAL HELP THE
SO BADLY NEED POTENTIALLY
PROTECTING BOTH ANIMALS AND
PEOPLE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER WOKE MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE I IS
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING ON A FILE ITEM SIXTY
SEVEN SENATOR PORTANTINO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY FIVE BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT
RELATING TO LAND USE PLANNING.
CENTER PORTANTINO [inaudible]
MAKES THE THANK YOU ARE MADAM.
PRESIDENT A MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SB SIX NINETY FIVE
WHICH WOULD ALLOW THE CITY TO
DEEM A HOUSING UNIT
PARTICIPATING IN A HOME SHARING
ARRANGEMENT.
WITH AT LEAST ONE OR LOW
MODERATE INCOME SENIOR OR
DISABLED OCCUPANTS AS A VERY LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF MEETING ITS REGIONAL
HOUSING NEED ALLOCATION.
LOW INCOME SENIORS WHO FIND
THEMSELVES HOMELESS OR ABOUT TO
BE HOMELESS ARE HURTING WHETHER
THEY ARE RENTERS ARE BUYERS
RENTAL UNITS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
PRICED WELL BELOW ABOVE 30% OF
MANY SENIORS FIXED INCOME.
LIKEWISE BUYING OR MAINTAINING A
HOUSE HAS BECOME MORE DIFFICULT
FOR US SENIORS IN PARTICULAR ON
FIXED INCOME THOSE ON FIXED
INCOMES OFTEN CANNOT KEEP UP.
WITH GROWING COST HOME SHARING
OPPORTUNITIES IS A SIMPLE IDEA
WHERE HOMEOWNER OFFERS
ACCOMMODATIONS TO HOME SHARE IN
EXCHANGE FOR GREED LEVEL OF
SUPPORT IN THE FORM OF FINANCIAL
EXCHANGE ASSISTANCE.
I WITH HOUSEHOLD TASKS ARE BOTH
FROM SHARING PROGRAMS CAN OFFER
MORE SECURE ALTERNATIVE. TO
OTHER ROOMMATE OPTIONS
VULNERABLE SENIORS OR NEED OF A
HOME SHARE ARE FREQUENTLY AFRAID
TO ENTER INTO A RENTAL AGREEMENT
ON THEIR OWN.
HOME SHARING PROGRAMS OFTEN HAVE --
STAFF WERE TRAINED TO CAREFULLY
SCREEN EACH PROGRAM APPLICANT --
THROUGH INTERVIEWING BACKGROUND
CHECKING AND PERSONAL OF
REFERENCES AS WELL AS CASE
MANAGERS TO ASSIST -- THE
PROGRAM SO INCENTIVIZING CITIES
TO INCREASE HOME SHARING
OPPORTUNITY IS A PROVEN -- TO
OPTION THIS BILL ORIGINALLY WAS
BROADER WE'VE NOW IT IT JUST TO
THE SENIOR COMPONENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
DO YOU KNOW YOU TAKE A QUESTION.
HOW TAKE A QUESTION I HOPE I
HAVE THE AT LEAST?
FOR I'M SORRY IN ALL DOCTOR
ABOUT IT BEFORE HIM BUT JUST
THAT THERE IS AN AMAZING
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION LOS
ANGELES THAT THAT MANAGES IT'S
WHAT YOU TALKED ABOUT HOUSE THE
CASE WORKERS TO HELP -- DO
PLACEMENT DO THE THE PRE WORK TO
MAKE TO THE PLACEMENT IS REALLY
A GOOD PLACEMENT.
AS I READ THE BILL I'M NOT SURE
WHO BENEFITS IT DOES THE
NONPROFIT WHO WHO'S ALREADY
TRYING TO RAISE MONEY PROBABLY
TO BE ABLE TO KEEP UP.
WITH THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE IN
ORDER TO DO THESE PLACEMENTS
THEY BENEFIT OR DOES THE
MUNICIPALITY BENEFIT MORE SO --
BY ALLOWING TO COUNT THE SHEER
HOUSING UNITS AGAINST THEIR
REGIONAL KIND OF THRESHOLD I
THINK EVERYONE BENEFITS I THINK
THE THE SENIOR BENEFITS BECAUSE
BY HAVING MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
HOUSING.
I THINK THE NONPROFIT BENEFITS
BECAUSE NOW YOU'RE PULLING
MULTIPLE INCOMES AND I THINK THE
MINISTER POLITY BENEFITS BECAUSE
THEY GET TO COUNT THESE TOWARDS
THE ARENA NUMBER.
SO I THINK IT'S THE INTENT TO
BENEFIT ALL THREE COMPONENTS OF
THE THING I'LL LOOK SPECIFICALLY
HOW IT WORKS FOR THE NONPROFIT
BUT I THINK IT'S AN INTENT TO
TRY TO MAKE EVERYBODY IN THAT.
PROCESS HAVE THE BENEFIT GOT I
GUESS JUST MY CONCERN HAVING
COME FROM THE NONPROFIT WORLD WE
WE WERE ALL OFTEN YOU KNOW THE
BENEFICIARIES OF LEGISLATION --
THAT WOULD KIND OF DRIVE WORK
OUR WAY BUT NOT THE DISH THE
RESOURCES THAT'S AFTER THEY
REALLY GET A SENSE OF WHO'S THE
WINNER HERE -- AND SO IF YOU
WANT FALL WHAT DESPAIR AS I
THINK IT'S AN AMAZING IDEA THIS
NONPROFIT DOES GREAT WORK.
AT LEAST IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES BUT I DON'T WANT TO OVER
TAX THEM IF THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO REALLY CARE TO KEEP
UP WITH THE DEMAND THAT YOUR
BILL MAY HELP CREATE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL CENTER
JONES.
THANK REPRESENT MASS THE AUTHOR
QUESTION PLEASE CENTER
PORTANTINO YOU TAKE A QUESTION.
OF COURSE PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- IN A
COMMITTEE WHEN WE VOTE ON THIS
BILL IT FOCUSED MORE ON FOSTER
YOUTH AND THAT YOU'VE TAKEN
FLOOR AMENDMENTS. TO CHANGE THE
FOCUS TO ELDERLY AND I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU COULD EXPLAIN.
THE PURPOSE FOR THE CHANGE IT
HAD TWO COMPONENTS AND WE JUST
NARROWED IT.
TO ONE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU CENTER JONES SAWYER
CABALLERO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- I'M
GOING -- TO OPPOSE ABILITY AT
THIS PARTICULAR POINT IN TIME
AND I I AM WITH WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO MY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOOKING OUT I DID HEAR THIS IN
COMMITTEE AND I ICE I VOTED TO
SUPPORT IT MOVING BECAUSE I
THOUGHT IT WAS WORTH THE
CONVERSATION.
BUT AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT
THE RINA PROCESS IS FRAUGHT WITH
PROBLEMS AND IT'S A VERY
POLITICAL PROCESS WHERE YOU YOU
KNOW ONE COMMUNITY AS WE WANT TO
HAVE.
ANY AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND SO
THEY FORCE IT ON ANOTHER
COMMUNITY AND THEY GET THE VOTES
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
BUT BUT BUT IS IN PERFECT IS IT
IS IT'S WHAT WE HAVE IT AND I
HESITATE TO START ANY PROGRAM
AND I ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT.
SENIOR HOMELESSNESS IS THE
LARGEST GROWING SEGMENT OF THE
POPULATION IN OUR STATE AND NOT
REALLY TROUBLES ME BECAUSE UP
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE WORKED THEIR
ENTIRE LIFE AND END UP HOMELESS
AT THE END.
IS IS HEARTBREAKING I THINK MY
MY GOOD FRIEND -- FROM LOOKING
OUT IS IS GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I JUST THINK THERE HAS
TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND AND ACCOUNTABILITY MEANS OR
HAS TO BE A SYSTEM SET UP.
SO THAT YOU CAN VERIFY.
THAT YOU'RE ACTUALLY MEETING
PARTY ARENA NUMBERS AND YOU CAN --
YOU UTILIZE A NON PROFITS
THEY'RE ACTUALLY DOING THE WORK
TO BE ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER
PEOPLE END UP -- TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT WORKS AND SO I I THINK
IT SAID IT BEFORE IT'S TIME.
I WANT TO ENCOURAGE -- MORE
THOUGHT ON THIS BUT TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE HAVE A SERIOUS
HOUSING CRISIS SHORTAGE.
AND AND AND THERE'S NO WAY TO
VERIFY -- THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS
ARE ACTUALLY OPENING THEIR HOMES
AND IN DOING LONG TERM
AGREEMENTS TO BE ABLE TO HOUSE
PEOPLE I JUST DON'T THINK THAT
WE CAN AFFORD. TO MESS WITH THE
READING A PROCESS AT THIS
PARTICULAR POINT IN TIME SO I
WOULD RECOMMEND IN OVER.
THANK YOU CENTER CABALLERO ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SING DANCE IN A PORTANTINO JOINT
TO CLOSE -- I THINK THEY NEED TO
HAVE TO HELP THE SENIOR
POPULATION IS IMPORTANT I THINK
THE VERIFICATION AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMES THROUGH
CITIES WANTING TO ACTUALLY MAKE
THIS WORK -- I THINK IT'S A GOOD
BILL I THINK THE SENIOR
COMMUNITY WHICH BROUGHT IT TO ME --
SEES THE NEED AND HOPEFULLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PORTANTINO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
HI ATKINS AYE BATES [inaudible]
BY BILL.
I PURCHASED.
AYE BRADFORD [inaudible]
CAFIERO [inaudible]
CHIANG.
I DODD.
BY THE RISE OF I GALGIANI
[inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO BY -- TOTAL
[inaudible]
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I AM MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN.
HI PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
BY RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG
[inaudible]
IOWA CASKEY [inaudible]
NO WIENER [inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
BUT BY [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
I MORE LOCK.
I THIRTY FOUR KNOWS TO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
NINE SENATOR GLAZER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO BY SENATOR
GLAZER AN ACT RELATING TO
STUDENT DATA.
CENTER GLAZER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
SB TWO IS A BILL THAT WOULD
CREATE A STATEWIDE DATA SYSTEM
TO TRACK.
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT PROGRESS FROM
PRESCHOOL THROUGH COLLEGE AND
INTO THE WORK FORCE.
CALIFORNIA COLLECTS A MASSIVE
AMOUNT OF DATA ABOUT STUDENTS
HOWEVER THE DATA THAT WE DO
COLLECT IS MAINTAINED.
IN SYSTEMS THAT ARE NOT
CONNECTED.
AND AS A RESULT OF THESE
DISCONNECTS.
IMPORTANT INFORMATION ABOUT
STUDENT PROGRESS.
IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO ACCESS.
THESE INFORMATION GAPS ARE A
SIGNIFICANT WEAKNESS.
IN OUR APPROACH TO MAKING GOOD
CHOICES ABOUT STUDENT PROGRESS
IN OUTCOMES.
OUR FUTURE STUDENTS WILL BE
GUIDED -- TO CLEAR PATHWAYS IF
IF WE KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENED TO
THEM IN THE PAST.
THAT DATA IS KEY TO POINTING
THEM AND US IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IN THE CHOICES WE MAKE.
AS POLICY MAKERS WITH THAT
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
GLAZER MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I'M JUST A CURIOUS ABOUT THIS
BILL I KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
IMPROVE OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
US NEWS AND WORLD REPORT RANKED
CALIFORNIA. TWENTY FIRST WITH
ITS K. THROUGH TWELVE AND THIRTY
ENTERS HIS BEING RANKED.
WAS RANKED TWENTY FIRST WITH
THIS K. THROUGH TWELVE A THIRTY
SEVENTH BUT BECAUSE OF OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IN FOURTH
PLACE -- THE AVERAGE CAME OUT TO
TWENTY FIRST IN USA TODAY.
HAS IS A THIRTY FIFTH FARM.
KIND OF SCRATCHING MY HEAD ON
WHY WE NEED TO DO A MASSIVE
DATABASE AND HOW WOULD MOVE UP.
OUR SYSTEMS ARE SCHOOL SYSTEMS
IN THE RANKINGS.
I'M ALSO WONDERING WHERE THE
MONEY TO PROVIDE FOR THE FUNDING
COME FROM PROP NINETY EIGHT
REVENUES.
I'M ALSO CURIOUS IF THE PROPOSED
TEN MILLION DOLLARS.
COULD MAYBE BE SPENT BETTER BY
PROVIDING INCENTIVES FOR HIGHER
PERFORMING TEACHERS.
AND A WHAT ELSE TELLS ME A
INTRIGUED IS WHY THE COURAGEOUS
[inaudible]
STATE SENATOR.
IS IS PROPOSING THIS LEGISLATION
AS OPPOSED TO PERHAPS THE
STATE'S DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
AND IT'S ELECTED SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION.
AND WILL THE CONCLUSION MANY
MANY YEARS FROM NOW BE A REQUEST
FOR MORE FUNDING. FOR SCHOOL
SYSTEMS BECAUSE THE
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORTS OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
INDICATE CORPUS GO MANAGEMENT.
WITH SACRAMENTO CITY SCHOOL
DISTRICT AS A GREAT EXAMPLE.
COLLEAGUES THE CURRENT SCHOOL
DISTRICT FUNDING MECHANISMS IN
THE CURRENT TEACHER COMPENSATION
PACKAGES ARE NOT WORKING IF THE
FACTORY IS BROKEN WHY TRACK THE
PRODUCT.
SITE CONSEQUENTLY I I REQUEST A
NO VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORLOCK.
SEE CENTER JACKSON.
QUESTION THE AUTHOR FINE MAY
CENTER GLAZER EXCEPT QUESTION
THANK YOU THERE IS SOME CONCERN
EXPRESSED BY THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE AMASSING.
LOTS OF INFORMATION ABOUT THESE
YOUNGSTERS ANNA SOMEONE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ACCUMULATION
OF PERSONAL DATA PARTICULARLY OF
REGARDING YOUNG PEOPLE -- COULD
YOU DISCUSS WHAT ARE THE
PROTECTION SO ARE YOU ARE
PLANNING TO PUT IN PLACE OF THAT
THIS INFORMATION.
IS NOT AGGREGATED AND USED IN
WAYS THAT ARE OTHER THAN WHAT
THIS BILL PURPORTS TO DESIGN
THEM TO DO.
GREAT WELL -- THROUGH THE CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION -- IT
IS A REQUIREMENT OF THE BILL
THAT.
THE WORK THAT'S DONE TO
CONSOLIDATE THESE DATA SYSTEMS.
AND A NEEDS SILO EDUCATION
SYSTEM REPORTS COLLECTED.
BUT AS WE BRING IT TOGETHER IN
AN ACCUMULATION THAT ALL EFFORTS
ARE MADE TO PROTECT THE PRIVACY
OF THE INDIVIDUALS HAT.
NONE OF THAT DATA IS TRACKED AS
A PERSON BUT RATHER AS A NUMBER
AND THAT'S REALLY PART OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE
AND WHY THESE SYSTEMS ARE
COMMUNICATING BECAUSE THE
NUMBERS THAT A PERSON'S ASSIGNED
TO TO PROTECT THAT PRIVACY.
IS A DIFFERENT NUMBER IN A
DIFFERENT SYSTEM SO THIS BILL I
IDENTIFIES THAT TASK FORCE TO TO
WORK TOGETHER TO CREATE THIS.
HOLIDAY DATA SYSTEM THE BILL
CALLS OUT PRIVACY IS A
REQUIREMENT FOR THE WORK THAT
THEY DO AND IT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT COMPONENT.
THAT THAT THAT PRIVACY BE
PROTECTED THANK YOU FOR MY OWN
TIME THE ISSUE OF PRIVACY IS ONE
THAT'S RAISED EVERY.
TIME WE LOOK AT THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE IT DOES HAVE THE ABILITY
TO STUDY IT THE STUDENTS
PROGRESS LONGITUDINALLY -- WILL
IMPACT THE SUCCESS OF THEIR
EDUCATION -- SO -- I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY HAVE TO DISAGREE
WITH MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY THIS IS A TOOL
THAT IT COULD VERY WELL BE.
A GREAT SOURCE OF ASSISTANCE TO
OUR STUDENTS AND TO OUR TEACHERS
IN THAT WHOLE PROCESS.
BUT I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PRIVACY ELEMENT HERE -- SO WITH
THE RECORD -- WITH THE
REPRESENTATIONS MADE BY THE GOOD --
CENTER FROM.
ORINDA.
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY -- I WILL
SUPPORT THIS BILL BUT AS IT
MOVES TOWARD I HOPE THAT YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO ASSURE
THAT ALL PRIVACY RIGHTS ARE NOT
ONLY PROTECTED.
BUT AGAINST THE BREACHES SO WE
DO SEE RATHER REGULARLY -- THIS
IS INFORMATION THAT DOES NOT
BELONG IN THE HANDS OF ANYONE
OTHER THAN OUR EDUCATION
COMMUNITY AND AGAIN HOPEFULLY IN
A NON IDENTIFY PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE WAY.
EXCEPT AS NECESSARY TO ASSIST
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE IN THEIR
EDUCATION.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON CENTER
STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AS ONE
ARISE BRIEFLY IN SUPPORT THE
MEASURE I KNOW FOR YEARS HERE.
WE'VE BEEN -- SORT OF HIDING OUR
EYES TO HOW WE'RE DOING
SOMETIMES IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE FATE OF MANY STUDENTS IS AND
HOW THEY DO -- WE'VE LEFT
FEDERAL MONEY ON THE TABLE OVER
THE YEARS I THINK IT'S HIGH TIME
WE CORRECTED THAT ESPECIALLY IF
WE'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING AT THE
FUTURE OF WORK. TO GO FURTHER UP
THAT PIPELINE AND LOOK AT HOW
STUDENTS ARE FARING IN OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM IN AND KNOW
WHAT KINDA JOBS THEY'RE GETTING
THEMSELVES PREPARED FOR WE NEED
TO KNOW.
WHAT THE OUTCOMES ARE SO I THINK
IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT MEASURE
IN APPRECIATE SHIPPING AND?
FOR THANK YOU CENTER STERN
SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'D
LIKE TO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE I THINK IT'S SO
IMPORTANT AS WE LOOK TO THE
FUTURE.
AND THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT MAY
OR MAY NOT BE THERE FOR OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE CURRENTLY IN
SCHOOL WITH THE ADVANCE OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCEROBOTICS --
WHAT JOBS ARE GOING TO BE THERE
WHAT CHARTER SCHOOLS BE
PROVIDING OUR CHILDREN ARE
BEGINNING IN KINDERGARTEN I SEE
IT AS A POSITIVE MEASURE?
OUR CONCERNS EXPRESSED CERTAINLY
ARE THERE BUT I THINK THE AUTHOR
HAS ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THOSE FOR
THE PRESIDENT AND IT'S SOMETHING
WE NEED TO SEE.
I THINK A WORK IN PROGRESS
MOVING FORWARD WILL BE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT INFORMATION. FOR THE
FUTURE OF OUR COUNTRY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER BATES THERE
GOES A WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
AT THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I CERTAINLY WANT TO
THANK THIS SENATOR FROM SANTA
BARBARA FROM RAISING THE PRIVACY
ISSUE IN.
THE LEGISLATION SPECIFICALLY
SAYS THAT PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION
COLLECTED FOR STORED IN OUR USE
FROM THE DATABASE IS
CONFIDENTIAL.
AND SHOULD NOT BE DISCLOSED I
AND IT GOES ON FURTHER TO SAY
THAT.
THAT THE STATE HAS TO FOLLOW ALL
STATE AND FEDERAL RULES IN TERMS
OF PRIVACY AND SO I KNOW IT'S UP
TO US TO PROTECT THAT PRIVACY
WITHIN OUR STATE RULES AND AND
THERE'S ALSO FEDERAL REGULATIONS
THAT.
REQUIRE IT AND I THINK THERE'S
COMFORT IN KNOWING THAT THIS IS
A PROVISION OF THIS LEGISLATION
GOING FORWARD.
AT THE SENATOR FROM ORANGE
COUNTY -- GIVES ME THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO TO MENTION TO
HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP FROM GOVERNOR NEWSOME
ON THIS ISSUE.
HE'S TALKED ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF LONGITUDINAL DATA HE HAS PUT
IN HIS BUDGET TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT.
A LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM SO
MONEY IS BEEN ALLOCATED FOR AT
THAT LONGITUDINAL DATA GOES
BEYOND K. THROUGH TWELVE THE
SENATOR MENTIONS IS CONCERNED
ABOUT.
LEADERSHIP FROM THE K. TO TWELVE
COMMUNITY THEY DO WORK IN THAT
COMMUNITY -- ON COLLECTING DATA
ANDTRYING TO LEARN FROM IT BUT
THIS MEASURE GOES BEYOND THAT IT
GOES TO PRESCHOOL IT GOES INTO
THE COLLEGE SYSTEM THAT GOES
INTO THE WORK FORCE.
AND CONNECTING ALL THAT TOGETHER
IS WIDELY LEADERSHIP FOR THINGS
LIKE THIS NEED TO COME FROM US
FROM OUR GOVERNOR FROM THE
SENATE.
SIDE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF WHAT
THIS INFORMATION TEACHES US
ABOUT HOW WE CAN DO OUR WORK
BETTER. TO MAKE EVERY PERSON
SUCCESSFUL EVERY STUDENT
SUCCESSFUL IN WHATEVER PATHWAY --
THEY DECIDE TO GO DOWN -- SO I
APPRECIATE THE FOR THE SUPPORT
FROM THE SENATOR FROM LAGUNA
MIGUEL.
AND FROM THE MY FRIEND FROM
VENTURA AND FOR ALL OF YOU WHO
WORK TOGETHER WITH THE STUDENTS --
COMMIT SENATE COMMITTEE ON
STUDENT SUCCESS.
TO HOLD A HEARING SPECIFICALLY
ON THIS ISSUE AND CRAFTED THIS
BILL INTO ITS FORM THAT WE SEE
TODAY WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BY BATES BY BILL BY BURGESS.
BY BRADFORD.
BY KELLY AT ALL.
I CHIANG.
BY DOT.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
BY HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES.
I LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN.
BY PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH I RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
AYE AMBERG.
BY WHAT CASKEY.
I WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
JACKSON HI [inaudible]
MORE LOCK. FIVE THREE SEVEN NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK ON FILE
ITEM ORDER TO FILE ITEM.
TWELVE SENATOR WIENER MISTER
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY SIX BY
SENATOR WINNER AND ACTOR LINDA
SENTENCING.
SENATOR WIENER.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH I REPEAL
IS A COMMON COSTLY.
AND INEFFECTIVE ONE YOUR
ENHANCEMENT THAT APPLIES FOR
EACH PRIOR FELONY.
TERM OR FELONY COUNTY JAIL TERM
OF IMPRISONMENT THAT INDIVIDUAL
HAS SERVED -- THE ENHANCEMENT IS
IS NOT TRIGGERED BY A PRIOR
FELONY CONVICTION.
BUT RATHER ONLY IF THE PERSON
SERVE TIME FOR THE PRIOR
CONVICTION.
THIS ONE YOUR ENHANCEMENT -- AND
COSTS EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER ENHANCEMENT BECAUSE THE COST
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO
INCARCERATE SOMEONE FOR A YEAR.
MORE THAN FIFTEEN THOUSAND STATE
PRISON SENTENCES CURRENTLY HAVE
THIS ANNOUNCEMENT.
AND THAT'S IN ADDITION TO A
LARGE NUMBER OF COUNTY JAIL
TERMS THAT HAVE THE ENHANCEMENT.
SO IF YOU DO THE MATH.
THAT'S ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS THAT THE TAXPAYERS ARE
PAYING FOR THIS ENHANCEMENT.
THIS IS A PERVASIVE SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENT BUT DOES LITTLE OR
NOTHING TO IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY
BUT COST US DEARLY.
THIS ONE YOUR ENHANCEMENT IS A
RATIONAL INDICTED ONLY APPLIES
IF THE PRIOR FELONY WAS PUNISHED
BY JAIL TIME.
SO IF YOU HAVE AN OFFENDER WITH
MULTIPLE FELONY OFFENSES ON
THEIR RECORD.
BUT WHAT IF THAT OFFENDER WAS
SENTENCED TO PROBATION
PREVIOUSLY INSTEAD OF JAIL TIME.
THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
ENHANCEMENT.
BUT IF SOMEONE WITH A MORE
SERIOUS PRIOR FELONY CONVICTION.
SERVICE EVEN A SMALL AMOUNT OF
TIME IN JAIL.
THEY ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR THE
ENHANCEMENT.
ONLY IF A PERSON SERVICE TIME
THIS DISTINCTION IS COMPLETELY
IRRATIONAL.
WHAT IS A RISE?
WHAT THIS A RATIONALITY
ACCOMPLISHES OF COURSE IS TO
EXACERBATE RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
DISPARITIES?
IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THE TWO STICKS SO THAT AFFLUENT
WHITE MALE IS FAR MORE LIKELY TO
BE SENTENCED TO PROBATION AND
THUS NOT ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
ENHANCEMENT.
AS OPPOSED TO JAIL OR PRISON
TIME.
A PERSON OF COLOR LOWER INCOME
PERSON IS MUCH MORE LIKELY TO BE
SENTENCED. TO JAIL OR PRISON
TIME AND THUS BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS ENHANCEMENT.
THIS DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR OUR
SYSTEM.
COLLEAGUES I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN TARGETED BY AN AGGRESSIVE
CAMPAIGN BY OPPONENTS OF THE
BILL.
IMPLYING OR EVEN EXPLICITLY
STATING.
THAT REPEALING THIS ENHANCEMENT
WILL MAKE IT HARDER TO PROSECUTE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND CHILD
ABUSE REPEAT OFFENDERS.
I'M REALLY IT'S SURPRISING TO
HEAR THAT BECAUSE IT IS
ABSOLUTELY UNTRUE.
CALIFORNIA HAS VARIOUS IS
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS THAT ARE
SPECIFIC TO DO REPEAT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE OFFENDERS AND REPEAT
CHILD ABUSE OFFENDERS. FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THE PENAL CODE
SPECIFICALLY ALLOWS A HIGHER BE
SENTENCE UP TO THREE YEARS
HIGHER FOR A SECOND.
OR SUBSEQUENT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CONVICTION.
AND ON TOP OF THAT IF THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESULTS IN
SKIN GREAT BODILY INJURY.
THE COURT HAS THE DISCRETION TO
IMPOSE.
A FIVE YEAR ENHANCEMENT THAT IS
SPECIFIC TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
REPEALING THIS ENHANCEMENT TODAY
WILL NOT UNDERMINE ANYWAY JUDGES
ABILITY TO PUNISH REPEAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OFFENDERS
HARSHLY.
REGARDING CHILD ABUSE THE PENAL
CODE PROVIDES A FOUR YEAR
ENHANCEMENT FOR A SECOND OR
SUBSEQUENT FELONY CHILD ABUSE
OFFENSE.
AND ON TOP OF THAT FOR YOUR
ENHANCEMENT THE PENAL CODE
PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL THREE
YEAR ENHANCEMENT.
IF GREAT BODILY INJURY WAS
INFLICTED ON THE CHILD AND A
FIVE YEAR ENHANCEMENT IF GREAT
BODILY INJURY WAS INFLICTED ON A
CHILD.
UNDER FIVE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AND CHILD ABUSE REPEAT OFFENDERS
HAVE THEIR OWN MUCH HARSHER
ENHANCEMENTS.
ON THIS ONE YOU'RE ENHANCEMENT.
SB ONE THIRTY SIX CHANGES NINE
OF THESE PUNISHMENTS OR
ENHANCEMENTS -- AT ALL AND TO
SUGGEST THAT THIS UNDERMINES OUR
ABILITY TO PUNISH THESE
OFFENDERS AROUND THE MASSIVE
VIOLENCE AND CHILD ABUSE.
IS MISLEADING ABOUT STE.
OPPONENTS ARE ALSO ADVANCING THE
NARRATIVE THAT REPEALING THIS
ENHANCEMENT WILL SOMEHOW REDUCE
JUDICIAL DISCRETION IN
SENTENCING.
BUT IS ALSO UNTRUE AS JUDGES
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT DISCRETION AND
IMPOSING SENTENCES ON REPEAT
OFFENDERS.
HI.
WE KNOW THAT IN VARIOUS RESPECTS
WHETHER IT IS IMPOSING THE LOWER
MID OR HIGH RANGE OF A SENTENCE
OR OTHER ENHANCEMENTS AND THEIR
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY OTHER
ENHANCEMENTS.
BY JUDGES WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
DISCRETION.
AND SPECIFIC TO SERIOUS AND
VIOLENT FELONIES.
BY THERE IS A SEPARATE FIVE YEAR
ENHANCEMENT. FOR REPEAT
OFFENDERS AND YOU CAN'T IMPOSE
BOTH THE ONE YEAR AND THE FIVE
YEAR AND SO THIS ONE YEAR
ENHANCEMENT IS NOT GOING TO
REPEALING IT WILL NOT UNDERMINE.
THE ABILITY OF JUDGES TO
SEVERELY PUNISH REPEAT SERIOUS
AND VIOLENT OFFENDERS.
MORE BROADLY SPEAKING COLLEAGUES
WE ARE TRYING TO MOVE AWAY FROM
CALIFORNIA'S UGLY HISTORY OF
MASS INCARCERATION.
OUR STATE ONE FROM TWENTY
THOUSAND STATE INMATES IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND IN
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT WITH A
QUADRUPLING OF THE RATE OF
INCARCERATION.
AND FOCUSING DISPROPORTIONATELY
ON BLACK AND LATINO PEOPLE
TEARING APART FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA BILL TWENTY THREE NEW
STATE PRISONS TO HOLD THIS
BURGEONING POPULATION.
AND IN THE PROCESS FOR MANY
YEARS WE SPENT MORE ON OUR
PRISON SYSTEM THAN ON CSU AND
YOU SEE COMBINED.
BY IN RECENT YEARS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING AS A STATE TO REPAIR THE
DAMAGE TO OUR BUDGET AND TO OUR
COMMUNITY SAID HAS BEEN
INFLICTED BY THIS BAD SYSTEM.
WE CAN HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR BEHAVIOR.
WITHOUT EXCESSIVELY LONG
SENTENCES TO DESTROY PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
TURNING A TWO YEAR BASS SENTENCE
FOR A LOW LEVEL CRIME IN TWO OR
THREE OR FOUR OR FIVE YEAR
SENTENCE JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
RESEARCH ALSO SHOWS THAT THESE
ENHANCEMENTS ARE INEFFECTIVE.
IT DOES NOT MAKE US SAFER.
COLLEAGUES SP ONE THIRTY SIX
PUTS AN END TO THIS A RATIONAL
INEFFECTIVE COSTLY AND
UNNECESSARY SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR DR -- THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE SENATOR NIELSEN.
THAT A PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE.
THIS ISN'T SO MUCH ABOUT MONEY
IT'S ABOUT JUSTICE [inaudible]
JUSTICE.
AND CONSEQUENCES GO HAND IN HAND.
AND CONSEQUENCES MEAN.
IF YOU IMPROVE.
THE CONSEQUENCES IMPROVE.
IF YOU DO NOT.
THE CONSEQUENCES INCREASE.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS REALLY ALL
ABOUT THE ENHANCEMENTS. ONE OF
THE DEFICIENCIES OF TERM LIMITS
IS LACK OF INSTITUTIONAL MEMORY
OR INTELLECTUAL CURIOSITY OF
WHAT WENT ON BEFORE.
AND IN SENTENCING THROUGH THE
SEVENTIES.
WE WERE UNDER SOMETHING WAS
CALLED THE INDETERMINATE
SENTENCE.
THAN A PROBOARDS MADE MOST ALL
THE DECISIONS WHETHER OR NOT AND
WHEN SOMEONE WOULD BE RELEASED.
BOTH LIBERALS AND CONSERVATIVES.
DIDN'T LIKE THAT.
AND SOUGHT A CHANGE. TO A
DETERMINATE SENTENCE SYSTEM. FOR
THE CONSERVATIVES THEN THEY
WOULD NOT HOLD THAT THIS
INDIVIDUAL WOULD SERVICE SO MUCH
TIME.
AND THE BE LESS.
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO GET
OUT CALLED EARLY.
THE MORE LIBERAL PERSUASION.
WERE ENTICED BECAUSE THE INMATE
WOULD KNOW WHEN THEY WOULD BE
RELEASED SO WHAT PASSED.
AND BOTH SIDES INCLUDING THE
GOVERNOR WHO SIGNED THAT
LEGISLATION.
LIVE TO RUE THE DAY.
THE GOVERNOR EVEN SAID THAT.
IT WAS A MISTAKE.
WE WENT OVER THEN AND NOW
THROUGH WHAT'S CALLED
REALIGNMENT.
NOW AS TO SAVING MONEY THAT CAN
GO IN THE HIGHER EDUCATION.
WE'VE BEEN IN THE THROES OF THIS
REALIGNMENT OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM FOR ABOUT FIVE
YEARS NOW.
IN THOSE FIVE YEARS GUESS WHAT
IN CONSERVATION COST OF DONE
[inaudible]
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
GOT UP.
THE SO CALLED RE ALIGNMENT
DIVIDEND.
MY TERM.
DID NOT HAPPEN.
THE COST OF INCREASED.
THERE WILL BE ARGUMENTS BUT THE
REASONS BUT THAT IT INCREASED.
CANNOT BE ON NOW.
IN TERMS OF REPETITIVE BEHAVIOR
THEIR TWO THINGS THAT I
MENTIONED.
REPETITIVE BEHAVIOR.
AN ESCALATING BEHAVE.
THAT MEANS IF YOU KEEP DOING THE
SAME THING EVEN THOUGH IT MAY BE
A LOWER LEVEL [inaudible]
DRUG OFFENSE.
THAT'S SHOWING CONCRETION
DISREGARD. FOR THE LAW
[inaudible]
THE CONSEQUENCES.
VIOLATING THE LAW.
ESCALATING BEHAVIOR THERE'S ONLY
TAKE THAT NEXT STEP.
THE BETTER EXAMPLE IS A PERSON
THAT.
FIRST THEY JUST GRAB AND RUN.
THEN THEY GRAB AND RUN.
THE WOMAN RESIST.
AND SHE GETS BEAT [inaudible]
ESCALATING BEHAVIOR.
THE ENHANCEMENTS AFTER THE
PASSAGE.
THE DETERMINANT SENTENCE LAW.
WERE PUT.
ON THE BOOKS.
BY SUCCESSIVE LEGISLATORS.
GOVERNORS AND EVEN THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FAIRLY RECENTLY IN FACT.
THE MARSHES LAW.
THE PEOPLE HAVE ACCEPTED THAT
YES SIR DO NEED TO BE INCREASING
CONSEQUENCES FOR REPETITIVE
BEHAVIOR.
AND THAT'S VERY SIMPLY WHAT THIS
IS ALL ABOUT.
IF YOU VOTE FOR IT.
DON'T HARBOR IN THE EXPECTATIONS
AT CSU AND YOU SEE ARE GONNA GET
RATE INCREASES IN THE BUDGET
NEXT YEAR.
THEY HAVE A NOR WILL THEY LET'S
THINK ABOUT.
CONSEQUENCES AND JUSTICE.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN CENTER
SKINNER.
THANK YOU AYE MADAM PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL [inaudible]
AND I HAVE IN MY HANDS.
THE SEVEN PAGES AND YOU CAN SEE
THE SIZE OF A OF ALL OF THE
SECTIONS OF THE PENAL CODE. FOR
WHICH CALIFORNIA OVER THE YEARS
HAS ADDED AN ENHANCEMENT.
NOW I ASK THE LA.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW VERY COMMONLY
WHEN WE DISCUSS THESE ITEMS
THERE'S A LOT OF A LOT OF PEOPLE
CERTAIN THINGS.
AND IT'S NOT OFTEN CLEAR WHETHER
IT'S ACCURATE SO I ASKED THE LA --
TO GIVE ME SOME ESTIMATES.
OF THE NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL
YEARS THAT ARE NOW BEING SERVED
TO DO ENHANCEMENTS I ALSO ASKED
HIM TO GIVE ME AN ESTIMATE.
OF THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED.
THAT.
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY ONE OR
MORE OF THESE ENHANCEMENTS IN AS
I SAID.
THERE ARE.
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY OF THEM.
WHICH THIS BILL DOESN'T COVER
ALL BUT THEY'RE STILL ON THE
BOOKS HUNDRED FIFTY AND THEY
RANGE SOME OF THE MAD. ONE YEAR
SOME OF THEM OUT UP TO FIVE
YEARS OTHERS OUT UP TO TEN YEARS.
IN SOME OUTSIDE MULTI GUIDE GIVE
CHOICES OF A NUMBER OF YEARS
ADDED.
IT'S FEWER THAN ONLY ADD ONE
YEAR.
ANYWAY SO I ASKED THE ONLY -- TO
TO GIVE ME SOME NUMBERS LIKE
THAT AND I ASKED THEM WHAT WAS
THE COST. TO CALIFORNIANS DUTIES.
THE REASON I ASK THAT IS BECAUSE
AS CHAIR OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY.
I HAVE OBSERVED THAT.
OVER THE YEARS EVEN THOUGH WE
HAVE -- THROUGH REALIGNMENT AND
OTHER THINGS.
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE SERVING IN OUR STATE PRISONS
[inaudible]
OUR COST.
CONTINUES TO GO UP TO THE POINT
NOW THAT WE ARE SPENDING SOME
THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS.
ON JUST THE STATE PRISONS MORE
THAN WE ARE SPENDING ON OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND WHEN I COMPARE IF I GIVE THE
EXAMPLE OF WE HAVE I'M SURE ALL
OF OUR OFFICES HAVE GOTTEN
LETTERS FROM THE UC SYSTEM.
INDICATING THAT JUST BY IN
ADDITION I BELIEVE OF I COULD BE
THE IT'S EITHER FORTY MILLION OR
HUNDRED MILLION I'M FORGETTING
EXACTLY WHICH FIGURE WE COULD.
BUY OUT THE THE TUITION
INCREASES THAT THEY HAD BEEN
CONSIDERING FOR MULTIPLE YEARS
NOT JUST ONE YEAR.
AND WE COULD GREATLY INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
THEN PERHAPS WE WOULD AVOID
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE WHAT WE'VE
JUST RECENTLY SEEN WE'RE ALREADY
WE HAVE AND WEALTHY CALIFORNIANS
TRYING TO BUY THEIR WAY.
INTO OUR UC SYSTEM BECAUSE WE DO
NOT HAVE ENOUGH SLOTS.
ANYWAY LET ME GO BACK TO MY
POINT.
SO THAT FORTY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION THAT'S PRETTY MINOR.
AND IT'S NOW.
TAKEN UP VERY MUCH BY.
OUR RISING COSTS OF OUR
CORRECTIONS SYSTEM SO WHAT THE
LA -- GAVE ME.
IS THAT.
USING FIGURES FROM SEPTEMBER
TWENTY SIXTEEN ABOUT 80%.
OF INDIVIDUALS IN OUR STATE
PRISONS HAD AT LEAST ONE
ENHANCEMENT.
AND THAT ESTIMATE WAS THAT.
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND OF
CALIFORNIA'S PRISON POPULATION.
HOW IS?
IT HOUSING ENHANCEMENT COULD BE
FIVE YEARS COULD BE TEN YEARS.
AND THEY ESTIMATED.
THAT THIS ULTIMATELY WOULD COST
US BILLIONS OF DOLLARS SPREAD
OVER YES A NUMBER OF YEARS BUT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
SO I THINK THAT IT IS.
PRUDENT FOR US TO LOOK AT HOW
MUCH DOES HAVE SERVED US FROM A
PUBLIC SAFETY POINT OF VIEW.
AND I ASK THAT BECAUSE PUBLIC
SAFETY IS THE LEGITIMATE LANDS
FOR US TO LOOK THROUGH.
CRIME IS DOWN AND HAS BEEN DOWN
FOR OVER TEN YEARS VIOLENT CRIME
ESPECIALLY YOUTH CRIME.
AND I THINK IT IS WISE FOR US TO
LOOK AT WHEN WE ARE DEBATE
WHETHER WE HAVE ADEQUATE FUNDS
FOR EXAMPLE FOR TEACHER SALARIES
FOR EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION OF
OUR ZERO TO FOUR YEAR OLDS.
OR FOR EXPANDING OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SHOULD WE BE INSTEAD
CONTINUING.
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS ON CERTAIN
CATEGORIES OF CRIMES THAT ARE
NOT REALLY SERVING US AND YET
COSTING US AS ELLIE -- HAS
ESTIMATED BILLIONS SO I ASKED
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THE USER SKINNER MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR CROW.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
SIR WE DO WE TAKE A QUESTION YES
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU M. MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO IN YOUR BILL
ONLINE -- PAGE TWO ITEMS -- LINE
SIXTEEN IT SAYS AN ADDITIONAL
TERM SHALL NOT BE IMPOSED.
UNDER THIS SUBDIVISION.
OF FOR THE CONVICTION OR PURPOSE
OF THIS SECTION VIOLENT FELONY
AND I'M SKIPPING DOWN TO TWENTY
NINE BECAUSE EVERYTHING ELSE IS
AMENDED OUT.
SHALL MEAN THE FOLLOWING MURDER
VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER MAY HIM
RATE AS DEFINED IN PARAGRAPH
SUBDIVISION SECTION TWENTY SIX
PARAGRAPH.
ONE FOUR AND I'M ASSUMING IT'S A
PARTICULAR RAPE.
SODOMY AS DEFINED IN SUBDIVISION
CD OF SECTION TWO EIGHTY SIX OR
COPULATION LEWD AND LASCIVIOUS
ACTS.
ANY FELONY PUNISHABLE BY DEATH
OR IMPRISONMENT AND ANY FELONY
WHICH DEFENDANT IT FLICKS GREAT
BODILY INJURY.
ARMED ROBBERY ARSON VIOLATION --
IN VIOLATION OF A SUBDIVISION AB
OR SECTION FOR FIFTY ONE SEXUAL
PENETRATION AS DEFINED IN
SUBDIVISION A OR J. ATTEMPTED
MURDER VIOLATION OF SECTION
EIGHTEENS AND 451-871-5187.
FIFTY FIVE KIDNAPPING ASSAULT
WITH INTENT TO COMMIT A
SPECIFIED FELONY IN VIOLATION OF
SECTION.
TWO TWENTY CONTINUOUS SEXUAL
ABUSE OF A CHILD IN VIOLATION OF
SECTION TWO EIGHTY EIGHT POINT
FIVE CAR JACKING.
REAP SPELL SO RAPE SEXUAL
PENETRATION IN CONCERT WITH A
VIOLATION OF SECTION TWO SIXTY
FOUR POINT.
ONE EXTORTION IS DEFINED IN
SECTION FIVE EIGHTEEN WHICH
COULD CONSTITUTE A FELONY.
AND IT GOES ON AND ON AND ON ARE
THESE THE PARTICULAR ITEMS
IDENTIFIED IN YOUR BILL THAT
WILL NOT INCUR AN ADDITIONAL ONE
YEAR ENHANCEMENT FOR PREVIOUS.
CONVICTIONS.
SORRY GO AHEAD SENATOR WIENER
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
THANK YOU AFTER I QUESTION MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD.
I COULD SIT HERE AND READ IT
WOULD TAKE A VERY LONG TIME SO I
DON'T WANT.
TO SPEND THAT AMOUNT OF TIME BUT
I COULDN'T READ -- OFF THE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY OTHER
ENHANCEMENTS BETTER MUCH HARSHER.
THAN THE ONE YOU'RE ENHANCEMENT
FOR EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THE
CRIMES -- THEY USE HAS LISTED
OFF AND IN FACT FOR SERIOUS AND
VIOLENT FELONIES AND THOSE ARE
ALL FAR AS I KNOW SERIOUS
VIOLENT FELONIES.
THERE IS A FIVE YEAR ENHANCEMENT
AND YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO A
COURT CANNOT IMPOSE BOTH THE
FIVE YEAR.
AND THE ONE YEAR AND SO IF WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
PEOPLE WHO COMMIT SERIOUS AND
VIOLENT FELONIES.
YOU'RE GOING TO GO WITH A FIVE
YEAR AND THEN YOU'RE NOT EVEN
ALLOWED TO APPLY THE ONE YEAR IN
ADDITION SOME OF THE CRIMES THAT
YOU MENTIONED -- FOR EXAMPLE
CHILD ABUSE KIND OF CRIMES ARE
COVERED BY YEAH AND ADDITIONAL
ENHANCEMENTS SPECIFIC THE CHILD
ABUSE THEIR ENHANCEMENTS
SPECIFIC TO THE MASTER BONDS
SPECIFIC TO KIDNAPPING SPECIFIC
TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
AND THEN THERE ARE OF COURSE
STRIKES BECAUSE YOU CAN GET AN
ENHANCEMENT AND IT CAN QUALIFY
AS A STRIKE AND HAD YOU TOWARDS
LIFE IN PRISON -- SO THESE
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT CRIMES ARE
COVERED BY OTHER HARSHER LONGER
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS -- THIS
IS NOT THE ENHANCEMENT DIE IS
GOING TO BE APPLIED TO THOSE
KINDS OF CRIMES.
THANK YOU ON MY OWN TIME MADAM
PRESIDENT IS RECEIVED I'M JUST
ARE I JUST WAS READING THE BILL
TO FIND OUT OF BECAUSE YOU KNOW
REALISTICALLY IF SOMEBODY'S
GOING TO GET A FIVE YEAR PRISON
ENHANCEMENT AND ADDITIONAL YEAR.
WOULD BE -- I DON'T KNOW I WAS
CONSIDERING YOUR BILL IS WHAT I
WAS DOING AND THEN I READ ALL
THIS INFORMATION ON HERE BECAUSE
IT'S JUST A VERY SHORT FOUR PAGE
BILLER FIVE PAGE BILL.
BUT THE WAY IT READS IS THAT
YOUR ELIMINATING AN ADDITIONAL
ONE YEAR ENHANCEMENT FOR
PREVIOUS CONVICTIONS OF ALL OF
THESE IDENTIFIED VIOLENT
FELONIES.
N. SO I MEAN IN MY MIND OF
SOMEBODY RAPES REGARDLESS OF THE
DIVISION OR THE THE DESCRIPTION
WHICH IS DEFINED OR COMMIT
SODOMY ALL OF THESE LEWD AND
LASCIVIOUS ACTS -- ARSON
KIDNAPPING.
AGAIN SPELL SO RAPE -- ALL OF
THOSE THINGS IF THEY REPEAT THIS
ACT I DON'T CARE IF THEY GET A
TWENTY YEAR ENHANCEMENT.
THEY SHOULD SERVE A PRISON TIME
AND ANY ADDITIONAL ENHANCEMENT
THAT A JUDGE COULD PROVIDE WOULD
BE BENEFICIAL TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY IN SOCIETY SO I WOULD
REQUEST A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR BATES MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR PAM.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- I
ACTUALLY -- SHARED TO MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM -- BAKER FEELS
CONCERN BUT I ALSO HAD A
ACTUALLY CONVERSATION ONLY WITH
THE AUTHOR BUT HAD MY STAFF LOOK
INTO THE ISSUE AND I THINK AS
HE'S EXPLAINED -- BECAUSE MY
CONCERN WAS THAT SOMEONE
COMMITTED A VIOLENT FELONY
ANSWERS FELONY AND THEY'VE COME
IN OTHER ONE THAT.
PERHAPS THERE SHOULD BE AT THE
JUDGE'S DISCRETION AN
ENHANCEMENT.
AND IN FACT I THINK IS SEIZE
CLEARLY STATED BOTH YOUR ON THE
FLOOR AND CERTAINLY -- WE SEEN
ALSO IN MY STAFF'S OWN
EXAMINATION THAT ACTUALLY THERE
ARE OTHER -- SHE MORE SEVERE
ENHANCEMENTS AND IN FACT THIS
PARTICULAR HAND SMIT CANNOT BE
EMPLOYED.
IF THOSE OTHER ENHANCEMENTS ARE
USED SO I THINK -- FOR THAT
REASON.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WHAT
DOES NOT ALLOW CRIMINALS WHO --
GAUGING SERIOUS VIOLENT FELONIES
TO ACTUALLY GET A NECESSARILY A
LESSER SENTENCE TO AND THEREFORE
I SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PANCER BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF ONE THREE SIX
AND I THINK HISTORY HAS SHOWN US
OVER THE LAST FORTY YEARS THAT.
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS ARE TOUGH
ON CRIME MEASURES HAVE NOT
SUCCEEDED AT ALL ALL WE'VE DONE
IS OVER POPULATE OUR PRISONS AND
COST AGAIN THE TAXPAYERS MORE
MONEY.
BUT I AM IN TOTAL AGREEMENT WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM TO HIM WHEN HE
SAYS THIS IS ABOUT JUSTICE.
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
IT'S JUST US BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE WHO ARE RECEIVING
ATTACHMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING MANSER WINNER
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT ARE COLORS FIRST OF
ALL ON THE ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED --
AND THE SECTION THE BILL THAT
WAS READ BY THE SENATOR FROM
BAKERSFIELD -- LOOKING BACK AT
THE BILL THOSE ARE ALL -- THOSE
ALL PERTAIN TO THE THREE YEAR
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENT THAT IS NOT
BEING REPEALED SO THE THE
SECTION ISSUE HERE IS BOTH THE
ONE YEAR.
AND A THREE YEAR -- AND WE'RE
NOT REPEALING THE THREE YEAR
ONLY REPEALING -- THE ONE YEAR --
SO JUST TO TO CLARIFY THAT THE
LIST OF REALLY -- HEINOUS CRIMES
IS NOT WHAT'S AT ISSUE HERE THE
THREE YEAR AND HANDSOME WILL
STILL BE IN EFFECT.
AS WILL THE FIVE YEAR
ENHANCEMENT AND THE MANY OTHER
THREE FOUR FIVE SEVEN TEN TWENTY
YEAR ENHANCEMENTS IN ALL OF THE
STRIKES.
AND ALL OF THE WAYS THAT WE HAVE
OF INCARCERATING PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA -- THIS IS ABOUT
TAKING ONE PARTICULAR
ENHANCEMENT. ONE YEAR WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE DEADLY AND
MOST SERIOUS AND HEINOUS CRIMES
HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LOW
LEVEL OFFENSES.
WHERE PEOPLE ARE BEING OVER
INCARCERATED NOT SAYS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR BEHAVIOR
BUT OVER INCARCERATED HAVING
THEIR LIVES DESTROYED HAVING
THEIR COMMUNITIES?
TORN APART UNDERMINING
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO PAY FOR
THINGS LIKE HEALTH CARE AND
HIGHER EDUCATION WE NEED TO STOP
WITH THE MASS INCARCERATION AND
THIS ENHANCEMENT IS PART OF THE
PROBLEM AND NEEDS TO BE REPEALED
I ASKED FOR AN AIBO.
THANK YOU CENTER WINNER MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS.
BY BATES.
NOBEL I PORGES.
NO BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
BY GALGIANI [inaudible]
NO GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
BY HILL.
AYE HUESO BY -- TITLE.
JACKSON.
BY JONES.
NO.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
BY COUNTY.
I WINNER BY WILK.
NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARCHULETA [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible] FOR TITLE
[inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
NUMBER.
OF THE OF THE MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
GLAZER -- TADO [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
NUMBER REMOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN SENATOR PAN MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIXTY FIVE A SENATOR
PAN ACKERLEY IN HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
CENTERS UP MANY CALIFORNIANS ARE
STRUGGLING EVERY MONTH TO AFFORD
THEIR HEALTH INSURANCE PREMIUMS
AND COST SHARING AND WE'VE MADE
A LOT MUCH PROGRESS UNDER THE
ACA TO EXPAND ACCESS.
THE COPPERS OF COVERAGE BUT
THERE'S STILL MORE WE CAN DO
ESPECIALLY WITH ACTIONS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AIMED AT AND DOING
THIS PROGRESS.
WHEN THE THINGS WE CAN DO TO
HELP KEEP COSTS DOWN TO
ENCOURAGE ROMAN AND HELP
CALIFORNIANS IS INCREASED
SUBSIDIES TO HELP PEOPLE FOR THE
PREMIUMS?
SB SIXTY FIVE WILL CREATE A
STATE SUBSIDY PROGRAM TO HELP
PEOPLE BUY HEALTH INSURANCE TO
COVER CALIFORNIA.
SB SIXTY FIVE PROVIDE STATE
FUNDED SUBSIDIES FOR PEOPLE WITH
INCOMES UP 26100% OF THE POVERTY
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL NOW POINT
OUT THAT THAT.
REALLY IS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HELPING OUT PEOPLE IN THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
SB SIXTY FIVE GIVES COVER
CALIFORNIA AUTHORITY TO DOT
PROGRAM DESIGNED BUT REQUIRES
COVER CAL FOR THE PAY THE
SUBSIDY TO THE PLANS.
AND PLANS WILL COLLECT THE REST
OF THE PREMIUM FROM THE CONSUMER.
BASE ANALYSIS FROM COVER
CALIFORNIA SB SIXTY FIVE WOULD
BRING IN A HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND NEW ROWLEY'S INTO
COVERAGE -- WOULD ALSO.
REDUCE PREMIUMS -- BY FORTY
DOLLARS PER MONTH ON AVERAGE.
FOR SIX HUNDRED SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
ACTUALLY ON THE EXCHANGE BECAUSE
WE'RE ACTUALLY IMPROVING THE
OVERALL CASE MIX OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE COVERED WITH HEALTH
INSURANCE PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS THE TIME FOR US TO STEP
UP AND HELP.
BOTH LOW INCOME THE MIDDLE CLASS
SURE THAT THEY CAN AFFORD HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE AND WE NEED TO
STABILIZE THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
INSURANCE MARKET.
IN A TIME WHEN FORTUNATELY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
UNDERMINING THIS HEALTH
INSURANCE MARKET.
WE NEED TO KEEP HEALTH INSURANCE
AFFORDABLE FOR PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT AND HELP. TO
CALIFORNIANS PURCHASE HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE THANK YOU THE USER PAN
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
NO.
BRADFORD.
BY CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
BY [inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TACO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LUCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
BY.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER.
BY STERN.
BY STONE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
NUMBER.
IOWA OUT SEE I WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BY.
AYE ALLEN AYE [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO -- TADO [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NO.
LIES THIRTY NO SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO LIST THE
FILE ON IT WILL IF THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM TWELVE SENATOR WIENER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ARCHULETA
[inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
GLAZER -- TODDLE [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
NUMBER.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ONE MORE
TIME ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GLAZER I FOR TITLE [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I TWENTY ONE KNOWS ELEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NOW WE WILL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY SENATOR CARRIER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUR
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY BY
SENATOR CAFIERO ANAK WILLING TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
CENTER CABALLERO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES I RATE RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB.
TWO THIRTY A BILL DESIGNED TO
REDUCE THE USE OF FORCE BY
POLICE OFFICERS.
THAT WILL CHANGE THE CULTURE IN
THE WORKPLACE OF OVER FIVE
HUNDRED LINE FORSMAN AGENCIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHEN I FIRST INTRODUCED THIS
BILL IN FEBRUARY PEOPLE ASK ME
WHY WOULD YOU BE INTERESTED IN
THE BILL THAT IT THAT IS SO
CONTROVERSIAL?
WELL TELL YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I SERVED AS A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER FOR FIFTEEN YEARS EIGHT
AS MAYOR.
AND AS MAYOR AND COUNCIL MEMBER
I TO VERY SERIOUSLY AND
PERSONALLY THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
CREATE PEACE.
SAFETY AND HARMONY AMONG ALL
RESIDENTS OF THE COMMUNITY NO
MATTER WHO YOU ARE WHAT YOU LOOK
LIKE.
HOW YOU DRESS OR WHAT KIND OF
WORK YOU DID?
THE ISSUE OF WHEN THE USE OF
FORCE BY POLICE OFFICERS AS
APPROPRIATE AND WENT.
UNDER WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES WAS
VERY PERSONAL TO ME.
AND IT IS EMOTIONAL COMPLEX AND
DIVISIVE.
WE MUST COME TOGETHER AND FOCUS
ON THE TRUE INTENT OF THIS BILL.
WHICH IS TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
USE OF FORCE INCIDENTS.
CALIFORNIANS NEED TO STAND
TOGETHER AND LEAD THE WAY
FORWARD TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR OFFICERS AS
THEY UPHOLD THEIR COMMITMENT TO
SERVE.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS THAT
WE KNOW THAT POLICE AGENCIES AND
THEIR OFFICERS HAVE TO DO A
BETTER JOB.
OFFICERS AND THEIR SUPERVISORS
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING IN THEIR
POWER TO MINIMIZE THE USE OF
FORCE USED.
AND THOSE OFFICERS THE CONTINUE
TO USE UNNECESSARY FORCE SHOULD
BE GONE FROM POLICING.
WE HAVE RESEARCH AND SURVEYED
THE MOST EFFECTIVE METHODS
PROVEN TO REDUCE THE USE OF
FORCE.
SB THIRTY TO THIRTY IS AN
EVIDENCE BASED APPROACH THAT
FOCUSES N ADOPTING NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED BEST PRACTICES WITH
PROVEN RESULTS.
THE BILL WILL RAISE THE NATIONAL
STANDARD TO PROTECT THE SANCTITY
OF LIFE BY REQUIRING THAT THE
USE OF FORCE BE PROPORTIONAL TO
THE THREAT IMPOSED.
THAT IT ESTABLISHED THE FIRST
STATEWIDE GUIDELINES TO CLEARLY
DEFINED WHEN OFFICERS ARE
AUTHORIZED TO USE FORCE.
REQUIRE THAT EVERY CALIFORNIA
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER RECEIVED
THE MOST RIVER ROBUST TRAINING
IN THE NATION STRICTLY DESIGNED
TO MINIMIZE THE USE OF FORCE.
SET SPECIFIC POLICY REQUIREMENTS
ON DE ESCALATION INTERPERSONAL
COMMUNICATION TRAINING A
TACTICAL METHODS THAT USED TIME
DISTANCE COVER AND CONCEALMENT.
REQUIRE IMPLICIT AND EXPLICIT
BIAS AND CULTURAL COMPETENCY
TRAININGS.
ESTABLISHING A DETAILED
STANDARDIZED REQUIREMENTS FOR
REPORTING ALL INSTANCES WHEN
FORCES USED SPECIAL SPECIFY THE
USE OF FORCE POLICIES AND
TRADING ARE CONSIDERED IN LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS.
AND ADDING NEW DUTIES SUCH AS A
DUTY TO RENDER MEDICAL AID THE
DUTY OF OFFICERS TO INTERCEDE
AND REPORT INCIDENTS OF
EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE.
AND THE DUTY OF SUPERVISORS TO
REPORT AND INVESTIGATE INCIDENTS.
ALL OF THESE NEW GUIDELINES AND
DUTIES WILL REQUIRE THAT THE
FIVE HUNDRED POLICE AGENCIES AND
THEIR OFFICERS UNDERGO A NEW
TRAINING AND EDUCATION PROGRAM.
THROUGH POST OR THE POLICE
OFFICER STANDARD TRAINING
PROGRAM.
SB TWO THIRTY MAKES FUNDAMENTAL
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGES TO HOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ARE TRAINED
AND THIS WILL AND ENABLE THE
CULTURE SHIFT AWAY FROM USING
FORCE TO GET COMPLIANCE.
I ALSO WANT TO THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER FOR HER WORK TO DO
DEDICATION AND COMMITMENT -- TO
AB.
THREE NINETY TWO AND AND HER
COMMITMENT TO CHANGE TO MAKE
CHANGE FOR THE BETTER FOR THE
BETTERMENT OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND ALSO FOR WORKING AND TALKING
WITH ME ABOUT THIS BILL.
THIS BILL FOCUSES ON SOLUTION TO
CREATE MEANINGFUL CHANGE AND
RECEIVED NO NO VOTE IN PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER CABALLERO
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
NIELSEN.
WELL PRESENT LADIES IN GENERAL
THE SENATE THIS IS BEEN.
A RATHER CONTROVERSIAL COURSE OF
ADVANCE.
THE EVOLUTION OF THE BILL'S.
THREE NINETY TWO AND I WANT TO
THANK.
THE SENATOR FROM THE COAST
[inaudible]
FOR AUTHORING THIS.
I SAY A MORE USEFUL VERSION. ONE
THAT WOULD BE MUCH MORE
RESPECTFUL OF THE LIVES OF OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS IN
LIVES IT WOULD AFFECT MEETING
THEIR FAMILIES.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
AUTHOR TO OF THE BILL THAT I'VE
OPPOSED.
THAT THERE IS APPEARS TO HAVE
BEEN.
A WILLINGNESS TO NEGOTIATE.
SOMETHING THAT IS.
MUCH BETTER SENSE IN TERMS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IF YOU HAVE NOT WALKED THE LINE.
OR BEEN CLOSE TO IT YOU HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT THESE CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE.
WERE BY FORCE IS USED.
S. FORCES BEING CONFRONTED.
BY THAT OFFICER.
YOU'RE NOT AWARE OF BY THE
EVENING NEWS CLIP FROM
SOMEBODY'S PHONE.
OF WHAT HAPPENED PRECEDING THAT
PARTICULAR MOMENT OF THE CLIP.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY.
YOU DO NOT KNOW.
WHAT GOES THROUGH THE MINDS OF
THE INDIVIDUALS [inaudible]
THE QUESTION [inaudible]
THE PERPETRATOR.
THEN THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSION [inaudible]
THIS BILL.
GOES A LONG WAY TO ACCOMPLISHING.
THE CONCERNS I THINK OF MANY.
WHO ADVOCATED SO VIGOROUSLY FOR
A STRONGER BILL
THE STRONGER BILL.
WOULD HAVE WEAKENED.
THE SAFETY.
OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS.
THEN I CLEARLY ARGUE FOR THE
CITIZENS.
WHEN AN INCIDENT OCCURS
[inaudible] FOR EXAMPLE.
WITH A GUN.
IN A PERPETRATOR STARTS TO PULL
THE TRIGGER.
OFTENTIMES THEY DON'T QUIT.
WITH THE FIRST FULL [inaudible]
THEY CONTINUE.
AND BYSTANDERS ARE OFTTIMES
[inaudible]
AFFECTED [inaudible]
THAT HAPPENS [inaudible]
EVERY YEAR.
THIS CONTROVERSIAL IN THIS.
AGONIZING IS THIS BILL HAS BEEN
SO FAR.
IT IS MY HOPE THAT WE REACHED A
MOMENT OF CON FOR MICE AND I
COMPLEMENT ALSO THE LEADERSHIP
FOR BEING INVOLVED IN THIS.
AND I'M HOPING THAT THIS
OCCASION.
IN THE LEGISLATURE AS WE WOULD
BE VOTING.
WE CAN HAVE TRUST.
THAT THE DEAL THAT IS HERE
WROUGHT.
IT'S GOING TO STAY IN PLACE.
THE NOT BE CHANGED LATER IN THE
YEAR.
BY SOMEONE ARGUING THAT CHANGE
OF CIRCUMSTANCE.
I'M PUTTING MY TRUST IN MY
COLLEAGUES IN THIS INSTITUTION.
WELL ABOVE MY VOTE YES. FOR THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN CENTER
ARCHULETA.
ADAM PRESIDENT I'M SO PROUD
HONOR TO BE A CO AUTHOR IN THIS
BILL. TWO THIRTY IT IS.
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE ALL EXCITED
ABOUT BECAUSE BOTH HOUSES OF
COME TOGETHER.
IN AYE I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THE TIME AND EFFORT THAT SHE PUT
TOGETHER WITH HER COLLEAGUES --
FROM THE ASSEMBLY.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THE FACT
THAT WE CAN ALL RECOGNIZE THAT
WHEN WE COME TOGETHER. FOR THE
BETTERMENT OF THE COMMUNITY
BETTERMENT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THE BETTERMENT OF ALL OF US
WHO SERVE THIS GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT WE CAN SHOW THAT WE CAN
COME TOGETHER TO RE REALIZE THAT
THERE ARE THINGS THAT HAVE TO BE
CORRECTED AND I THINK THERE'S NO --
NO ONE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
REALIZE IS MORE THAN ALL OF US
THAT WE HAD TO MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS.
AND I THINK THE EDUCATION AND
THE TRAINING ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE EQUAL NOT
ONE NOT ONE DIFFERENT IN IN LA
COUNTY ORANGE COUNTY SEVER DEAL
COUNTY.
OR UP IN SAN FRANCISCO.
IT SHOULD ALL BE EQUAL THE
TRADING SHOULD BE THE SAME
ACROSS THE BOARD. TO TRAIN AND
TEACH OUR MEN AND WOMEN IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE TEACH WE TREAT
PEOPLE WITH DIGNITY WITH PRIDE
WITH RESPECT.
AND WE MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
IS AFFORDED THAT OPPORTUNITY.
THAT THE COURTS ARE THERE FOR A
REASON AS LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
THERE FOR A REASON AS WELL.
SO I THINK THIS NOT ONLY COMES
IN PUBLIC SAFETY BUT OFFICER
SAFETY AS WELL.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY GOD KNOWS
HOW MANY LIVES YOU WILL SAVE.
AND I JUROR -- I VOTE THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU CENTER ARE TO
LET US SENATE SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT AS I STOOD IN PUBLIC
SAFETY AFTER WE WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SOME CLARITY IN TERMS OF
THE LANGUAGE THAT WAS PROPOSED
IT WAS PROPOSED.
LAST MINUTE IN PUBLIC SAFETY SO
IT TOOK A FEW MINUTES TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE SCOPE.
ON THE NATURE OF THE CHANGES I
WAS SPOKE THEN.
ALL AND SUPPORTED AND CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT SO DID TUESDAY TO DO
SO TODAY -- I AM GLAD THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO GET TO A POINT.
ALL THAT THE TWO BILLS COULD BE
COULD JOINED AND WE CAN HAVE A
FULLER CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
TRUE ISSUE IMPACT THE LONG
COURSE MEANT.
AND RESIDENTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO HEAR WORDS SPOKEN ON
THIS FLOOR THAT CONTINUES TO
DENY.
THAT WE HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEM.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES ACROSS THIS
STATE.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE MADAM
PRESIDENT ALL LIFE.
IS VALUABLE.
THOSE WHO WEAR BLUE.
AND THOSE WHO ARE BLACK AND
BROWN EQUALLY.
THE NOTION OF TRUST.
THE NOTION OF TRUST IS IS REALLY
A TWO WAY STREET.
AND SO I'M CASTING MY VOTE TODAY
BECAUSE I DO FUNDAMENTALLY
BELIEVE THAT TRAINING IS
NECESSARY TO CREATE CULTURE
SHIFT.
THE TRAINING IS NECESSARY TO
CREATE A CULTURAL COMPETENCY
[inaudible]
AMONG THOSE.
WHO TAKEN -- TO PROTECT AND
SERVE ALL OF US. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE REALLY IS AN
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
PERCEIVED BY CERTAIN SEGMENTS OF
THE POPULATION.
AND THAT WE CAN GET TO A PLACE
WHERE ALL COMMUNITIES FEEL
EQUALLY PROTECTED AND SERVED BY
THOSE WE ENTRUST WITH THAT DUTY
AND RESPONSIBILITY.
AND SO YES I LOOK FORWARD TO
VOTING FOR SB.
TWO THIRTY I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON BEHALF OF
ITS COMPANION BILL ON THE SENATE
FLOOR ONCE AGAIN.
AND HOPE THAT WE CAN ALL AS HAVE
THE OPPONENTS AND PROPONENTS OF
THESE TWO BILLS.
CHANGE OUR OWN THOUGHTS AND
MINDS AND LANGUAGE AS WE TALK
ABOUT APPROPRIATE POLICING FOR
THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA.
I STAND IN SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO THIRTY THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL CENTER HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT SHE'S.
MANY RECALL WHO ON THIS FLOOR
LAST YEAR.
THAT WE WERE FACED WITH THIS
MESS THIS ISSUE BECAUSE OF VERY
CHALLENGING -- ISSUES THAT WERE
REFERRED TO BY THE AUTHOR AND
OTHERS WHO SPOKE ON THIS.
I JUST WANT TO SHARE BECAUSE I
CARE SO MUCH ABOUT THE PROCESS.
THAT SINCE THAT TIME NEARLY A
YEAR AGO.
THE PRO TEM HAS BEEN WORKING
TIRELESSLY SHE MADE A COMMITMENT
AT THAT TIME TO ALL OF US.
WHO ARE LOOKING TO VOTE ON THIS
TO COME UP WITH THE WAY FORWARD
IT WAS A CHALLENGING WAY FORWARD
AND I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT THESE
THINGS CAN BE?
AND OFTEN AS WE DEBATE THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES WE FORGET ABOUT.
THE LARGER PROCESS AND HOW MUCH
ENERGY AND TIME AND LEADERSHIP
IT TAKES TO DO THAT.
AND I JUST WANT.
TO GIVE HER THE GREAT CREDIT
THAT'S DUE EVEN THOUGH HER NAME
DOESN'T APPEAR ON EITHER OF
THESE BILLS BUT DOING THE RIGHT
THING GETTING IT DONE TAKING THE
TIME.
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING THEM SENATE
CAREER YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT AND
AND YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
SENATOR I WAS REMISS IN NOT
RECOGNIZING OUR OUR ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM I WANT TO
THANK HER VERY MUCH.
FOR KEEPING OUR FEET TO THE FIRE
IN MAKING SURE THAT EVERYBODY
WAS AT THE TABLE AND THAT WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS -- EVEN EVEN
THOUGH IT WAS A DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYBODY WAS THERE AND SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO HER.
THIS BILL IS A RECOGNITION THAT
WE HAVE A PROBLEM AND IT'S A
RECOGNITION THAT WE NEED A
SOLUTION AND THAT IT'S UP TO US
TO BE ABLE TO COME UP WITH THAT
SOLUTION AND THEN TO FIND IT.
AND SO -- THE THIS BILL IS.
A SET UP AND IT IS LINKED TO AB
THREE NINETY TWO AND I EXPECT
THAT -- WE ALL WILL SUPPORT IT
WHEN IT COMES OVER HERE I AM IT
IS.
ANA THERE'VE BEEN A LOT OF OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE WORKED REALLY
HARD ON THIS AND SOMEONE TO
THINK THANK ALL OF THEM AS WELL
AND INTO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THAT ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN A AND IF
I COULD -- MADAM PRESIDENT --
THIS INVOLVED.
A LOT OF PEOPLE COMING TO
SACRAMENTO AND PARTICIPATING IN
THE POLITICAL PROCESS A LOT OF
PEOPLE FROM -- MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WHO UP FELT VERY
VERY STRONGLY ABOUT THE ISSUE
AND I WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE MEN
AND DOT AND HONOR THEIR
COMMITMENT TO A POLITICAL
PROCESS.
THAT -- THAT IS FUNDAMENTALLY
GOING TO GOING TO CHANGE THE WAY
THAT WE DO POLICING HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO -- I I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER CABALLERO
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE EYES
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY FOUR SENATOR RUBIO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR RUBIO AND ACCOLADES
TAXATION TO TAKE BACK TO MERELY
TAX LEVY.
CENTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS CHAIR RICE TO PRESENT.
SB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE THIS BILL
CONFORM STATE LAW TO PROVISIONS
IN THE FEDERAL LAW PROVIDING TAX
EXEMPT STATUS TO ME TO WATER
COMPANIES.
AFFECTED FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TACK FOUR YEAR.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
RECOGNIZE THE FEDERAL FIVE OH
ONE C. TWELVE TAX EXEMPT STATUS
OF MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES AND
THEREFORE THE RESIDENTS OF ME TO
WATER COMPANIES AND THE FACT.
OUR TAX IF THEY ACCEPT THE
GROUND TO HELP OR CONSOLIDATE
THEIR WATER SYSTEMS. 80% OF
THOSE SYSTEMS LISTED ARE SMALL
MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES THE
REALITY IS THAT MANY MUTUAL
WATER COMPANY SERVE AREAS THAT
ARE GEOGRAPHICALLY ISOLATED FROM
LARGER PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS IN
MOUNTAINOUS AREAS.
AS WELL AS THE STATE'S DESERT'S
WHERE WATER SERVICES ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
IN THOSE CASES THE LOGISTIC
IMPEDE ON THE ECONOMIC WELL AS
OUR ECONOMICAL PHYSICAL
CONNECTION BETWEEN SYSTEMS OR
EVEN A MANAGERIAL CONSOLIDATION.
MEMBERS THIS BILL PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY THANK COMMITTEE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
BUT YOU CENTER RUBIO MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING THAT MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION IS A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE AYE AYES
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES WE ARE NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX SENATOR
WILK.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY THREE
BY SENATOR WILL CONNECT WILLING
TO HOMELESSNESS.
SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA'S ON THE
BRINK OF DEDICATING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TOWARDS THE HOMELESS
CRISIS.
AND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
MONEY IS SPENT EFFECTIVELY
SENATE BILL THREE THREE THREE
WILL REQUIRE THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING A FINANCING COUNCIL
TO DEVELOP A LONG TERM STRATEGIC
PLAN TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS.
BASED UPON THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM A REPORT.
RELEASED LAST YEAR BY THE STATE
AUDITOR -- THESE POLICIES ALONG
WITH SPECIFIC DATES AND
BENCHMARKS WILL ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA.
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY
ADDRESSES THE HOMELESS CRISIS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WILK MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USE A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
SIXTY EIGHT BEAR WITH ME HERE.
SENATOR GLAZER FILE ITEM.
SIXTY EIGHT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL SIX
FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR GLAZER AN
ACT RELATING TO TENDENCY CENTER
GLAZER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANKS
YOUR GOOD WORK TODAY.
IS THE DAY.
OUR MEMBERS SB SIX FORTY FOUR
WOULD - PROVIDE RENTAL RELIEF
TO ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS
BASED IN CALIFORNIA.
BY REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF
SECURITY DEPOSIT SERVICE MEMBERS
ARE REQUIRED TO PAY. TO MOVE
INTO A RENTAL UNIT.
SB SIX FORTY FOUR WOULD ALSO
PROHIBITS LANDLORDS FROM
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST SERVICE
MEMBERS. FOR HAVING TO PAYLESS
SECURITY DEPOSIT -- IN ADDITION
TO THIS LEGISLATION SB TWO TWO
TWO BY SENATOR HILL THAT WE
PASSED EARLIER THIS MONTH.
IN FORCES THIS PROVISION BY
PROHIBITING DISCRIMINATION IN
THE RENTAL MARKET BASED ON
VETERAN OR MILITARY STATUS.
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS IS
ME AS MADE IT PARTICULARLY
DIFFICULT. FOR SERVICE MEMBERS
TO AFFORD THE UP FRONT COST OF
MOVING INTO A RENTAL UNIT IN OUR
STATE.
WITH MILITARY BARRACKS BECOMING
SCARCER THE NEED FOR SERVICE
MEMBERS TO FIND HOUSING IN THE
COMMUNITY WHERE THEY ARE STATION
IS INCREASINGLY COMMON.
ALL THE SERVICE MEMBERS RECEIVE
A BASIC ALLOWANCE FOR HOUSING
FROM THE MILITARY IT IS OFTEN
NOT ENOUGH TO COVER THE I'M
UPFRONT COSTS.
OF RUNNING IN CALIFORNIA.
I WILL SERVICE MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA RECEIVE A LARGER
ALLOWANCE TO THE DUE TO THE
HIGHER COST OF LIVING.
IT CAN TAKE MONTHS FOR THAT
ALLOWANCE INCREASE TO TAKE A
FACT.
WHEN SERVICE MEMBERS MOVED HERE
FROM OTHER STATES?
THEY'RE FORCED TO TAKE OUT LOANS
ANOTHER FORM OF CREDIT TO PAY
FOR THAT EXERCISE YOUR DEPOSIT
IN FIRST MONTH'S RENT.
THIS BILL WILL ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE MAKE SURE OUR ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICE MEMBERS ARE ABLE TO
AFFORD RENT WHILE SERVING THIS
BILL SUPPORTED BY A VARIETY OF
VETERANS GROUPS WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THOUGH TODAY.
THAT YOU CENTER GLAZER MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
GROW.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I
VISITED TWENTY NINE PALMS MARINE
CORPS BASE THAT WE HAVE DOWN
THERE AND BECAUSE OF IBM BEES IN
THE WAY THAT OUTSIDE MARKET
HOUSING IS GOING THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF HOUSING BACK THERE FOR
THOSE MILITARY PERSONNEL THERE.
SERVING IN THAT AREA AND I KNOW
THIS WILL BE A GREAT -- ASSET
FOR THEM SO THANK YOU SIR FOR
THIS BILL AND I'M HONORED TO
SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THING IN HER NONE SURVEYS WHICH
LET'S CLOSE THANK THIS SENATOR
FROM BAKERSFIELD FOR HER SERVICE
AND HER SUPPORT AND ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU SIR MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE I IS
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM FORTY SIX
CENTER ATKINS MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOR FIFTY ONE BY
SENATOR ATKINS AN ACT RELATING
TO TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
CENTER ATKINS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT.
AND I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB FOUR
FIFTY ONE THIS MEASURE WOULD
CREATE AN INCENTIVE FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THROUGH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A TAX CREDIT
FOR THE PRESERVATION AND
REHABILITATION OF HISTORIC
BUILDINGS IN CALIFORNIA.
IF ENACTED CALIFORNIA WOULD JOIN
THIRTY FIVE OTHER STATES WITH
STATE HISTORIC TAX CREDIT
PROGRAMS.
A STATE HISTORIC TAX CREDIT
WOULD HELP TO STIMULATE LOCAL
ECONOMIES AND REVITALIZED
DOWNTOWN AREAS THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE.
BY ENABLING CALIFORNIANS TO
LEVERAGE EXISTING FEDERAL
REHABILITATION TAX CREDITS IT'S
OUR HOPE THAT THIS MEASURE WILL
PROVIDE THE EXTRA INCENTIVE
NECESSARY TO STIMULATE PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE INVESTMENTS.
WHILE ALSO BUILDING CIVIC PRIDE
AS WE CELEBRATE OUR HERITAGE AND
PRESERVE CALIFORNIA'S PASSED I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER ATKINS MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
THERE IS MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES AYE BILL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
CARILLO.
BY CHIANG.
BY DODD.
BY THE RUSSELL.
I GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER AYE GROVE.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO -- TADO.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
I LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
HI SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
STONE.
BY HAMBURG IA CATHY.
I WINNER.
AYE WILK.
BY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BELL.
HI [inaudible]
BRADFORD BY [inaudible]
WITH SOME [inaudible]
MORE LUCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY.
EYES THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS RENTING A LITTLE PAUSE
NOT A BREAK THE DON'T LEAVE JUST
A PAUSE
WITH CALLS WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH FILE ITEM FIFTY
ONE SENATOR CHIANG.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVIE ON A FILE
ITEM FIFTY TWO SENATOR UMBERG
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS BY [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
NO[inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
I THIRTY ONE KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY THREE SENATOR DORADO
MITER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS BY [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
NUMBER.
WE HAVE TO MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME
[inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
NUMBER.
EYES NINETEEN KNOWS FIFTEEN THE
MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR RAZA MOVES FOR
RECONSIDERATION YES PLEASE -- AS
IT PASSES PARDON ME I'M A LITTLE
TIRED.
THE MEASURE FAILS.
THIRD RAZA IS ASKING FOR
RECONSIDERATION WITHOUT
OBJECTION RECONSIDERATION IS
GRANTED.
EYES THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS.
ZERO EYES OF THANK YOU ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO ALL RIGHT IF THERE IS NO
FURTHER BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS
THE DESK IS CLEAR.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH -- IT WAS OBVIOUSLY A VERY
PRODUCTIVE DAY THANKS TO YOU AND
MEMBERS OF THE FLOOR TEAMS OF
BOTH REPUBLICANS AND THE
DEMOCRATS WE WANT TO THANK YOU --
WE MANAGED TO GET FORTY BILLS
DONE TODAY -- WE ARE DOING QUITE
WELL TOMORROW PROBABLY WILL BE A
A LITTLE.
LONGER -- BUT WE'RE PREPARED TO
TAKE UP THAT WORK IN AND GET
INTO IT AS OF TEN O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING ON MAY TWENTY NINTH.
I WOULD LET YOU KNOW THAT -- WE
ANTICIPATED A HARDER WORK DAY SO
AT FOUR O'CLOCK THERE WILL BE
DINNER -- HERE -- YOU'RE WELCOME
TO STAY AND AND ENJOY EACH
OTHER'S COMPANY AND ENJOYED
DINNER ARE WE WILL MAKE SURE --
OTHERS ARE ABLE TO ENJOY THE
MEAL IF YOU.
NEED TO LEAVE BUT I HAVEN'T SAID
THAT WE WILL RECONVENE TOMORROW.
MAY TWENTY NINTH WEDNESDAY AT
TEN AM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER ATKINS WE STAND
ADJOURNED TO SEE EVERYBODY
TOMORROW AT TEN AM